NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
HEARING- A FEW REMINDERS WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL MASKS
ARE REQUIRED AT ALL TIMES HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITAL AND THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION OUTSIDE.
TESTIMONY CAN BE PROVIDED IN
PERSON AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION LOCATED OUTSIDE THE
CAPITAL NEAR THE NORTH STEPS
AND BY PHONE. THE NUMBER FOR
PHONE TESTIMONY IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE PEN IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. THIS NUMBER IS POSTED ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND
ALSO APPEARS ON THE VIDEO FEED.
ONCE THE PRIMARY SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES HAVE
TESTIFIED I WILL CALL FOR PHONE
TESTIMONY TO REDUCE DELAYS
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WILL BE
COMBINED IN A SINGLE Q. PLEASE
NOTE THAT THE HEARING WILL
ADJOURN BEFORE ONE PM. AS THE
ROOM MUST BE CLEARED BY ONE
TESTIMONY LIMITS MAY BE APPLIED
IF NECESSARY TO COMPLETE THE
AGENDA ON TIME. THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES ARE PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT I AM TEN AB FOUR FOUR
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
ITEM ELEVEN AB FOUR THIRTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON AN
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB FIVE ZERO FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
WILL GO AHEAD AND START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND I'D LIKE TO
CALL UP- THE FIRST ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGAIN-
CURRY. NINETEEN AB. TEN EIGHTY
SIX. OKAY THANK YOU.
IT'S
CRITICAL TO MEETING OUR
EXISTING CLIMATE AND AIR
QUALITY GOALS. HOWEVER THE
STATE LACKS A COORDINATED
STRATEGY AND FUNDING PLAN TO
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFICIAL RE USE
OF THESE ORGANIC MATERIALS.
BENEFICIAL RE USE OF SUCH AS
COMPOST BIO ENERGY OR SOIL
AMENDMENTS CAN SUPPORT NET
CARBON EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMICAL
BENEFITS. A STRATEGIC PLAN ON
ORGANIC WASTE MANAGEMENT WILL
PROVIDE LONG TERM TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL END DATE INFORM
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
SUPPORT INCENTIVIZE THE
BENEFICIAL RE USE OF ORGANIC
WASTE. IT WILL CONSIDER AND
BALANCE THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF
LOCAL COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY EXPOSED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION
INCLUDING WILDFIRE SMOKE. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OUR
NICK LAPIS FROM CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE AND JULIA LEVIN
FROM CALIFORNIA BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE LET THAT SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON. MORNING THIS
CYNICAL OFFICE OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE- THIS BILL HAS
BEEN BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
BEFORE NEXT PASSED WITH A
UNANIMOUS VOTE SO I WON'T GO
INTO TOO MUCH DETAIL BUT IT
BASICALLY ALL IT DOES IS TELL
THE STATE TO DEVELOP. A CROSS
SECTOR IMPLEMENTATION PLAN FOR
AGAMIC VOICE YES WE HAVE A
PRETTY DECENT PLAN FOR
FORGIVENESS FOR WAYS TO WASTE
UNDER- SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
BUT THERE'S NO COORDINATION
BETWEEN THAT MATERIAL AND
AGRICULTURAL MATERIAL PROPERTY
TO USE YOUR BIO SOLIDS FOR SHE
WASTE. AND EACH OF THOSE HAS
FOUND REGULATORY AGENCIES THAT
OWN- TARGET THE TERMS
LEGISLATIVE REQUIREMENTS- AND
ALL THIS BILL SIZES LET'S
COORDINATE THOSE LET'S SEE IF
WE CAN MANAGE AND TOGETHER
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN. BUILD
HEALTHY SOILS AND USE THOSE
PRODUCTS AND OFFICIALLY-
INSTEAD OF. DEALING WITH ALL OF
THEM ASILO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
SURELY A LETTER WITH A
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WILL BE
KEPT CALIFORNIA GENERATES
MILLIONS OF TONS OF ORGANIC
WASTE A YEAR AND MOST OF THAT
WASTE CURRENTLY IS BURNED
EITHER IN WILDFIRES OR
CONTROLLED BURNS OR ITS
LANDFILLS FOURTH LEFT TO
DECOMPOSE AND ALL OF THESE ARE
SOURCES A SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS THE MOST DAMAGING
THE FOR THE CLIMATE. THEY'RE
ALSO LARGE SOURCES OF AIR
POLLUTION AND WATER POLLUTION
AB TEN EIGHTY SIX WITH
XCELERATED TRANSITIONED TO
BENEFICIAL RE USE OF THIS
ORGANIC WASTE AND WILL HELP US
ACHIEVE A CIRCULAR ECONOMY
WHERE INSTEAD OF THINKING OF
THIS MATERIAL AS WASTE IT
BECOMES THE SOURCE OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY ORGANIC SOIL AMENDMENTS
AND OTHER BENEFICIAL PRODUCTS
IT WILL ALSO HELP TO CREATE
JOBS AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO FOR ALL
THESE REASONS WE THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR CURRY FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AND URGE THE COMMITTEE. TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I BELIEVE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. OUR NEXT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON THIS
BILL. CASEY NINE ANYONE IN THE
REMOTE TESTING. LOCATION. OKAY
THERE ISN'T- OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES OF WE
WILL BE TAKING UP COMMENTS FROM
WITNESSES BOTH IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION JUST PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN EIGHTY SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM MINE SEVENTY TWO.
ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JULIE ALLEN ASKEY BOTTLE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NINE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KELLY BOYD BE
SOMEBODY CLEAN ENERGY IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TEN EIGHTY SIX.
SB JUST A MOMENT FOR NEXT
COMING. ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING NATALIE KNOCKED ON
BEHALF OF RETHINK WASTE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SELF. AND ONE
MORE MOMENT WE DO HAVE TO MORE
COMMON. NINE SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MARK LANTE RESOURCE RECOVERY
COALITION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. AND NINE SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR MIND GO AHEAD. AT ALL I'M
CALLING FOR THE AS AND CHAD
MAYES A. B. AB FOUR FOUR TWO.
WE ARE NOT DOING THIS TESTIMONY
WE ARE WE ARE ON AB TEN EIGHTY
SIX THAT THOSE OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE ACCEPTING RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU- I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. MISTER
SMITH MATHIS THANK YOU MADAM
SHARE- PRECIADO THE AUTHOR'S
WORK IN THIS AND WOULD LIKE
THAT ON AS A JOINT AUTHOR WITH
YOU TO ENSURE BIPARTISAN-
COALITION ON THIS MATTER- TO
ENSURE THAT THIS BILL MOST FOR.
IF YOU'LL HAVE ME. I'D LOVE TO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CRISTINA
SOME OF ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS CASEY NINE- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- WELL I GUESS
THIRD TIME'S A CHARM ON THIS
BILL BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WHEN
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL BE
VOTING ON THIS GREAT BUT THANK
YOU FOR PRESENTING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I JUST WANTED TO
THANK ALSO YOU'RE A COMMITTEE
STAFFER HELPING OUT. PRECIADO
THANK YOU. K. NEXT STEP- AB
FIVE FIVE NINE. MY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA. WILL I MEAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB FIVE FIVE NINE WILL
ADD NEW VOICES TO THE SAN%
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY BOARD
RE FRAME THE FOCUS OF THE
COUNTY RESIDENTS SEATS ENSURE
THAT THE BOARD IS FULLY SEATED
AND MAKE OTHER CHANGES TO ALIGN
ITS OPERATION AS A STATE AGENCY
ALONGSIDE OTHER CONSERVANCY.
PUBLIC PARKS IN AND AROUND
URBAN AREAS ARE CRUCIAL FOR
BOTH MENTAL HEALTH AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCE THE PANDEMIC HAS
MADE CLEAR BOTH THE NEED FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE SPACES. AS WELL AS THE
SEVERE LACK OF ACCESS MANY OF
OUR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
HAVE. RESIDENTS AND UNDERSERVED
NEIGHBORHOODS ACROSS FRESNO AND
MADERA COUNTIES FACED SUCH A
PREDICAMENT. THANKFULLY THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER VALLEY
CONSERVANCY'S MISSION TO
ACQUIRE LANDS ALONG THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER TO CONSERVE
VALUABLE HABITAT AND DEVELOP
THESE LANDS FOR THE PUBLIC'S
BENEFIT IS A CURATOR THIS LACK
OF ACCESS. HOWEVER TO PROVIDE
THE MAXIMUM BENEFIT TO ALL IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT DIVERSE AND
MARGINALIZED VOICES AND
PERSPECTIVES HELP GUIDE THE
DECISIONS OF THE CONSERVANCY IN
AN EQUITABLE MANNER. AB FIVE
FIVE NINE EXPANDS THE
CONSERVANCY BOARD TO INCLUDE
THESE NEW VOICES TO REPRESENT
THE BROAD GEOGRAPHIC AND
CULTURAL DIVERSITY THAT THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER PARKWAY SERVICE.
I AM JOINED TODAY BY WITNESSES
JOHN SHELTON THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER CONSERVANCY AND SHARON
WEAVER THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
PARKWAY AND CONSERVATION TRUST.
THANK YOU CAN WE HAVE THE FIRST
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. THIS IS
JOHN SHELTON FROM THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY WE
ARE NOT OFFICIALLY TAKING
POSITION AS A STATE AGENCY. I
AM HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS- I AM ALLOWED TO SAY
THAT THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY I BELIEVE HAS BEEN
DOING VERY IMPORTANT WORK AND I
DO APPRECIATE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THE RAMBLERS AND HIS STAFF
EFFORT TO- TO WORK ON OUR OUR
BEHALF. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THE SHERIN WEAVER DOWN WHAT HE
RIVER PARKWAY IN CONFIRMATION
CLASS AND I THAT'S WHEN I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RANDY LAST FOR
BRINGING FORWARD THAT ANY PARTY
AND CHANGE FOR THE FAMILY IN
ORDER TO THURMOND THINKING ABLE
AND LEGISLATION IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME AS A RESIDENT
OF THE TOWN MUST BE VALLEY
ABOUT THE GOVERNING BOARD OF
THE FAMILY HE NEVER CONSIDERED
ANYTHING IT BETTER REPRESENT
THAT POPULATION OF THE FAMILY
THE DALLAS. AND THE CHANGES
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL WILL HELP
ACCOMPLISH THAT- OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS WE'VE HAD AN OPEN
SEAT IN MADERA COUNTY HAS RIGHT
NOW THAT EACH ROTATE BETWEEN A
LANDOWNER ON THE FAMILY MEMBER
AND YOU HAVE A GREAT SUCCESS OF
THE WORK OF THE FAMILY MEMBER
CONSERVANCY AND OUR
ORGANIZATIONTHE RIVER CRAFT
OVER THE YEARS- THERE JUST
AREN'T THAT MANY. OTHER HONORS
ON ON THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
WITHIN THE PARK THEY REACH SO
WE REALLY APPRECIATE OF THE
CHANGES THAT ARE- ARAMBULA HAS
PROPOSED HERE AND WE THINK THEY
WILL BE BENEFICIAL- FOR HELPING
THE CONSERVANCY DATE COULD.
WORK INTO THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE ANY WITNESS AND
I. OKAY OKAY NOW THE NEXT I'D
LIKE OF TWO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ON
THIS BILL. YOU SEE NONE OF DO
WE HAVE ANY. WITNESSES AT THE
REMOTE TESTING LOCATION.
REMEMBER WHAT TESTIMONY. THE
CAN OF COVERT SORRY. ANY
OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE FIVE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. NINE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS KIM
DELFINO- REPRESENTING AT THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
AND DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS IS
PAUL YOUR BEHALF OF FRESNO
COUNTY FRESNO COUNTY BOARD
SUPERVISORS VOTED YESTERDAY TO
OPPOSE AB FIVE FIVE NINE AS
SOON AS I WAS NOTIFIED TO LET
THE OTHER STAFF KNOWS WELLS
COMMITTEE STAFF. I'LL MAKE SURE
THAT ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
GET THE COUNTY'S LETTER WHEN IT
IS FINALIZED- MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THE COUNTIES OPPOSITION WILL
TOUCH UPON POINTS THREE AND
FOUR IN YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
AND POSSIBLY A CIVIL SEVERAL
OTHER POINTS. THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THREE
CELERY HELP IMPLEMENT
REPRESENTING AMERICAN
WHITEWATER AS THE CALIFORNIA
STEWARDSHIP DIRECTOR IN
CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR ALLIANCE AS
A MEMBER ORGANIZATION. WE ARE
VOICING SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
MISTER MATHIS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK ON THE
SAN JOAQUIN- CONSERVANCY EIGHT
AS A COLLEGE STUDENT AT FRESNO
STATE GO DAWGS- SPENT SOME TIME
DOING RIVER CLEANUP IN THOSE
THINGS- BUT MR AMIN I. BRUGADA
ASK YOU- ONE ON THE
APPOINTMENTS WHAT WHAT IS THE
PROCESS YOU'RE LOOKING AT HERE-
I KNOW A LOT OF US DID- KIND OF
CONCERNED WHEN WE'RE ALLOWING
THE GOVERNOR TO MAKE
APPOINTMENTS IN LOCAL AREAS-
VERSUS THE LOCALS- DOING THAT'S
WHAT IS THE PROCESS FOR THIS
WERE YOU LOOKING AT IS THEIR
CRITERIA- TO THESE
APPOINTMENTS- WOULD YOU INDULGE
OF SOME AND I HAVE A FEW OTHER
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS. SURE WE
ARE TRYING TO WITH THESE TWO
NEW SEATS TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
BRINGING A BROAD AND DIVERSE
AND CULTURALLY- MORE
APPROPRIATE REPRESENTATION ON
TO THE BOARD CURRENTLY WE DO
NOT HAVE A DESIGNATED SEATS FOR
OUR NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES AND-
SINCE THEY WERE THE ORIGINAL
STEWARDS FOR THESE LANDS I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THEM
TO HAVE A SEAT TEND TO SAY AND
HOW WE PRESERVE AND CONTINUE
THESE LANDS. IN ADDITION TO
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED HOW WE
CAN HAVE A SOCIAL JUSTICE SEATS
SOMEONE WHO CAN MAKE SURE THAT
WERE TAKING CARE OF THE LANDS
AS WELL WE TRY TO IDENTIFY
THOSE TWO SEATS AS WELL AS TO
BRING CONSISTENCIES ACROSS
CONSERVANCIES SO THAT WE HAVE
SIMILAR STATUTES IN THE BANKING
ACT HI COMMITMENTS THAT WE MADE
TO THE I UNDERSTAND THE DESIRE
FOR THE SEATS AND I
EXPRESSIONIST BACK THE ADDING
THE- THE TRAVEL PORTION TO IT-
BUT THAT MY BIGGER QUESTION IS
WHY HAVE THE GOVERNOR. APPOINT
THE SEAT VERSUS HAVING THE-
CURRENT COMMITTEE- LOOK AT THAT
APPOINTMENT PROCESS VERSUS THE
GOVERNOR WHY TAKE THAT ROUTE-
JUST AS WE HAVE TALKED WITH THE
COMMITTEE SPECIFICALLY WE'RE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD I WILL SAY THAT THIS
ORIGINAL CONSERVANCY WAS
STARTED IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO.
AND SINCE WERE NOW COMING UP ON
NEARLY THIRTY YEARS THAT THIS
CONSERVANCY HAS BEEN- IN
STATUTE I'D LIKE TO SEE SOME
RESULTS ALSO THAT THE BROADER
PUBLIC CONCERN. TO REALIZE THE
POTENTIAL AND ACCESS THAT YOU
WERE SPEAKING ABOUT AT THE
BEGINNING OF YOUR COMMENTS HERE
TODAY. NOW MY CONCERN IS THAT
THE- LAW IS PICKING VERSES THE
GOVERNOR PICKING. ON IS
OBVIOUSLY A CONCERN- FOR THAT
PROCESS THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE FOR YOU. IN AN OBVIOUSLY
IS LEGISLATORS WE UNDERSTAND
THIS BUT FOR THE FOR THE PUBLIC
RECORD AND SO THE PUBLIC
LISTENING AND OBSERVING- CAN
YOU EXPLAIN- WHY THE SWITCH.
FOR THE- BAGLEY KEENE OPEN
MEETING ACT RATHER THAN THE
BROWN ACT- AND WHY THAT SWITCH
IS NEEDED. JUST JUST FOR THE
RECORD FOR THOSE WHO DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT IS SO THEY
CAN HEAR PUBLICLY CONSERVANCIES
ARE STATE AGENCIES. AND
CURRENTLY ALL CONSERVANCY'S
EXCEPT FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER CONSERVANCY CONDUCT
BUSINESS UNDER THE BAGLEY KEENE
OPEN MEETING ACT WHETHER OR NOT
EXPLICITLY STATED IN THE
ESTABLISHING ACT. AS BAGLEY
KEENE PROCEDURES GOVERN STATE
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS IT IS
SENSIBLE TO RECLASSIFY THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY UNDER
THESE PROVISIONS. SOMEWHAT BOTH
THE PUBLIC SEE WHAT WOULD BE
THE DIFFERENCE THEY WOULD SEE
IN THAT. FROM FROM A PUBLIC
PERSPECTIVE FOR SOMEONE THAT
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND THIS WE'RE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH MORE
DETAILS TO YOUR OFFICE ON AYE I
KNOW I'M JUST SAYING FOR THE
PUBLIC. I GET IT BUT WE'RE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH MORE
DETAILS. FANTASTIC THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS
YOU SEE NINE OF I'D LIKE TO
BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD I'D LIKE
TO GO AHEAD AND TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM. SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS
RIVAS. HI I MEAN HERE LARA CHAU
FRIEDMAN HERE GARCIA MATHIS
MCCARTY MURATSUCHI SAY OUR
SOFTWARE YOUR DOCTOR WOULD.
STONE STONE HERE. OKAY THANK
YOU- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
FOR OKAY ALL SECOND EVENT- SO
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
SECRETARY CAME PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I DON'T TO AB FIVE FIFTY
NINE BY ARAMBULA THE MOTION IS
TO PASS A REFER TO GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE. MEMBERS
RIVAS I RIVERSIDE FLORA. FLOOR
NOT VOTING CHAU FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA MATHIS I'M
GONNA HOLD OFF ON MY VOTE UNTIL
I SPEAK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
WE'LL SEE ABOUT SUPPORTING NGO.
MCCARTY RIGHT THIRTY THEY ARE
TELL VOTING THEY ARE NOT VOTING
STONE RIGHT STONE I WOULD.
THREE ZERO K. THREE ZERO WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN AND ALLOW
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU MR
ARAMBULA. K. NEXT UP WE HAVE AB
TWENTY ONE I'M BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REBEKAH BAUR CAN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
IT'S GOOD TO BE HERE FIRST
THING IN THE MORNING- FIRST I
WANT TO THANK THE STAFF FOR
THEIR INCREDIBLE HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL IN THE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE OFFICE- WOULD MAKE
CLEAR OF ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TODAY
WHICH I HAD A RIGHT TO CURE.
AND CLARIFY AND THE INTENT OF
THE PENALTIES COLLECTED AND
WHERE THEY WILL GO AT THESE
AMENDMENTS MAKE THE BILL
STRONGER AND GET US TO WHERE WE
ARE TRYING TO GET TO WHICH IS
PREVENTION. OF WILDFIRES. TODAY
I AM PRESENTING AB TWENTY ONE A
BILL THAT AIMS TO PROTECT ALL
CALIFORNIANS BY ENTERING
PROACTIVE INSPECTION OF
ELECTRICAL LINES FOR DANGEROUS
OVERGROWN VEGETATION OR
OVERHANGING TREE BRANCHES. OUR
STATE FACES DIRE FIRE RISKS
FIVE OF THE SIX LARGEST
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY
HAPPENED IN TWENTY TWENTY ALONE
ACCORDING TO CAL FIRE LAST YEAR
WE ENTERED NINE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED WILDFIRES BURNING OVER
FOUR POINT TWO MILLION ACRES IN
KILLING THIRTY THREE PEOPLE.
THIS HEIGHTENED RISK OF FIRE IS
A RESULT OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
ONLY EXACERBATED. BY THE
DECADES THE VEGETATION OF
MISMANAGEMENT BY THE I. O. U.'S.
WE NEED TO PUT SAFETY BEFORE
PROFITS AND IN THE FACE OF THIS
CRISIS WE HAVE TO INCREASE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE REGULATIONS
ALREADY ON THE BOX. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE CAMPFIRE DECIMATED
THE TOWN OF PARADISE TRAGICALLY
KILLING EIGHTY SIX PEOPLE THE
FIRE WAS CALLS CAUSED BY FAULTY
TRANSMISSION LINES IGNITED BY
OVERGROWN VEGETATION NEARBY.
THE DESTRUCTION AND LOSS OF
LIFE IN THE TOWN OF PARADISE
AND MANY OTHERS FORCED
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST I. O. U.
P. JEANNIE TO FILE FOR
BANKRUPTCY A SECOND TIME.
DURING THE BANKRUPTCY
PROCEEDINGS IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
NINETEEN A COURT APPOINTED
MONITOR- THE JUDGE ALSO PUT
APPOINTED IN THE- CASE RELATING
TO THE SAN BRUNO EXPLOSION
NOTICED HUNDREDS OF INSTANCES
WHERE PG&E CONTRACTORS HAD
FAILED TO TREAT TREES THAT POSE
POTENTIAL WILDFIRE RISKS. HE
REPORTED THAT THE INSPECTIONS
AND COVERED SUBSTANTIAL RECORD
KEEPING ISSUES AS WELL TO THE
ID'S CREDIT SOME OF THIS
APPEARED TO BE A FAILURE. OF
RECORD KEEPING AND THE
INDIVIDUALS TASKED WITH
MAINTAINING THE LINES HAD
FAILED TO DO SO DESPITE
REPORTING THEY HAD. AND THIS
JUST HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR US
TO HAVE INSPECTORS ON THE
GROUND THAT ARE LOOKING AT WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN OUR COMMUNITIES
ENSURING THE VEGETATION IS
MANAGEMENT IS HAPPENING AND
THAT WE ARE SAFE FROM THIS RISK
AS IT RELATES TO WILD FIRES. I
KNOW MANY OF YOU PROBABLY SAW
THE REPORT I SAW JUST WEEKS AGO
ON THE TOXIC NATURE OF THE AIR
THAT IS COMING OUT OF THESE
WILDFIRES IT IS BOTH A RESTORE
HEALTH RESTORE LIVES AND
RESTORE COMMUNITIES AND ONE
THAT WE AS A LEGISLATURE. NEED
TO TAKE SERIOUSLY AND THAT IS
WHAT THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO DO.
JOINING ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL ON THE PHONE IS NOT
BELT TRAUMA FROM THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE. AND PATRICK COLLINS
FROM THE NAPA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. MANAGER CAN
RETURN TO THE- YES FIRST
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MATTHEW BELTRAME WELL
I'M AN ASSISTANT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE I
SPEAK TODAY ON BEHALF OF
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY
O'MALLEY WITH- WHO SPONSORS
THIS BELT WILDFIRES HAVE HAD A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON CALIFORNIANS
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS. SEVEN
OF THE STATE'S DEADLIEST FIRES
HAVE OCCURRED SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN KILLING OVER A
HUNDRED PEOPLE AND BURNING
MILLIONS OF ACRES MANY OF THESE
FIRE SHARE A COMMON TRAIT THEY
WERE CAUSED BY ELECTRICAL
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
EQUIPMENT MOST TRAGIC EXAMPLE
TO DATE OCCURRED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHEN A FIRE CAUSED BY
POORLY MAINTAINED EQUIPMENT
SWEPT THROUGH THE TOWN OF
PARADISE KILLING OVER EIGHTY OF
ITS RESIDENTS. FIRES OF THIS
KIND COULD HAPPEN IN MANY
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
INCLUDING MY OWN ALAMEDA COUNTY
WHICH HAS SIGNIFICANT WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT OR THE LACK THEREOF
IS A BIG PART OF THE PROBLEM
FOR EXAMPLE IS REALLY KEEN
FOCUS OF THE FEDERAL JUDGE
OVERSEEING P. GENIES CRIMINAL
PROBATION HE FOUND IT P. GENIES
PERFORMANCE WITH RESPECT TO
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WAS QUOTE
DISMAL AND RECOMMENDED THAT
MEASURES BE TAKEN BY STATE
AUTHORITIES TO IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES FOR SUCH
FAILURES. THIS BILL IS A SMALL
STEP TOWARD MEETING THESE
CONCERNS HE MAKES ANY PERSON
WHO OWNS OR OPERATES ELECTRICAL
TRANSMISSION OR DISTRIBUTION
LINES SUBJECT TO CIVIL
PENALTIES FOR EITHER FAILING TO
MAINTAIN ADEQUATE VEGETATION
CLEARANCE OR FOR CAUSING ANY
WILDFIRE AS A RESULT OF THAT
FILURE THE PENALTIES WOULD BE
SET BY A JUDGE AFTER TRIAL
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT A LIST OF
FACTORS. THE POSSIBILITY OF
CIVIL FINES OF THIS SORT
ACCOMPLISHES TWO GOALS FIRST IT
CREATES AN ADDITIONAL REAL
WORLD RETURNS FOR OWNERS OF
UTILITY LINES FOR FAILING TO
ENGAGE. IN REQUIRED VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. SECOND IT UP FOR
LAW ENFORCED AN ADDITIONAL
MEASURE TO ADDRESS IN ON
PROBLEM ONE THAT NOT. FELONY
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION WHICH IS
THE ONLY REAL TOOL CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE. WE ACKNOWLEDGE AND
APPRECIATE THE WORK DONE BY
REGULATORS INCLUDING THE CPUC.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THESE
EFFORTS MUST BE SUPPLEMENTED BY
THE POSSIBILITY OF CIVIL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION IN ORDER TO
ADEQUATELY PROTECT CALIFORNIANS
IN THE YEARS TO COME. WE URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS PATRICK COLLINS SIMON
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN THE
NAPA COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND SPEAKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF DISTRICT ATTORNEY
ALLISON HALEY. I AM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN UP EXPERIENCED TWO
MAJOR WILDFIRES ALISON PARTRICK
WHICH STARTED BECAUSE THE KING
TREES BLUE AND PG&E POWER LINES
WHICH IGNITED THE DRY FUELS
BELOW. THE PARTRICK FIRE
COMBINED WITH SEVERAL OTHER
FIRES IN SONOMA COUNTY MANY OF
WHICH WERE ALSO STARTED BY
DYING TREES BLOWING IN A PDF
POWER. THE FIRES BURNED SIXTY
THOUSAND ACRES DESTROYED
HUNDREDS OF STRUCTURES.
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS MYSELF
INCLUDED WERE EVACUATED DURING
THE FIRES. IN SIX PEOPLE DIED
IN THE ATLAS FIRE. AFTER A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION CAL FIRE
FOR THE CASE OUR OFFICE FOR
PROSECUTION. HOWEVER THE
EXISTING REVENUE HAD A HAND
BOTH CRIMINAL AND CIVIL WERE
INSUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS SCOPE
OF THE PROBLEM. CRIMINAL
CHARGES FOR THE USE OF PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE SECTIONS REQUIRE
PROOF BEYOND REASONABLE DOUBT
WHICH IS OFTEN VERY DIFFICULT
STANDARD IN WILDFIRE CASES.
LIKE THESE HELPFULLY CONVICTION
ON THE MISDEMEANOR CHARGES
AGAINST THE CORPORATE ENTITY IN
THIS CASE P. JEANNIE. A LITTLE
PUNISHMENT AN EXISTING CIVIL
REMEDIES ARE LIMITED TO AN
UNFAIR COMPETITION ACTION WHICH
SET THE MAXIMUM CIVIL PENALTIES
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER VIOLATION. THE
CURRENT BILL PROVIDES A TOOL
THAT WE WISH WE HAD HAD WHEN
CONSIDERING WHETHER AND HOW TO
PROSECUTE THESE VIOLATIONS
DURING FIRES. I PROVIDE THE
MIDDLE PASSED THE STYLISH IS
DETERRENCE IMPLEMENTS ADEQUATE
PENALTIES AND IN PARTICULAR.
THE PENALTY OF A THOUSAND
DOLLARS UP TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER ACRE OF LAND BURN AS A
RESULT OF THE VIOLATION OF
TITLE. IT'S OFTEN DIFFICULT TO
PATROL AND MONITOR POTENTIAL
VIOLATIONS PRIOR TO A FIRE MAN
AFTER FIRE CAN BE DIFFICULT TO
ESTABLISH HOW LONG THE
VIOLATIONS GOING ON PRIOR TO
THE FIRE. IN FAIRNESS
DEFENDANTS THE BILL GIVES THE
COURT THE DISCRETION TO TAKE IN
ALL RELEVANT CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN
DECIDING ON THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
OF PENALTIES PROVIDE ALEUTIAN-
AS MR BALL SHARMA SAID WE
KNOWLEDGE APPRECIATE OR CAL
FIRE IN CPUS. TPC DEERE THIS
AREA TO MINISTRY TO OPPOSE
VIOLATIONS BUT SOMETIMES. AS IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CERTAIN
VIOLATIONS NECESSITATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVOLVEMENT AND
POTENTIALLY PROSECUTION. WE
FILL THIS BILL WILL GIVE OUR
OFFICE A TOOLS THAT WE NEED TO
AFFECTED ACROSS THE STATE. SO
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IPHONE
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
NEXT STOP- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS SCOTT WHAT'S YOUR
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
OF THE OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES AND
THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS. I WOULD
SUBMIT TO THE COMMITTEE THAT
THIS BILL WOULD BE A VERY
REASONABLE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. HAD A PRETTY
REDUCE FIVE YEARS AGO. BUT
GIVEN WHAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
DONE. ALREADY THIS BILL IS
COMPLETELY UNNECESSARY ANY
DANGERS MAILLET MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA. SPECIFICALLY.
RESPOND TO LEGISLATION BY
SENATOR DODD IN TWENTY NINETEEN
S. B. TWO FORTY SEVEN WHICH
COMPLETELY CHANGED THE
COMPLIANCE PROCESS FOR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT THIS IS
CRITICAL FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
UNDERSTAND IN THE OLD DAYS
CONTRACTORS WORKING FOR PGD
WOULD GO UP. VERY GRETED OF
WHAT THEY WERE GOING TO DO FOR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT. THEY
WOULD PERFORM THE WORK THEY
WOULD THEN INSPECT THEIR OWN
WORK IN THE U. TOLD HE WOULD
COME IN AND SPOT ON IT TO WORK.
INTO FORTY SEVEN WE PROPOSED
WITH CAL FIRE TAKE OVER THOSE
COMPLIANCE INSPECTIONS INSTEAD
OF THE COMPANIES. WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE DO YOU TO DO
INSTEAD BECAUSE QUALIFIER
DIDN'T WANT THE RESPONSIBILITY.
WAS TO HAVE THE P. YOU SEE
SELECT INDEPENDENT EVALUATORS.
EXPERTS SO NOW THE PROCESS IS
THE COMPANY SUBMITS ITS
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLAN THE
CLOSER IS EXHAUSTIVE REVIEW
PROCESS OF THE COMMISSION BIG
GO OUT AND EXECUTE THE PLAN AND
THEN THEY HAVE TO SELECT
EVALUATORS CHOSEN BY THE P. YOU
SEE TO GO TO CERTIFY THAT THEY
HAVE COMPLIED THAT'S WHY THIS
IS FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED IN
ADDITION THE AUTHOR FAILED TO
MENTION THE P. JEANNIE WAS
FALLING. OVER TWO BILLION
DOLLARS BY THE P. YOU SEE IN BY
THE FEDERAL COURT. FOR
VIOLATIONS. SO THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS KNOWING THIS IS
UNNECESSARY IT'S DANGEROUS
BECAUSE THE DEFINITION OF
CONTROL OF THE PROPERTY. WOULD
EXTEND TO MY MEMBERS PERFORMING
THE WORK IN OVERSEEING THE WORK.
SO I'M A CONTRACTOR GOES UP TO
DO VEGETATION MANAGEMENT MY
MEMBERS OVERSEE THE WORK IS
FOREMAN AND SUPERINTENDENTS.
SOME DA THE DOESN'T KNOW.
SOMETHING FROM SHINE ALL COMES
IN AND SAYS YOU DIDN'T DO A
GOOD ENOUGH JOB AND IN MY
MEMBERS GETTING FINED A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. FINALLY I
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT AND
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
SUBMIT THE DATA POST HEARING.
THEY'RE ONE OF THE COUNTIES
THAT IS THE WORST. INDEED IN
ISSUING WHAT VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PERMITS. IS A COUNTY
OF ALAMEDA WE HAVE STACKS OF
PERMITS RIGHT NOW WITH THE
SPONSORS OF THIS LEGISLATION
HAVE NOT APPROVED SO OUR CREWS
CAN'T BE OUT THERE RIGHT NOW
MAKING. ALAMEDA COUNTY SAFE FOR
ALL OF THE ABOVE REASONS. THIS
BILL IS A SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF
A PROBLEM THAT YOU WILL
ADDRESSED TWO YEARS AGO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR WELCH- WE
HAVE ONE MORE. WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION BY PHONE OPERATOR
CAN YOU PUT HIM ON THE LINE.
YEAH YEAH IT IS ADAM SMITH
SEVEN CALIFORNIA EDISON URGING
HER NO VOTE ON AB TWENTY ONE AB
TWENTY ONE WOULD UNDO THE
CLARITY OF VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ENFORCEMENT CREATED
BY S. B. NINE A ONE AB TEN
FIFTY FOUR SB TWO FORTY SEVEN
AND ONGOING REGULATORY
PROCEEDINGS. IT WOULD DO THAT
BY GIVING A DUPLICATIVE AND
UNNECESSARY ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY TO THE LOCAL DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND RATHER THAN
ACCELERATING OR INCENTIVIZING
UTILITY VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
THIS BILL WOULD INTERFERE WITH
THAT EXISTING ENFORCEMENT
STRUCTURE ESTABLISHED AND
REINFORCED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
AB TWENTY ONE DUPLICATIVE
ENFORCEMENT SYSTEM WOULD BE
UNCOORDINATED WITH THE EXISTING
EFFORTS OF OUR CORE REGULATIONS
AND I THINK THAT YOU JUST HEARD
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS LEFT IN
ME EVEN MORE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
HAVE BUILT A STRENGTHENED
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK HOLD I'LL
USE ACCOUNTABLE AB TWENTY ONE
IS AN UNNECESSARY DEPARTURE
FROM THE FRAMEWORK YOU WORKED
SO HARD TO CREATE. FOR EXAMPLE
THE LEGISLATURE ADDED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE PC
BUDGET IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
REVIEW AND ENFORCE UTILITY
WILDFIRE WORK WHILE PART SIXTY
DIVISION WHICH IS NOW PART OF
THE PC IS ON TRACK MOVED OUT OF
THE PC WHICH WE THINK WILL
INCREASE IT INDEPENDENT AS AN
AUDITOR ARE YOU VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT THEY ARE THE ONES
WALKING THE LINE. AND OFTEN
SPOTTING ANY PROBLEMS SB NINE
OH ONE YOU KNOW A COUPLE YEARS
BACK ALSO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE THE POTENTIAL DOLLAR
AMOUNT OF FINE IF I USE DON'T
MEET EXPECTATIONS AND YOU KNOW
I'LL USE HAVE ALREADY THE
STRONGEST OF INTENT IS TO MAKE
SURE TREES AND BRANCHES ARE
APPROPRIATELY TRAINED. IF A NON
CONFORMANCE DISCOUNT OF BECAUSE
THE FIRE IS LIKELY UTILITY
SHAREHOLDERS WILL HAVE TO PAY
FOR ANY DAMAGES DIO YOU. RIDLEY
IS ONLY ONE NOTCH ABOVE JUNK
BOND STATUS YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
URGENCY WITH WHICH WE ADDRESS
THE MILLIONS OF TREES WE
OVERSEE AND ON THAT FINAL YEAH
THAT KIND OF FINAL POINT OF
FINANCIAL STABILITY AB TWENTY
ONE WITH UNDERMINE SIGNIFICANT
EFFORTS MADE BY CALIFORNIA
POLICY NUMBER THE LEGISLATURE
INCLUDED TO MAINTAIN INVESTOR
CONFIDENCE. IN THE UTILITIES
FINANCIAL HELP AND OUR
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT IF THE
STAFF BACK BUT IT IS A FACT
WHEN INVESTOR CONFIDENCE TO
ROADS. CUSTOMER COSTS INCREASE
AND FOR THOSE REASONS. EDIT
THEN URGES YOUR NOTEBOOK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- NEXT I'D LIKE
TO OPEN IT TO ANY WITNESSES IN
THE HEARING ROOM. C. NINE DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION. OKAY
THERE ARE NONE OF THE OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR. A SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO. COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF OR OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. TO BE JUST
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE
NUMBERS. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CHRIS
PATTERSON ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC IN OPPOSED TO
THE BILL FOR THE REASONS
STATED. THANK YOU. YOUR. NINE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS NIKOLINA MANDATES
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR SAN
DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU I DO ANY
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS. OKAY
MISS FRIEDMAN. OKAY. THANK YOU
I GUESS I WAS GOING TO ASK FOR
MAYBE YOUR YOUR SPONSOR TO
RESPOND TO THE OPPOSITION'S
COMMENTS BUT I THINK RATHER
THAN DOING THAT GIVEN THE KIND
OF BREATH OF THE- CONCERNED
ABOUT SOME OF THE ISSUES HERE
THAT I'LL JUST SAY THAT I DO
SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE WORKABILITY OF THE
SOLUTION THE NECESSITY OF IT AS
WELL BUT I WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY REALLY. IN RESERVE
MY RIGHT TO NOT SUPPORT IT ON
THE FLOOR- REALLY TO GIVE
ALAMEDA A CHANCE TO MAYBE TALK
TO THE OPPOSITION TO SEE IF
SOMEHOW THEIR CONCERNS YOUR
ALAMEDA'S CONCERNS CAN BE
ADDRESSED- IF THEIR
SHORTCOMINGS WITH THE
INSPECTION PROGRAM IS THEY SEE
IT MAYBE THERE'S A WAY TO
ADDRESS THAT BUT I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT THE I'LL USE OPPOSITION
THEIR ABILITY TO ACTUALLY. KIND
OF DO THIS PROGRAM IN THIS WAY.
THANK YOU. MR FLOOR THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS AND I GUESS MAYBE
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN ANSWER THIS
FOR IT BUT WHERE. AS YOU SEE
WHERE THE HOLES WITH SI PC ON
THEIR OVERSIGHT OF VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. YES I THINK THAT I
AM THE PLACE IT IS BEEN MOST
ILLUSTRATED BEYOND OBVIOUSLY
THE FIRES DEATH AND DESTRUCTION
THAT I TALK ABOUT OPENING WHAT
IS THROUGH JUDGE ALSUP'S OWN
OVERSIGHT OF AND P. JEANNIE
SPECIFICALLY AND THE COURT
ORDERED MONITORING THAT CASE IS
GONE OUT AND SPOT CHECKED. THIS
WORKED OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF ACRES OF LINES SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND SO IT
IS HARD FOR ANY ONE ENTITY TO
UNLESS WITHOUT MASSIVE
RESOURCES DO THE PROPER
OVERSIGHT AND SO PART OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE IS ENSURING
THAT THEIR LOCAL INSPECTORS
THIRTIES OFFICE WHO CAN DO THAT
AND I WANT TO POINT OUT. AND
HOPEFULLY THIS ALSO DRESSES MRS
FRIEDMAN'S COMMENTS BUT ALSO
SOME OF WHAT WE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION THE ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKING TODAY-
DOES PROVIDE A RIGHT TO CURE
AND INSTRUCTS THE DEPARTMENT TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT A REASONABLE
PATHWAY TO RATE TO CURIOUS
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THAT COULD BE
A DIFFERENT TIMELINE.
POTENTIALLY NEED TO GET PERMITS.
AND THAT TAKES TIME- BUT AT THE
RIGHT TO CURE WAS DONE BECAUSE
THE GOAL HERE IS PREVENTION.
AND SO WHAT WE WANT IS LOCAL
INSPECTORS TO COME IN AND SAY
YOU HAVE A RISK HERE GO FIX IT
I HAD. I WANT TO THANK THE I
USE FOR ALL EXTENSIVELY MEETING
WITH ME ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON SAID
TO ME IN OUR MEETING WAS THE
MINUTE WE KNOW THERE'S A
VIOLATION WE GO AND FIX IT.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT HERE. AND
SO THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A LOCAL
INSPECTOR TO SEE A PROBLEM.
NOTIFY THE I'LL USE AND THEN
HAVE IT FIXED WHICH IF THEY DO
IT THER ARE NO FINES AND
THERE'S NO ENFORCEMENT ACTION.
IS THE GOAL. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT SHOULD BE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR STREETS AND
THE MORE INSPECTORS. THE MORE
THIRTIES WE HAVE OUT THERE
DOING THE WORK TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED THE
SAFER COMMUNITIES WILL BE. I'M
KIND OF ON THE- VEIN. LIKE
THERE ARE CERTAIN AREAS WITHIN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
UTILITIES ARE NOT ALLOWED TO GO
ON. ON PRIVATE PROPERTY CERTAIN
RIGHT AWAY JUST BUT THEY'RE
GONNA BE HELD RESPONSIBLE AND
RELIABLE IF SOMETHING GOES DOWN
ON ON THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE. SO
WHATARE WE DOING TO ADDRESS
THAT. SOTHERE IS- LANGUAGE AND
I CAN TURN IT TO MR BELTRAME
WHO CAN SPEAK MORE AS TECHNICAL
EXPERT AND I CAN BUT THERE IS
LANGUAGE THAT DOES ADDRESS. THE
RIGHT TO GO AND FIX ESPECIALLY
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS MISTER
ABOUT COMEDY WANT OUT IN. THE
FACE ON THE LINE FOR. I AM
STARTING THANK YOU. THE ONE
THING I WOULD SAY WITH RESPECT
TO THAT ISSUE IS- THIS IS A
QUESTION OF- IT IN MANY
RESPECTS PROSECUTORIAL
DISCRETION IT BACK
DISCRETIONARY EXERCISE IN THE
RIDING OF DIFFERENT- CONTACTS
IF IT IF IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR.
THE MINISTRY TO REGISTER
REASONS FOR A UTILITY TO CLEAR
VEGETATION FROM A DISTRIBUTION
OR POWER LINES THEN THAT'S NOT
THE CASE THAT WE'RE GONNA BRING
IT UP LIKE IF IT HAS ANY TEETH
THAT ARE AS ANY MERIT- BUT
WHERE IT IS POSSIBLE AND WE'RE
NOT DONE. THAT'S AN AREA WHERE
WE WOULD- CONCEIVABLY TAKE
ACTION PARTICULAR WORK RESULT
IN A SUBSTANTIAL- WILDFIRE THE
STATUE HAS BUILT INTO IT A
NUMBER OF FACTORS FOR A JUDGE
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION AND
I'M SURE THAT THE AN ABILITY TO
CORRECT THE PROBLEM IF THAT.
DOES EXIST IS ONE OF THEM. YES
I HAD JUST OF SUCH THE YES NO
SO I TO BE ON WHAT HE JUST SAID
WHICH ALSO IS. FOR THOSE THAT
HAVE CONCERNS THE DA'S WILL NOT
USE THE PROSECUTORIAL
DISCRETION AS DESCRIBED THERE
IS ACTUALLY LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL. IT SAYS THAT THE COURT IS
SUPPOSED TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN DETERMINING
A PENALTY- WHETHER. THE
AFFECTED VIOLATION MAY BE
MITIGATED SO. AND I WOULD LOVE
IT IF MR WHICH COULD COME BACK
UP AND- MAYBE ADDRESS THAT AS
WELL MAKE. ON HIS CONCERNS.
THANK YOU SCOTT WHICH ABOUT
CALIFORNIA COALITION UNTIL
EMPLOYEES. WHAT'S BEING MISSED
HERE IN RELATIVE TO THAT
QUESTION IS. THE BILL THAT WE
SPONSORED THE DODD BILL WHICH
CHAPTER IN TWENTY NINETEEN. SO
THE ENTIRE REGIME OF FILING
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLANS IN
HAVING THEM REVIEWED BY THE CAN
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT WAS
APPOINTED BY THE P. YOU SEE
THAT WHOLE PROCESS JUST BEGAN
IN TWENTY TWENTY. OKAY SO
REALLY THIS YEAR'S THE FIRST
YEAR WHERE THIS WHOLE REGIME
THERE YOU KNOW WE HAVE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEES ABOUT WAS
PUT TOGETHER AND IN THE MIDST
OF THAT BECAUSE SOME DA HAS A
REALLY NEAT IDEA THEY'RE GOING
TO THROW A BRAND NEW PROCESS
INTO THAT WHOLE MIX. IT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER WHITE. MISTER
MATHIS. THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR-
MY THE SURE A LOT OF MISTER
WOULD USE CONCERNS ON THIS- WE
ALL WORKED VERY VERY HARD ON
SETTING UP THE PROCESS THAT WE
NOW HAVE- FRANKLY YEARS TO IRON
THAT OUT AND EACH. WHEN WE HEAR
ABOUT THINGS AND I UNDERSTAND
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL WE
UNDERSTAND NO. ALL POLITICS ARE
LOCAL. BOY FOR THESE COMPANIES
FOR THESE WORKERS TO GET INTO
SOME OF THESE AREAS THEY HAVE
TO GET THOSE COUNTY PERMITS.
AND MY CONCERN WITH HOW THIS
BILL HAS BEEN WRITTEN BY THE D.
A.'S IN NOT TO SAY THERE'S
VALENTYN HERE BUT THE COUNTY
CAN LITERALLY HOLD BACK A
PERMIT AND HAVE THE DIEGO WHEN
INSTRUCTOR PROSECUTE PROCESS.
HE IN IT TURNS INTO A MONEY
SCHEME. FOR THE COUNT. BECAUSE
THEY CAN BLOCK THE PERMIT AND
THEN ON THE OTHER SIDE GOING TO
DO THIS AND THAT IS MY CONCERN
WITH THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
ON TOP OF THE FACT THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE A PROCESS THAT
THAT IS NOW STARTING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED PLUS THE SIGHTING
OF THE INFORMATION ABOUT GOING
IN AND LOOKING AT IT AND IN ALL
THE BAD BLOOD THAT'S HAPPENED
OVER THE YEARS. WITH NOT GOING
IN AND NOT CLEANING UP AND ALL
OF THAT THAT IS. PART OF THE
OLD SYSTEM THAT WE WORK SO
HARD. THROUGH THE SENATE BILLS
TO GET RID OF IT NOW WE HAVE A
NEW SYSTEM MOVING FORWARD. I
THINK WOULD BE WRONG OF US AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY. TO SEE YOU
KNOW WHAT WE WORKED REALLY HARD
ON A PROCESS. WE'RE NOT EVEN
GOING TO GIVE IT A CHANCE. TO
WORK. AND FOR THAT I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE I WE'VE
GOT TO SEE THIS PROCESS WE
WORKED ON. ACTUALLY TAKE ROOT
AND WORK. SO THE TIMING OF THIS
I DON'T THINK IS NECESSARY- NO
I RESPECT YOUR YOUR HEART
TOGETHER SOLVE TO THIS THE
WILDFIRES ARE ARE AN ISSUE THE
AIR QUALITY IS AN ISSUE AND
THESE ARE THINGS THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED BUT I BELIEVE WE NEED
TO LOOK AT WHAT WE CAN DO FOR
THE PROCESS THAT WE ALREADY
WORKED SO HARD ON IN NATURE
THAT THAT WORKS IN IN IS MOVING.
IN AN EXPEDITIOUS WAY. TO
ENSURE WE'RE KNOCKING WILDFIRES
IN DOING THAT DOING SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO CAUSE
REPETITIVE FEES. TO ME WHEN I
LOOK AT IT AT THE AT THE END OF
THE DAY. COME FROM ONE OF THE
POOREST DISTRICTS IN OUR STATE
I HAVE TO LOOK IS THIS GOING TO
POSSIBLY DRIVE UP THE COST OF
PEOPLE'S ENERGY BILLS OR IS IT
GOING TO LOWER IT. IN THE ONE
OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS WE HAVE
IN THE STATE IS THE COST OF
LIVING. IN IF WE'RE INCREASING
THE COST IN ANY WAY EVEN IF
THAT'S NOT THE INTENT. THEN
THERE'S- WE SHOULD BE DOING. IN
AND FOR THAT I'M NOT GOING TO
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MATHIS A- CHIEF
SORTING. THANK YOU SO FIRST I
WANT TO THANK THANK YOU FOR
HAVING A PASSION ABOUT THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE I HAVE THAT PASSION TO
THERE'S NOBODY IN IN IN THE
ASSEMBLY THAT HAS HAD MORE
EXPERIENCE OR CARES MORE ABOUT
SOLVING THIS ISSUE- BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR A LONG
TIME- MY CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL. ARE YOU KNOW THERE IS A
QUOTE UNQUOTE OUR COMMENT.
ABOUT RELEVANT CIRCUMSTANCES.
N. AND WHEN. A UTILITY GETS
FINED THEY HAVE TO THERE IS
THERE'S A JUDGE'S SAYS WELL ONE
OF THESE RELEVANT CIRCUMSTANCES.
SOME OF THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES IN
MY EXPERIENCE BOTH AS A CITY
LEADER AND ALSO IN THE FIRE
SERVICE. ARE THINGS THAT ARE
WAY BEYOND THEIR CONTROL. AND
THAT'S THE REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE HAVE
CREATED IN THE STATE IN REGARDS
TO OUR ENVIRONMENT. OVER THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS THAT CREATE
HURDLES IN IN IMPEDIMENTS TO
ACTUALLY GETTING- TO ADDRESSING
THE VEGETATION ISSUE AND THE
VEGETATION ISSUE IS. THE ONE
THING THAT WE HAVE SOME CONTROL
OVER. AS A CITY WE ARE UNABLE
TO GET PERMITS TO BE ABLE TO
CLEAR AWAY BRUSH AND IT ALMOST
COST AS A NEIGHBORHOOD LAST
YEAR. THAT PROCESS IS SO LONG.
THAT OUR IS SO ONEROUS. THAT WE
CAN'T WE CAN'T GO IN AND START
FINING PEOPLE FOR NOT BEING
ABLE TO GET THROUGH A PROCESS
THAT WE CREATED. I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY-
MENTIONED THE INCENTIVE TO
FIND. WHEN YOU CREATE A PROGRAM
THAT DEPENDS ON FINDS PEOPLE
GONNA WANNA GO OUT AND FINE. SO
THEY CAN THEY CAN THEY CAN HAVE
THEIR PROGRAM- THE COSTS. ARE
GOING TO BE PASSED ON TO
CUSTOMERS I REALIZED THAT. THAT
THERE IS A CLAUSE IN THERE THAT
SAYS HERE NOT THEY CAN'T PASS
ALONG TO CUSTOMERS. BUT IF YOUR
CHOICE IS GOING BROKE OR GOING
PASSING ALONG I MEAN THAT'S
BUSINESS THEY HAVE TO PASS
ALONG TO CUSTOMERS THIS YEAR
WE'RE ALREADY LOOKING AT A 20%
INCREASE IN OUR ELECTRICAL
RATES AND A LOT OF IT IS
RELATED TO WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE STATE WITH THAT. THE
REGULATIONS AND HOW THEY'RE
BEING- FIND IN IN IN THE COST
TO THOSE THOSE THOSE ENTITIES
WE NEED TO PAVE THE WAY FOR
THEM TO DO THEIR JOB SO THAT
THEY WILL DO THEIR JOB THERE'S
NOBODY IN THE UTILITY SPACE.
THAT ONCE WILD FIRES TO
CONTINUE. THEY WANT TO DO THEIR
JOB. THEY KNOW THEY HAVE TO DO
THEIR JOB WE'VE CREATED
REGULATIONS IN LAST FEW YEARS
THAT MAY HELP THEM BUT LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE WAS SAYING WE NEED TO
GIVE THEM THE CHANCE TO DO THAT
SO FOR NOW. AT THE END I'M NOT
GOING TO BE VOTING IN FAVOR OF
THIS- JUST FOR THOSE REASONS
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH
YOU. TO CREATE THE SOLUTIONS
THAT I THINK ARE GOING TO BE
HELPFUL IN THE FUTURE TO DOING
THIS SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
IT AND- AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PASSION ON THE ISSUE. YEAH
MR STONE. THANK YOU ONE
CHALLENGE THAT I HAVE WITH THIS
BILL THOUGH I'M A CO AUTHOR
BECAUSE I THINK WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING WE NEED TO SOMETHING
DRAMATIC HERE IS THIS OVER
RELIANCE ON VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT BECAUSE IT'S BEEN A
DODGE BY SOME OF THE I. O. USE
FOR YEARS TO NOT UPGRADE THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ACTUALLY MAKE
IT SAFE BECAUSE THINGS ARE
GOING TO HAPPEN. IN THE FORESTS
AND THINGS ARE GOING TO HAPPEN
ALONG THE LINES THAT THAT WILL
LEAD TO FIRES AND IF THEY'RE
NO USING AND UPGRADING THEIR
SYSTEMS TO THE NEWEST
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WILL CONTINUE
REGARDLESS OF THE THIS OVER
RELIANCE ON VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT SO THAT'S THAT'S
JUST ONE OF THE CHALLENGES HERE.
BUT AS TO THE REST OF IT I WILL
HAVE TO SAY. THAT HAVING BEEN
ENGAGED IN THIS ISSUE FOR YEARS
WITH OUR LOCAL I. O. U. TWO
GREAT FRUSTRATION LOCALLY. AND
WITH WITH REALLY ALL OF THE
AGENCIES. I'M NOT SURE THAT
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS GOING TO
ADDRESS UP TO THIS POINT WE'VE
DONE UP THIS POINT IS ACTUALLY
GONNA DRESS ANY THESE ISSUES.
BECAUSE AT LEAST THE I. O. U.
IN MY AREA. IS NOT PAYING
ATTENTION. THEY HAVE LONG HAD
EASY ACCESS TO PROPERTIES
BECAUSE OF RIGHTS OF WAY THEY
GET UNDER THOSE PROPERTIES. AND
THEY HAVE LONG. CUT MAJOR
SWATHS EVEN OVER THE OBJECTIONS
OF LANDED REASONABLE OBJECTIONS
OF LANDOWNERS. LOCAL FIRE
CALIFORNIA AND OTHERS. SERVE
WITHOUT REGARD TO WHAT THE
SITUATION IS. THERE THE IN THE
CZ YOU FIRE IT THE RESPONSE HAS
REALLY BAD VISIBLE THEY CLAIM
THEIR CHALLENGES ARE RIGHTS OF
ACCESS. WELL CALIFORNIA- YES
FEMA THE COUNTY HAD NO PROBLEM
GETTING RIGHTS OF ACCESS AND
BUILT THOSE AGREEMENTS WHERE
WAS THE LOCAL I. O. U. NOT TO
BE SEEN. THEY'RE STILL HAVING
NO PROBLEM GOING ON TO PEOPLE'S
PROPERTY. LEAVING MATERIALS
THAT THEY SHOULDN'T BE LEAVING.
AND IN FACT CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION IN THE COUNTY HAVE
HAVE ISSUED NOTICES OF
VIOLATION AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE BAD
ACTIVITY AND A BAD ACTOR. THAT
THE AYE YOU YOU IS BEING.
THEY'RE BRINGING IN THEIR THEIR
UNDER THE NEW RULES THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BRING IN FORSTER'S
WELL THEY BRING FORESTERS FROM
TEXAS IN NEW JERSEY AND ALL
INTO A REDWOOD FOREST. NOW NO
OFFENSE CITIES FORSTER'S BUT
THEY DON'T OPERATE IN REDWOOD
FORESTS SO ARE THEY MAKING.
APPROPRIATE DECISIONS YES IT'S
AN ARBORIST. YES IT'S SOME
POTENTIALLY FORRESTER BUT
SOMEBODY DOESN'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE NATURE OF WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT AND HOW
THOSE SYSTEMS FUNCTION. AND BY
THE WAY THE FIRES TO BURN
THROUGH BIG BASS AND OTHER
PLACES BURNED IN WAYS THAT THE
FORCE OF REALLY DID NOT
UNDERSTAND. BECAUSE OF THE
EFFECT OF CLIMATE CHANGE IN THE
DAY DEHYDRATION THE FOREST AND
OTHER IMPACTS SO THOSE FORCED
TO CHANGING. EVEN WITH RESPECT
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERTS HOW
THOSE FOR CEMENT. SO PGNIG IS
KIND OF CHECKING BOXES. BUT NOT
BEING EFFECTIVE IN HOW THEY'RE
MANAGING. THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
WITH RESPECT TO PUBLIC SAFETY
AND HOW THEY'RE ADDRESSING
THEIR RESPONSE TO THE FORCE IN
INTO THE FOUR STARS IT'S REALLY
BEEN A VISIBLE THERE ARE STILL
A NUMBER OF NOTICES OF
VIOLATION OUT TO THEM THAT
THEY'RE REFUSING TO DEAL. SO IF
WE'RE GIVING SOME AUTHORITY TO
LOCAL PROSECUTORS TO GO AFTER
BAD ACTORS I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
PROBLEM WITH THAT SOMETHING'S
GOING TO HAVE TO WAKE UP. THE
UTILITIES. TO BE ABLE TO MANAGE
THEIR SYSTEMS A LOT BETTER ENDS
IF WE'RE GOING TO. BEMOAN THE
FACT IT RATES ARE GOING UP
BECAUSE THE DECISIONS ARE BEING
MADE YEAH WE SHOULD BE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT. BUT
SHAREHOLDER CONFIDENCE AND
UTILITY BOTTOM LINE. IS
SOMETHING THAT IS DRIVING UP.
SOME OF THE COSTS TO THE
SHAREHOLDERS AND WHAT THAT
REALLY MEANS IS. THE SHOULD BE
IN THIS AWFUL. ORGANIZATIONS
AND NOT PRIVATELY OWNED BECAUSE
THEN THOSE COSTS IN THOSE
DECISIONS THAT ARE BEING MADE
FOR SHAREHOLDER CONFIDENCE.
APART MINDS WOULD BE OFF THE
TABLE THAT BY DEFINITION WOULD
BE CHEAPER FOR RATEPAYERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND GIVE US
MORE DIRECT ABILITY TO MANAGE
THESE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
SO THE VALUES THEMSELVES ARE
SAYING WHEN THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT INVESTOR CONFIDENCE.
THEY'RE MAKING THE CASE TO NOT
HAVE UTILITIES BEING RUN BY
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES SAID
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WAS ON
THE TABLE AS WE WERE TRYING TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE- ISSUES
WITH WILDFIRES AND
UNFORTUNATELY WAS TAKEN OFF BUT
THAT IS A REAL SOLUTION THAT
CALIFORNIA FOR BEING ABLE TO
MANAGE ITS GREAT LONG TERM. AND
KEEP CALIFORNIANS SAFE HAVE TO
BE WILLING TO TAKE STEPS LIKE
THAT TO. MAKE SURE THAT THE
RIGHT. ORGANIZATIONS THE RIGHT
LEVELS OF RESPONSIBILITY ARE
MANAGING THE GREAT SO I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY AND
I THINK THERE NEEDS TO STILL BE
A LOT MORE DONE TO RAINY AND SO
VERY SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS. IN
AGAIN ON THE GROUND IN SPITE OF
ALL THE RHETORIC IN THIS ROOM
IF YOU LOOK AT ON THE GROUND
RIGHT NOW. HOW THESE I'LL USER
ACTING IN THE COMMUNITY I WILL
TELL YOU NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
CONTENTS ALL MOVED TO THE-
PROTECT ACT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'VE GOT A MOTION. NOTICE AND
CLOSING- IN IN RESPONSE TO MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER STONE LIKE I
THINK THAT THERE IS. THERE'S
THREE THINGS A SUSTAINED FIRE.
IT OXYGEN. THE TECHNICIAN IN
ITS FUEL. WHAT WE'RE TALKING
TODAY ABOUT HIS IGNITION AND
WHO IS MAY OR MAY NOT BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT BUT ONCE
THAT ONCE THAT IGNITION IS ON
THE GROUND. I THINK IT CANNOT
BE UNDERSTATED HOW IMPORTANT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT THIS AT
THAT POINT. BECAUSE AND THAT'S
THE STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY THAT
LOCAL PROPERTY OWNERS
RESPONSIBILITY BECAUSE ONCE
THAT SPARK HITS THE- GROUND.
IT'S OFF TO THE RACES AND I
THINK THAT'S- WHERE WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE AS A STATE
WE AS A- AS A BODY HAVE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY AS WELL IS TO
MAKE SURE. THAT ONCE THAT
IGNITION NO MATTER WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT. WHETHER
IT'S LIGHTNING OR MAN MADE.
ONES THAT SPARK HITS THE
GROUND. WE GOT TO GET THE MEN
AND WOMEN IN THE FIRE SERVICE
THE OPPORTUNITY. AND THE
ABILITY TO DO THEIR JOB AND
CATCH UP TO THEM SO I DO THINK
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WELL. BUT
THAT'S A DIFFERENT CONTEXT.
BECAUSE THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
IS HOW WE MANAGE THE FORESTS
WHAT WE ARE IN FACT TALKING
ABOUT HERE WITH THIS MESS THIS
VERY. VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
QUESTION. IS THAT IGNITION
CORRECT AND SO IF THERE WHICH
IS WHY THEY THEY CUT LARGE
SWATHS UNDERNEATH THEIR- THEIR
LINES. A. N. BUT REFUSED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR LINES ARE
USING APPROPRIATE MODERN
TECHNOLOGY TO ENSURE THAT
THAT'S PARKING DOESN'T HAPPEN.
AND SO IT'S A COMBINATION OF
CLEARING BACK APPROPRIATELY NOT
INAPPROPRIATELY WHICH IS WHAT
THEY TENDED. BUT CLING BACK
APPROPRIATELY BUT BUT REALLY
WHAT IT IS MAKING INVESTMENTS.
AND GROUND FAULT INTERRUPTERS
IN FAST SWITCHES AND THINGS
THAT THAT. WILL DE ENERGIZE THE
LINE. BEFORE IT'S GOING TO.
THAT SPARKED IT WHAT YOU'RE
ABOUT WITH THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT THE FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT TO MINIMIZE THE
IMPACT OF FIRES IS REALLY
BEYOND THE QUESTION HERE.
BECAUSE THAT'S A BIGGER
QUESTION THAT THAT THE I'LL USE
ARE NOT GOING TO BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING. THE
ENTIRE FOREST AND HOW THAT FIRE
THAT MOVES THROUGH THE FOREST.
WE ARE TALKING SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THE POINT OF IGNITION AND
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY. FOR
MANAGING THAT INTERACTION
BETWEEN AND ENERGIZED LINE
WHICH SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE DE
ENERGIZE MORE QUICKLY WORKS.
NOT HAVE THAT SPARK BECAUSE OF
THE TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE OF
INSULATION BECAUSE OF OTHER
THINGS. SO NOT HAVING THAT
IGNITION IN IT BEYOND THAT.
THAT'S REALLY THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH THIS
PARTICULAR QUESTIONS ON WHICH
STATION AFTER. OF COURSE FIRST
ON. THE WILL GO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- THE ROBOTS DEBATE.
HAS BROUGHT A RUN QUESTION IN
MY MIND FOR THE AUTHOR GARCIA
LANGUAGE. IS THERE A MECHANISM
WITHIN THE LANGUAGE OF YOUR
BILL. THAT SPECIFICALLY PER TAX
UTILITIES IN THE CASE THAT THE
COUNTY HAS NOT APPROVED THE
PERMIT. SO IF THE I DON'T SEE
HOW WE CAN HELP IF THERE'S NOT
A PERMIT THE LET HIM GO IN
BECAUSE THE- YUP TELEVISION
COUNTY- EVERYTHING'S BACKLOG.
YOU KNOW SO I WANT TO ENSURE
THAT. THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET
BEAT UP BECAUSE SOMEBODY DIDN'T
SIGN OFF ON A PERMIT TO LET ME.
SO I DON'T WANNA I WANNA MAKE
SURE THIS DOESN'T TURN INTO A
PREDATORY PROCESS YEAH COUNTY
LEVEL. YES IS THAT SPECIFICALLY
WRITTEN IN THERE. TO PROTECT
THEM FROM LIKE A LAZY CAL YES.
PLEASE CALL THE COUNTIES IS
THAT YES THINGS STAND IN THEIR
WAY MISTER MATHIS ARE TRUSTED
HERE- AND I MAY NOT BE THE ONLY
THING RIGHT PERMITS IS ONLY ONE
THING YOU MISTER FLOOR
MENTIONED OTHER BARRIERS-
MISTER SARATOGA AS WELL- AND
YES SO IT IS SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSED IN THE COURTS
ANALYSIS OF FINES AND FEES SO
IF THE DA WERE TO BRING ACTION.
THAT- WAS FOR LACK OF EDUCATION
MANAGEMENT SUMMIT COULD
MITIGATE THE COURT IS
INSTRUCTED TO TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN DECIDING
WHETHER TO FIND. ENEMY HELPER
THAT'S THE BASIC DEFENSE TO
ISSUE BEING BROUGHT UNDER
SOMETHING LIKE THIS BY A DA IS
IF THERE'S A MINISTERIAL OR IF
THERE'S A GOVERNMENTAL ACTION.
THAT THE DEFENDANT IN THIS CASE
WOULD HAVE NEEDED. IN ORDER TO
MOVE FORWARD THEN. THERE'S NO
CASE YET MATHIS SALAS THAT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE IT'S JUST
INSURING EVEN THE PROCESS OF
THAT IS GOING TO COST THE
UTILITY MORE MONEY. SO IT IT'S
MAKING SURE IT'S VERY STAUNCH
AND CLEAR THAT WE HAD D. A.
CAN'T JUST BE LIKE WELL LET'S
JUST DO THIS ANYWAY. WELL I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THESE THINGS
ARE CRYSTAL CLEAR MOVING
FORWARD I KNOW THIS IS GOING TO
JUDICIARY. AND A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS ARE ON THE JUDICIARY
SIDE AND I BELIEVE MR SONG
YOU'RE STILL ON JUDICIARY
CORRECT SO. YEAH AND I DO I
MEAN WHAT I AS I READ THE
LANGUAGE I BELIEVE IT'S CLEAR
BUT IF IT'S NOT WE'RE HAPPY
CLEAR THAT THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
WAS IS NOT A GOTCHA IT'S NOT
EXCESSIVE FINES IT IS VERY MUCH
GIVING THE UTILITIES. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CURE LETTING
THEM KNOW THAT THERE IS A
VIOLATION. ASKING THEM TO FIX
IT GIVING THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
TO FIX IT FOR ANY ACTION BE CAN
BE TAKEN WHICH AGAIN. IN MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH EDISON THEY
SAID THEY DO SO WE SHOULD HAVE
NO PROBLEMS- BUT- ENSURING THAT
IF THEY DON'T. WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO OUT AND
CORRECT- WHAT IS HAPPENING AND
ENSURE THE LIVES ARE NOT LOST
AND I WANT TO THINK AND MR
SERETIDE AND HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK HIM FOR
HIS COMMENTS AND I KNOW BOTH.
YOU KNOW WE'VE SEVERAL PEOPLE
HERE WHO SPENT THEIR CAREERS
FIGHTING FIRES AND I'M
PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS AND-
OBVIOUSLY IS CRITICAL FOR ALL
OF US THAT WE GET THIS WORK
DONE- AND THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PREVENT
THE DEVASTATION THAT OCCURS
WHEN A FIRE HAPPENS- AS TO YOUR
COMMENT MISTER MATHIS- ABOUT
REPAIR COSTS I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT AND-
MISTER WHICH MENTIONS THE-
ENORMOUS FINES THAT COME OUT OF
THESE FIRES THAT IN FACT. THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO CURE AND HAVE
PEOPLE PROVIDING THAT
OPPORTUNITY. COULD SAVE THE I
USE MONEY IF THEY DO THE WORK
SO IT IS NOT CLEAR TO ME. THAT
GIVEN THE WAY THIS BILL AS
AMENDED BY THE COMMITTEE AND
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THAT- AMENDMENT
IN THEIR WORK ON THAT. THIS
COULD ACTUALLY REDUCE THE COST
ON THE I USE RATHER THAN
WAITING UNTIL THESE FIRES WHAT
HAPPENED. AND WE ARE FINDING
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR.
THAT COUNTLESS PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DIED IN THE COMMUNITIES OF.
THAT HAVE BEEN DESTROYED- SO I
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT THING
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION. BUT
OBVIOUSLY AS MR STONE POINTED
OUT AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE ON THIS AND IT IS
NOT. THIS IS NOT THE WHOLE
SOLUTION AND I DON'T. CLAIM IT
IS BY ANY STRETCH OF THE
IMAGINATION BUT I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF IT- YOU KNOW.
WE HAVE DONE WORK ON THIS WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS. BUT
I'LL POINT OUT THAT JUST THIS
WEEK. IT WAS FOUND THAT THE DOG
FIRE WAS CAUSED BY. A LACK OF
EDUCATION MANAGEMENT FOUR
PEOPLE KILLED FIFTY THOUSAND
PLUS ACRES BURNED SO WE- WE
HAVEN'T SOLVED THIS PROBLEM I
THINK WE NEED TO. OWN THAT AND
BE CLEAR ABOUT AND WE HAVE MORE
WORK TO DO. AND THAT IS THE
WORK THAT I'M TRYING TO DO HERE
TODAY. SO THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR ENGAGEMENT FOR CARING SO
MUCH ABOUT THIS ISSUE. OKAY DID
WE HAVE MORE QUESTIONS. YES THE
STARS. MANY A COMMON I KNOW THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND I'LL-
THANK AND- THE BILL- WE ARE. I
UNDERSTAND WHY IT'S HERE AND
IT'S GOING TO DO JUST VERY
WE'RE TALKING A LOT ABOUT
UTILITIES AND THE WORK THAT OUR
CHURCH THERE HAS DONE- IN THIS
SPACE AND WHEN WE THE WORK IS
DONE AT A WAS NOT AT THE END OF
THE WORKING DAY TO DO SO I DO
AGREE THERE'S MORE WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE AND I.
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE TRYING TO
EXPAND OUR TOOL KIT WITH WITH
THIS BILL I TO BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL AND MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS ARE ACCOUNTABLE OTHERS I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT YOU'RE
JUMPING INTO THE SPACE HERE
LEADERSHIP IS NOT A QUESTION AS
A MATTER OF ITS FOR YOU OR FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE OF. WHY IT'S NOT
GOING TO TELL THESE- WE'RE NOT
HEARING IT IN UTILITY. SINCE IT
SEEMS TO BE GERMANE TO THAT
TOPIC. I THINK THAT'S A
QUESTION FOR RULES BUT I CAN
SAY THAT IT IS IN PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE WHICH IS WHY
IT'S BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE-
AND- I KNOW THAT MR HOLDEN I
HAVE BEEN IN CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS THINGS ON THE SAME PAGE IN
THIS CONVERSATION AND- I WILL
CONTINUE. TO ENGAGE HIM IN CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT HIS WORK ON THIS
AND- AS YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN.
PART OF MANY OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND GETTING YOU
TO BE AND I KNOW HE SHARES. ALL
OF OUR INTEREST IN ENSURING OR
PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS FROM.
ANY UTILITY PASSED WELFARE.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE WORKING WITH THE CHAIR
THERE ARE LOTS OF THANK YOU. AT
THE SECOND LEVEL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERS. WOULD YOU LIKE ME
TO TAKE THOSE YOU'RE CLOSE
RESPECT FASTER ABBOTT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. LOCAL POLICE. I AM
THREE AB TWENTY ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAR PARA QUE HAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RIVAS. LARA
LARA NOTE CHAU FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS NO MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI SERTA NOW THEY ARE
DOING NOW STONE. STONE I WOULD.
THREE THREE. THE BILL'S UNCLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT UP WE
HAVE A. B. EIGHT NINETY SIX
BENNETT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD MORNING- AB NINETY SIX
THAT IS A BILL THAT WILL IMPOSE
A LIEN ON WELL OPERATORS- TO
RECOVER STATE COST THIS LEAN ON
WELL OPERATORS CAN BE
REMEDIATED BY THE- WELL
OPERATORS IF THEY- TAKE ANY OF
THE APPROPRIATE ACTIONS
REMEDIATED PAID A FINE-
INDEMNIFY THE BOND BUT IT CAN
BE REMOVED- THERE ARE OVER FOUR
THOUSAND IDLE WELLS- IN
CALIFORNIA. WHO BUT THERE ARE
OVER FOUR THOUSAND IDLE WELLS
IN CALIFORNIA THAT OVER SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN UNPAID FEES
THAT ARE OUT THERE OVER THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY OF THOSE IDLE
WELLS ARE IN MY DISTRICT ALONE-
ONE THIRD OF THOSE IDLE WELLS-
CAL GEMS IS NOT ABLE TO
IDENTIFY WHO THE OPERATOR IS OR
OR CONTACT THE OPERATOR.
THEY'RE POTENTIALLY ORPHANED
WELLS AN ORPHAN WELLS HAVE
POSED A REAL LIABILITY FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO LEAK GAS-
AND- FUGITIVE- ADMISSIONS IN
ADDITION TO THAT AS THE WORLD
TRANSITIONS AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUELS. THE POTENTIAL RISK FOR
MORE ABANDONED AND ORPHANED
WELLS INCREASES WE NEED
STRONGER ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE SO THAT
THE RESPONSIBLE ACTORS ARE NOT
TARNISHED BY THE AIR
RESPONSIBLE ACTORS. IN HOW THEY
HANDLE- THERE IDLE WELLS I'VE
BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS- AND TRYING TO AND
I APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
COOPERATION AS WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS BILL AND I. AM
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS TO ADDRESS
THE FEW REMAININGISSUES THAT
ARE OUT THERE I'M VERY HAPPY
THAT THERE ARE TWO
KNOWLEDGEABLE WITNESSES- THAT
HAVE DECIDED TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY ALSO. I HAD COURAGE AND I
VOTE FOR THIS GUY THANK YOU. I
GUESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FIRST UP ON THE PHONE WE HAVE
DAMON FROM IN OUR DC. THE
MODERATOR CAN YOU OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS DAMOND LIKE I MEAN I'M
A SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL OR NRDC WE SUPPORT AB
EIGHT NINETY SIX WHICH WOULD
GIVE THE STATE OIL AND GAS
REGULATOR CAL GEM ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY TO HOLD FOSSIL FUEL
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
IMPACTS OF THEIR OPERATIONS.
THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE CAL
GEMS PUT A LIEN ON PROPERTY AND
OPERATORS WELL DURING AN UNSAFE
CONDITION OR IF THEY'RE NOT
PAYING THEIR TO IMPOSE FEES OUR
COMPANY DECLARES BANKRUPTCY AND
TRIES TO LEAVE THE STATE
HOLDING THE BAG SALINAS ALREADY
INEFFECTIVE COMMONSENSE TOOL
THAT FRANKLY CONTENT ALREADY
SHOULD HAVE HAD IN THIS
TOOLBOX. THE BILL WOULD ALSO
ESTABLISH A COLLECTIONS UNIT TO
COLLECT UNPAID I DON'T WELL
FEES AS WELL AS COSTS INCURRED
WHEN A WELL HAS BEEN DESERTED
ORDER TO BE PLUGGED AND
ABANDONED AGAIN THIS IS A
COMMONSENSE TOOL THAT CAN
INCREASE COMPLIANCE AND SHOULD
BE INTELLIGENCE ARSENAL. THESE
MEASURES CAN SIGNIFICANTLY
SHORE UP CALCIUM TO FLORIDA
WITH REGARD TO NON COMPLIANT
WELL OPERATORS AS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF WHERE THIS COULD BE
HELPFUL IN MARCH OF LAST YEAR
HELLO JIM ISSUED AN ORDER TO
ALLEN CO ENERGY TO PLUGGING
ABANDONED WELLS AT ITS ST JAMES
STILL SITE IN SOUTH LOS
ANGELES. THIS SITE IS ADJACENT
TO HOMES CHURCHES BUSINESSES
AND A SCHOOL FOR SPECIAL NEEDS
CHILDREN AND CAL GEMS ORDER
DETAIL THAT THE THEORY RATING
CONDITION OF THE WILD AND
EVIDENCE OF MULTIPLE GAS LEAKS.
CAL JIM ALSO HAD PREVIOUSLY
ASKED FOR INFORMATION FROM THE
OPERATOR TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THE PROJECT COULD WOULD CAUSE
DAMAGE TO LIFE HEALTH PROPERTY
FINANCIAL RESOURCES AND YET
SEVERAL MONTHS LATER THE
OPERATOR STILL HAS FAILED TO
PROVIDE THIS DATA AND
INFORMATION TO THE AGENCY AND
ALSO. HAS FAILED TO PAY ITS
IDLE WEALTHY. BUT NEXT TO ALLEN
CO SITE AND OTHER WELL. AND THE-
ALL COULD BENEFIT FROM THE- IN
THIS BILL. THIRTY SECONDS NRDC
SUPPORTS AB EIGHT NINETY SIX
AND RESPECT RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE COMMITTEE TO MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT UP WE HAVE. TERRA MESSING
FROM ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
CENTER BY THE PHONE. GOOD
MORNING HEARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I NEED THIS TERM
MESSING AND I AM A STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE CENTER. EDC IS A PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW FIRM THAT PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT IN SANTA
BARBARA VENTURA AND FAMILIES
OBISPO COUNTY. EDT SUPPORT AB
EIGHT NINE SIX. OVER THE PAST
FIVE YEARS APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT OIL AND
GAS PRODUCER'S WITH MORE THAN A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN DEBT. ENTERED INTO
BANKRUPTCY. THIRTY SIX
PRODUCERS WITH AROUND FIFTY ONE
BILLION AND THAT FILED FOR
BANKRUPTCY IN THE FIRST EIGHT
MONTHS OF LAST YEAR. INCLUDING
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST OIL
AND GAS OPERATORS. CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES CORPORATION IS AN
EXAMPLE OF THIS SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL RISK THAT A SINGLE
BANKRUPTCY COULD POSE TO THE
STATE. THE COMPANY HAD MORE
THAN FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THAT.
ALONG WITH AN INVENTORY OF
THOUSANDS OF IDYLLWILD. WELL
DESERTED BY INSOLVENT OPERATORS
BECOME PORTION WILD PORCH THE
STATE MAY BECOME RESPONSIBLE. A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT
ESTIMATED THAT THE TOTAL COST
TO PLUG ALL ACTION ON A WILL BE
CALIFORNIA. WOULD BE ABOUT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS. THIS WILL
PROVIDE CALCIUM WITH THE TOOL
TO PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND TAXPAYERS BY
MANAGING THE DECLINE IN OIL AND
GAS. SHOULD AN OPERATOR FILED
FOR BANKRUPTCY THE BUILDING
AUTHORITY WOULD YOU GIVE
CALDERON HEIGHTENED PRIORITY
FOR REPAYMENT. THE BILL WOULD
ALSO ESTABLISH UNIT TO COLLECT
UNPAID IDYLLWILD FEES. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SEVEN OPERATORS
FAILED TO PAY FEES FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED WELL. THIS
UNIT PROVIDES ANOTHER MECHANISM
TO ADDRESS THE GROWING NUMBER
OF UNPAID FEES. I'M THREE
TWELVE ALL THREATENED CLEAN AIR
WATER AND HEALTHY COMMUNITIES.
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS LIVE
WITHIN SIX HUNDRED FEET OF
UNPLUG WHILE. WITHOUT YOU KNOW
BLACK AND LOW INCOME PEOPLE
LIVING NEARBY AT A HIGHER RATE
THAN THE CALIFORNIA POPULATION
AS A WHOLE FIFTEEN SECONDS OIL
WELLS ARE NONE OF IT. WELL
WALDRON UNTIL. DR GRANT
ADMISSION OF GUY. AND ALSO CAN
I CAN CRAFT ALONG WITH HIM AT
THE PHONE TO SPECIAL FOR ME.
SPREADING EDC SUPPORTS AB EIGHT
NINE SIX AND ASK THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORTS THIS BILL AS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT THE TWO MINUTES
THERE. ARE WE WILL BE MOVING ON
TO OPPOSITION TO A. B. EIGHT
NINETY SIX. ANY OPPOSITION AB
EIGHT NINETY SIX LOOKS LOOK AT
SEAN. WELL IN TEAM FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BEEN PATROLLING
ASSOCIATION. SHARE NUMBERS GOOD
MORNING THIS IS SEAN
WALLENSTEIN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION. WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY SIX- WE DO
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT AND HIS STAFF FOR THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO HEAR OUR
CONCERNS AND CONSIDER
AMENDMENTS. WELL IF THE BILL
WERE AMENDED TO ENSURE THE CAL
JIM USES EXISTING STAFF TO
FULFILL THE BILL'S REQUIREMENT
THE CAL JIM CREATE A
COLLECTIONS UNIT. WE WOULD NOT
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION CALGENE
MARTY HAS STAFF ATTENDING TO
THIS FUNCTION IN COOPERATION
WITH THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE WHO PROCESSES OUR FEET
PAYMENT. AND CAL JIM CURRENTLY
HAS A 20% STAFF VACANCY RATE SO
THEY HAVE LOTS OF POSITIONS
AVAILABLE TO AUGMENT THEIR
COLLECTION FUNCTION. FOR MISTER
BENNETT'S BILL. BUT WE ALSO
HAVE SOME TECHNICAL CONCERNS
ABOUT THE LEAD AUTHORITY IN THE
BILL CALCIUM ALREADY DOES HAVE
LEAD AUTHORITY AND PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE SECTION THIRTY
FOUR TWENTY THREE SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT HOW THIS BILL WOULD
MODIFY CURRENTLY AUTHORITY. IN
PRINCIPLE SAID BUT IT DOES NOT
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE IDEA
OF THE STATE USING WIENER
FORGET THE TOOL TO COMPEL
COMPLIANCE WHEN NECESSARY.
LANES ARE NOT SOMETHING SEVEN
MEMBERS- ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS WE HAVE A TRACK RECORD OF
PAYING IN FULL AND ON TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- CHAIR
NUMBER THREE HEARINGS THAT
THOSE CONCERNS THIS MORNING
WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR- AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ON ELSE IN THE- BY THE-
MODERATED YOU POP THE PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT NINETY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND OUR
FIRST LINE FOR COMMENT IS MINE
FIFTY NINE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS LAUREN CALLING WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA GOING STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINETY SIX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IN MY
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. MY NINETY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NINETY ONE NINETY ONE YEAH THIS
IS THIS IMPORT MODULE WITH THE
CLIMATE CENTER HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT NINETY SIX THANK
YOU. I NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBERS MELISSA
ROMERO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NINE NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING THIS IS
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF
THE VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENEFITS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE OF
SIXTY NINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS JIM WEINBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE FRENCH COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINE
SIX. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MY
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANTHONY HELP
THEM WITH HE CALIFORNIA LAND
TITLE ASSOCIATION SO I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE'VE SUGGESTED SOME
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS TO THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE RELATING TO THE
LEAN CREATED UNDER THE SPELL
AND ARE WORKING WITH- STAFF TO
HOPEFULLY ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
JUST A NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. AND ONE HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SACKLER WITH THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION- WORK CURRENTLY
NEUTRAL ON AB EIGHT NINETY SIX
AND I THOUGHT THE NUMBER OF
PRODUCTIVE MEETINGS WITH
AUTHORS OFFICE. WHERE WE RAISE
A COUPLE CONCERNS OR THANKED
AUTHORED AND STOP AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM IN
THE STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS TO
ADDRESS OUR ISSUES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IN NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE CHAIR
AND MEMBER IGOR TRIANGLE WITH
THE SIERRA CLUB IN STRONG AND
GRAPHICS A PART OF THIS BILL
pNINE ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ALICE
STATLER I LIVE IN RENTON FELT
RESERVE RIGHT NEXT TO
WILMINGTON WHERE THERE ARE MANY
OIL WELLS AND I'M STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NINE ONE OH EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
LESLIE PURCELL AND CALLING FROM
VENTURA I AM ONE OF- STUDENTS
CONSTITUENTS AND APPRECIATE HIS
WORK ON THIS AND WE WOULD LIKE.
TO SUPPORT THE- BILL AND HELP
CLEAN UP OUR ENVIRONMENT THANK
YOU FOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HIS NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. PERFECT
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IT'S NOT A
QUESTION BUT I WANT TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
FORWARD- THIS IS BEEN A HUGE
PROBLEM IN THE STATE AND LIKE
YOU SAID IT'S GOING TO BE A
GROWING PROBLEM AS MORE AND
MORE OF THESE WELLS. ARE
BECOMING USED AND WE OWE IT TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA TO NOT
HAVE THE TAXPAYERS BAIL OUT. OF
THE INDUSTRY BY PAYING TO CLEAN
UP THE WELLS OR WORSE BY
FAILING TO CLEAN UP THE WELLS
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK. ALL RIGHT MISTER BENNETT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
ALEX AND LIKE THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR THE
COMMENTS THAT ARE THAT SHE JUST
MADE- WITH REGARDS TO THE-
OPPOSITION- COMMENT THAT WAS
MADE A BALLOT TO. THE CREATION
OF A UNITS AND- THIS BILL DOES
NOT IDENTIFY HOW MANY PERSON
HOW MANY PERSONNEL HAVE TO BE
ASSIGNED IT DOES NOT SAY THAT
EXISTING PERSONNEL CAN'T BE
ASSIGNED BUT I THINK WE ALL
WOULD AGREE THAT- WE NEED TO
HAVE STRONG ENFORCEMENT
CAPABILITY. AND SO- COLLECTIONS
UNIT IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL IF
YOU'RE GOING TO START OF
SIGNING LEANS AND MONITORING
THOSE CLEANS AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE RULES ARE-
OF THOSE WINGS AND- WITHOUT.
CLEAR ENFORCEMENT- WE WILL HAVE
THIS PROBLEM CONTINUE TO GROW
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. SO AGAIN I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS- COOPERATION AS
WE'VE- REACHED OUT TO THEM AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN I ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ADAM FIVE
AB EIGHT NINETY SIX. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS RIVAS LARA. FLOOR NOT
VOTING CHAU FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
I'D GARCIA GARCIA I MATHIS
MATHIS NOT VOTING MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI FAIR TRIAL STONE.
STONE I WOULD. THREE ZERO.
REVERSIBILITY POLIAKOFF NEXT UP
WE HAVE A B. SIXTY SIX.
ASSEMBLY ONE HORA. GOOD
MORNING- MADAM CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FIRST OF ALL
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND I'D
LIKE TO THINK YOU'RE COMMITTEE
AND STUFF FOR WORK ON THE BELT
AB SIXTY SIX WILL PROVIDE
SCRIPT INSTITUTION OF
OCEANOGRAPHY WITH A TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION IN STATE FUNDING.
FOR RESEARCH TO INFORM THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A BLUFF
COLLAPSED EARLY WARNING
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM TO IMPROVE
BEACH SAFETY AND PREVENT
FURTHER FUTURE FATALITIES
EPISODIC LOVE FAILURES HAVE
CAUSED HUMAN INJURY IN SEVERAL
DEATHS IN RECENT YEARS ON JULY
THIRD TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN A
WOMAN DIED AFTER SHE FELL THE
HUNDRED FIFTY FEET FROM THE
SEASIDE BLUFF IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY WHEN THE GROUND BENEATH
HER CRUMBLED THE CLIFF HAVE
BEEN BATTERED BY WINTER STORMS
AND COLLAPSED. ON FEBRUARY TWO
TWENTY NINETEEN IN SAN
FRANCISCO WOMAN OUR DOG WERE
RESCUED ANOTHER WOMAN REMAIN
TRAPPED AFTER THE EDGE OF A
CLIFF AT FORT FUNSTON COLLAPSED
ON TOP OF THEM HEARING ONE
VICTIM UNDER TONS OF DIRT THE
TRAP WOMAN'S BODY WAS NEVER
RECOVERED. ON AUGUST TWENTY
NINETEEN THREE PEOPLE WERE
FATALLY CRASHED WHEN A BLUFF
CLASS IN EDIT INFINITIVES BEACH
IN MY HOMETOWN THE VICTIMS ARE
PART OF A LARGE FAMILY
GATHERING THAT ANY AND HAVE IT
BOTH COST OF JUST A FEW MINUTES
EARLIER THE DEATH. TOLL WOULD
HAVE BEEN HIGHER INCLUDED
CHILDREN. IN A TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY- CLUB. THREAD EXPENSE
CLIFTON OF. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE INCLUDING HIGHWAYS
RAILWAYS WASTE WATER OIL
NATURAL GAS AND NUCLEAR
FACILITIES. UNIVERSITIES AND
SEVERAL CRITICAL MILITARY BASES
AND NUMEROUS STATE BEACHES AND
PARKS. RESEMBLE OF FAILURES OF
THE CITY OF DEL MAR JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
THREATEN A BLUFF TOP REAL RIGHT
YOU HAVE RESULTED IN MULTIPLE
CLOSURES OF THE SECOND BUSIEST
REAL QUARTER IN THE ENTIRE
UNITED STATES. IMPACTING
COMMUTERS FREIGHT TRANSPORT AND
THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO. AS
CONCERT AT AS CONCERNING BLOOD
FIGURES ARE PROJECTED TO HAPPEN
MORE OFTEN. U. S. GEOLOGICAL
SURVEY SCIENTISTS HAVE
FORECASTED THAT BECAUSE OF SEA
LEVEL RISE OUR COASTLINE COULD
RECEIVE BY MORE THAN A HUNDRED
FEET THIRTY FEET. BY TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED IF THE LEVELS KEEP
RISING TO THE LOBAL CLIMATE
CHANGE. WHAT IS MISSING RIGHT
NOW IS UNDERSTANDING THE
SCIENCE AROUND WHITE BLUFFS
REAL. UNDERSTANDING THE PROCESS
THE DRIVE BUS FOR YEARS
TRIGGERING MECHANISMS.
MAGNITUDE OF ROSHEN AND TIMING
OF CLOUGH'S IS ESSENTIAL FOR
COASTAL MANAGEMENT AND BUILDING
RESILIENT AND SAFE COMMUNITIES.
AB SIXTY SIX OF THE FOR IS THE
FIRST STEP IN CREATING EARLY
MORNING NOTIFICATION SYSTEM
MUCH LIKE WE HAVE FOR
EARTHQUAKES. THE RESEARCH WILL
FOCUS ON THE DEL MAR BLUFFS
WHERE I MENTIONED THE REAL I
COSTS JUST RECENTLY HAPPENED.
AS WELL AS BEACONS BEACH AN
ACTIVE LANDSLIDE AREA IN
ENCINITAS. THIS WILL PROVIDE
THE SCIENCE STATEWIDE TO
DEVELOP IN FACE TO THE EARLY
WARNING NOTIFICATION SYSTEM. IT
IS MY HOPE THAT WE EVENTUALLY
WILL HAVE WARNINGS FOR BLOOD
FAILURES ON OUR WEATHER APPS
MUCH LIKE WE DO FOR HIGH WIND
ADVISORY. FLOODING OR HIGH SURF
ADVISORIES. THIS INFORMATION IS
CRITICAL TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER IN THE FACE
OF SEA LEVEL RISE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TODAY ARE MARK SOME
BURKE. RESEARCH GEOPHYSICIST
FROM THE INSTITUTE OF
GEOPHYSICS AND PLANETARY
PHYSICS SCRIPTS. AND COUNCIL
MEMBER DWIGHT WORDEN FROM THE
CITY OF DEL MAR. THANK YOU. IF
WE CAN OPEN UP LINES FOR
WITNESSES. HI THIS IS MARK
SAMBERG SCRIPTS OCEANOGRAPHY-
THANK YOU CHAIR RIVAS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANKS TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
FERNER DO SING THIS BILL THAT
CAN SIGNIFICANTLY ADVANCE
RESEARCH ON THE DYNAMICS OF
CLIFF COLLAPSE ALONG
CALIFORNIA'S COAST LINES. WITH
FUNDING FROM THE STATE PARKS
OCEANOGRAPHY PROGRAM MY
COLLEAGUE AT SCRIPTS DR ADAM
YOUNG HAS BEEN SERVING THE
CLIPS BETWEEN SAN DIEGO IN
OCEANSIDE FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
USING LIDAR A SYSTEM THAT SCANS
THE CLIFFS WITH A LASER
CREATING HIGHLY DETAILED
SPATIAL MAPS WITH RESOLUTION
MEASURED IN INCHES. TO LEARN
WHERE AND HOW OFTEN CLIP
FAILURES OCCUR- THIS TO TEXT
THE SMALL HARDLY NOTICEABLE
ROCKFALLS AND ALSO OF COURSE
THE MAJOR COLLAPSES WHICH
THREATEN LIVES AND PROPERTY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA'S
COASTLINE. WITH FUNDING FROM
THIS BILL WE WOULD AIM TO GAIN
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
PROCESSES LEADING UP THE CLIFF
FAILURES BY DOING TWO THINGS
FIRST WE WILL ACCELERATE THE
COLLECTION OF THE SLIDER DATA
ALLOWING MORE FREQUENT AND
HIGHER RESOLUTION SCANS OF THE
CLIFFS. AND ASSIMILATE THESE
MEASUREMENTS INTO A GROWING
HISTORICAL DATA BASE TO LEARN
WHERE AND WHEN FAILURES HAVE
OCCURRED IN THE PAST AND WHERE
THEY ARE MOST LIKELY TO OCCUR
IN THE FUTURE. A KEY GOAL IS TO
FIND OUT OF ANY SIGNATURE
EXISTS THAT COULD FORETELL OF
HEIGHTENED RISK IN SPECIFIC
LOCATIONS. SECONDLY WE WOULDN'T
INSTRUMENT KEY SITES WITH
GEOTECHNICAL MONITORING
TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPED HERE AT
SCRIPTS IN THE PAST FEW YEARS.
THAT CAN DETECT INFINITESIMAL
DEFORMATIONS OF THE ROCKS.
AGAIN OUR GOAL IS TO LEARN HOW
THE FORMATIONS ARE IMPACTED BY
TIDES LARGE SURFACE GROUNDWATER
AND RAINFALL. TO SEE IF WE CAN
ANSWER THE QUESTION OF WHETHER
SIGNALS EXIST THAT CAN FORECAST
WHERE AND WHEN. AN INCREASE
RISK FOR COLLAPSE IS DEVELOPING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS DWIGHT WORDEN I'M THE DEPUTY
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF DELMARVA
SMALL BEACH TOWN OF FOUR
THOUSAND RESIDENTS BUT WITH
ABOUT THREE MILLION VISITORS A
YEAR COMING TO OUR BEACH DELMAR
HAS ONE OF THE MOST STUDIED
BEACHES AND SEACLIFF SYSTEMS IN
THE US WE'VE BEEN MONITORING ST
MOVEMENTS CLIFF RETREAT STORM
SURGE AND MORE FOR DECADES AND
AS MENTIONED WE'VE BEEN A
PRIMARY STUDY SITE FOR SCRIPTS
WHICH WERE LUCKY TO HAVE HIM
RIGHT NEXT DOOR. WE HAVE A
STATE OF THE ART C. LEVEL RISE
UP PLAN THAT WE'VE ADOPTED IN
DEL MAR ADDRESSING RESILIENCY
AND ADAPTATION WE KNOW A LOT
ABOUT LONG TERM TRENDS
INCLUDING CLIFFORD TREAT AND
WHAT CAN MAKE THEM COLLAPSE
WELL WE DON'T KNOW IS HOW TO
IDENTIFY AREAS LIKELY TO COME
DOWN NOW WE CAN'T TELL YOU IS
IT SAFE TO LAY MY TOWEL ON THE
BEACH IN THIS LOCATION. THIS IS
A HUGE ISSUE FOR LOCAL CITIES
WE'VE HAD DEATHS AS MENTIONED
IN THE CADIA DELMAR TORREY
PINES AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE
UNEXPECTED FROM CLIFFS FAILURES
THAT WERE ARE NOT ABLE TO BE
PROTECTED WE HAVE A RAILROAD AT
RISK IN DEL MAR- IN IS- THE
AUTHORS MENTIONED WITH SERVICE
WAS STOPPED JUST A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO WHEN A MAJOR UNEXPECTED
COLLAPSE OCCURRED. HAND SOLVED
COASTAL ACT AND CHIEF EXISTING
GENERAL PLANT LAW REQUIRES THAT
CITIES LIKE DEL MAR THAT WE ALL
STUDY AND PREPARE AND THAT-
HAZARD ANALYSIS BUT THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE LAW AND THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE RESEARCH
REPERTOIRE TO HELP THE CITY
IDENTIFY WHAT'S AT RISK AND HOW
TO DEAL WITH THAT THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT AB SIXTY
SIX COMPLIMENTS EXISTING LAW
LOOKING AT LONG TERM SEA LEVEL
RISE AND CLIMATE CHANGE BY
ADDING CLIFF FAILURE HAZARDS
AND WARNINGS. IN THE NEAR TERM
LITERATURE RESEARCH SHOWS THERE
ARE AT LEAST TWENTY NINE SYSTEM
WORLDWIDE DOING THIS ALREADY
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE NONE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WE WOULDN'T BE
STARTING AT GROUND ZERO BOTTOM
LINE WE CAN TELL YOU THE LONG
TERM DYNAMICS OF CLIFF RETREAT
WITH PRETTY GOOD ACCURACY BUT
NOT IF IT'S GOING TO FALL ON.
YOU IF YOU VISIT THE BEACH OR
OF THE TRAIN IS GOING OVER THE
CLIFF IN THE NEAR. THIS WILL
PROVIDE CRITICAL FUN TO TAKE US
TO THE STEP TOWARDS. LIVES
THERE'S NO ONE BETTER TO DO
THAT SCRIPTS INSTITUTE OF
OCEANOGRAPHY. PLEASE SUPPORT AB
SIXTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
NEXT DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
SUPPORTER OPPOSE THE BILL. NOT
YET THE BILL. THANK YOU- ANYONE
AT THE REMOTE TESTING LOCATION.
OUR MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB SIXTY SIX MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THE MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST
COMING. NINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THINK YOU ONE COMMON FEAR COULD
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTY SIX. NINE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING KIRK
BLACKBURN ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS SENDEK AND SUPPORT.
NINE ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO
GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS THAT
THE FOURTEEN MINUTES WITH SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THERE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO WE HAVE WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM MISS FRIEDMAN AND THE
SECOND BY MISS GARCIA WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES- I'M SORRY IF
MEMBER QUESTIONS SORRY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I
REALLY HONESTLY DON'T. SEE THE
NEED FOR YOUR BILL- LOOKING AT
THE FEDERAL PROGRAM THROUGH THE
PACIFIC COASTAL AND MARINE
SCIENCE CENTER- ON THE FEDERAL
SIDE THE PRESIDENT CURRENTLY
HAS A PROPOSED- NINE HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS- TO GO TOWARDS THIS
TYPE OF- SITUATION SO I DON'T
REALLY SEE IT EQUITABLE FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE. TO DO A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR JUST ONE PARTICULAR
AREA- YOU KNOW THIS ALSO
EXCLUDES OTHER AREAS LIKE BIG
SIR- THAT WE KNOW HAS
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS EVERY YEAR-
I REALLY THINK IT WOULD BE WHO
OF THE OF SAN DIEGO AND IN OF
OTHERS TO REALLY LOOK AT HOW WE
CAN PARTNER WITH THOSE FEDERAL.
PARTNERS TO ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDING IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
LOOK AT THESE THINGS- SO. I
MEAN THAT'S THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY
COMPARED TO THE- TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION YOU'RE ASKING FOR FROM
THE STATE- AN EXPRESSION WITH
CALVIN AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO STATE
RECOVERY ON IT IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS WHERE I HAVE TO
ASK MYSELF IF. IF THEIR FANS
ARE ALREADY DROPPING A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY
INTO THIS. WHAT CAN WE DO AT
THE STATE LEVEL TO PARTNER WITH
THEM TO USE THE RESEARCH THAT
THEY THEY ARE ALREADY ON GOING
AND DOING- TO FIND THOSE. STATE
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIPS-
CALIFORNIANS INVESTING THAT THE
FUNDING SO. FOR THOSE REASONS I
WILL NOT SUPPORT BUT I DO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. OKAY SO
WE HAVE A MOTION THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SECRETARY Q.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I DON'T
SIX AB SIXTY SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RIVAS I
RIVERSIDE LARA. FLORIDA VOTING
CHILD. CHILD FIVE THREE.
FRIEDMAN I GARCIA GARCIA MATT.
MATHIS NOW MCCARTY WE'RE OUT.
THEY ARE CHAU STONE. STONE I
WOULD. FIVE ONE. THANK YOU THAT
BILL WILL ON CALL. K. NEXT WE
HAVE AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO.
THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING OF MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF PLEASURE
TO A PRESENT THIS BILL IN FRONT
OF YOUR COMMITTEE AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS MONETARY
APPOINTMENT I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX A
MEASURE THAT WILL BUILD ON
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING EFFORTS
TO COMBAT THINK WE'LL USE THE
WASTE WHICH HAS BEEN
EXACERBATED BY COVER NINETEEN
AND REDUCES UNNECESSARY COSTS
FOR BUSINESSES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE AND STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS EVERY YEAR IN THE U.
S. AN ESTIMATED FIVE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO BILLION
DISPOSABLE FOOD WHERE ITEMS ARE
USED RESULTING IN A MASSIVE
FOUR POINT NINE MILLION TONS OF
WASTE AND USE FOOD ACCESSORIES
INCLUDING UTENSILS STRAWS
NAPKINS AND CONDIMENT PACKAGES
CLOG OUR LANDFILLS COMPLICATE
RECYCLING AND POLLUTES STREETS
AND WATERWAYS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES AS WE HAVE
WITNESSED THE PANDEMIC HAS
INCREASED RELIANCE ON TAKE OUT
AND FOOD DELIVERY WHICH
RESTAURANTS HAD RELIED ON. TO
STATE A FLOAT AS SUCH THE USE
OF SINGLE USE WITH ACCESSORIES
HAS CONTRIBUTED TO AN
APPROXIMATE TWO HUNDRED AND
523100% INCREASE IN SINGLE USE
PLASTICS AND A 30% INCREASE IN
WASTE TODAY MANY FOOD
FACILITIES AND FOOD DELIVERY
SERVICES PROVIDE SINGLE USE
FOOD AND BEVERAGE ACCESSORIES
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE NEEDED MOST CONSUMERS
DO NOT WANT THEM AND ALREADY
HAVE REUSABLE ITEMS AT HOME OR
IN THEIR WORKPLACES IN THE END
THESE ACCESSORIES ARE USUALLY
DISCARDED. WITHOUT ACTUALLY
BEING USED IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AB TWELVE THIRTY SIX
EXPANDS THE PLASTIC STRAWS BY
REQUEST LAW TO INCLUDE OTHER
SINGLE USE FOOD ACCESSORIES
MORE FOOD FACILITIES AND THIRD
PARTY DELIVERY PLATFORMS
INCLUDING FOOD THAT IS TAKING
AWAY DELIVERED AND SERVED ON
SITE I WILL KEEP MY COMMENTS
SHORT AND WANT TO TEST MODE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO WE'RE
READY FOR WENT MRS. IN SUPPORT.
MODERATOR. REALLY WE HAVE EMILY
PARKER OR- PERMISSIBLE. YEAH WE
CAN START WITH MS PARKER. GREAT
HEY I CAN YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT
YES. WONDERFUL I'M GOOD MORNING
JERRY NACHMAN HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
ANALLY PARKER I'M A CO DURING
CATCH FOUR HE'LL THE BAY MY
MENTAL MOM IN. GOT. I AM THE
GREEN LINE CALLING IS BONKERS
ASSEMBLY. SEVENTY SIX. MY
MOTHER THE COACH OF THE
REUSABLE CO. WE DEMONSTRATE
SUPPORT OF A TRUMP SIX THE
FLOOD. IN THE ACROSS BOARD FOR
OUR BUSINESS THEY'VE GOT KEEP.
LIVERY THEY OPEN DURING THE TEN
THAT MATCH THEY HAVE NO OPTION
BUT YOU CAN TALK ABOUT. HOWEVER
THERE IS AN OPTION TO BOTH SAVE
MONEY AND CUT DOWN ON WASTE
ONLY THE CLIENT FACTORIES. IF A
CUSTOMER ASKS. ENDLESSLY
ALREADY INTRODUCED MOTIONS THAT
BOTH THE CITY AND THE COUNTY-
COOPER ACCESSORIES UPON REQUEST
SH- ORDINANCE THAT FLYING
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
JUST LAST WEEK THE LA CITY
COUNCIL VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO
PASS THIS MOTION. AND THE MAYOR
HAVE ALREADY INDICATED NINE.
AND OUTRAGE THAT WE CONDUCTED
SO FAR EVERYTHING RESTAURANT
AND EAT BUT CONTINUE IN STRONG
SUPPORT LEGISLATION WHICH WE'VE
ALREADY RECEIVED OVER THREE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED PETITION
SIGNATURES ON INTERMARRIAGE AND
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
WRITTEN COMMENTS OF SUPPORT TO
THE LAPD COUNCIL AND THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. EITHER FROM
RESIDENTS LOCAL BUSINESSES AND
RESTAURANTS AND I'M NOT WORRIED
AND EVEN THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION. THIS IS
BASIC FACT IN LA JUST GOES TO
SHOW HOW NEEDED THIS
LEGISLATION AIMS ON A BROADER
SCALE. ACROSS THE STATE. I MEAN
SHOW THE AND BOTTOM LIKE THIS
ONE CAN SAVE BACKGROUND BETWEEN
THOUSAND AND TWO ONE SOUTH.
DOLLARS EACH TRACTOR REDUCES
WAIT FOR THE OFTEN. WITH EVEN.
IF THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I.
THEY MONEY AND- WANT THE OPTION
THAT THEY LONGER ITEM THEY
DON'T WANT TWENTY. SECOND
FAVORITE AND LOCAL. ALL AGREE
IF I. IN THE WIN. BUT I ABLE
TO. SIX THANK FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU- NEXT WITH. HEY I
CHAIR THE MEMBERS OF THE CA MY
NAME'S KRISTINA FIRM PUBLIC MAN
TO LOOK. AN EMPLOYEE ON CA
BECAUSE WAY RECYCLING NCOME
SIR TO CITIES AND ACROSS CAL.
IN RESPONSE TO OUR CUSTOMERS
DEMAND TAKE OUR ON THE-
POLLUTION CRIME. AND MAKE
RECYCLING. IN THE LONG. WE'RE
HERE TO EIGHTY TWO FACT. THE
LAST FIVE YEARS HAVE BEEN MAJOR
TO THE WAYS TRADE. BY CHINA OUT
CONTENT RISK. MOST RECENTLY THE
PRACTICAL CEMENTED TO THE
BOTTOM CONVENTION THAT FOR
RESTRICT ACCESS TO FOR.
COUNTRIES AND MARKETS HAVE TO.
INCREASES IN KUALA. WE'VE
WAITED TO GO BY AND BEYOND TO
REDUCE. WE HAVE INCREASED OUR
LOCAL ARE EFFORTS AND REDID
ACROSS THE STATE. IN SHORT THE
COST PER TON OF RECYCLING AND
INCREASED WHICH IN TURN
INCREASING BUSINESS RESIDENTS
GARBAGE WELSH. VETERANS SERVICE
WHERE IT'S SMALL PRODUCTS ARE
AMONG MOST DIFFICULT PART TO
REPLY AND CONTENT OTHER REFLECT
BUT- IN A GOOD WAYS THAT IN
WITH GOOD WORD PETER CONTENT BY
MONSTER. AND MARKET. HE PENNY
AMOUNT ON THE ECONOMIC SIDE
PRODUCTS AND OTHER ITEMS LIKE
COME THAT WILL HELP STATE THE
CALL TO RECYCLE. SIMILARLY
MOTOR WHERE AT THREE EVEN KNOWS
TO BE COMPOSED ALL CONTAMINATED
COMPOST STREAMING PROCESS AND
HOPPED THE COMPANY PROGRAM
WORLD TO UP YOU CAN CAL
RECYCLED SB EIGHTY THREE
REGULATE. AT THIS TIME IN A OF
PRACTICAL SERVICE WHERE NEEDED
WITH. NOR CAN HELP. AND ONLY
SERVES TO RECYCLING
ACCOMPLISHED WORKS NOT THAT. AB
TEL SEVENTY SIX ONE SURE THE
ROLE DEALING WITH THE DISEASE.
PRODUCTS IN THE WHICH COULD
HAVE ACT WANTS TO. TRUMP A
DINING EIGHTY TWO ME SO STILL
AFTER COMPLETE THE COUNTRY'S
INTERESTS. BY BE THE PURPOSE.
OR COMPOSTING. THIS WILL ALLOW
JURISDICTION ARE HOLLOW
IMPROPER THERE'S TWO TOGETHER
TO TURN WHAT THE- FOR THE EXTRA
SERVICE ADDRESS THE- SO FAR IN
JURISDICTIONS WITH ABOUT HOW
BEEN GOING TO FOCUS ORDNANCE.
SIMILAR EACH THAT YOU ACT. THAT
YOU'RE A- ARE INTERESTED WITH A-
TO ENSURE. THAT AS MANY OP ARE
OF. TO BUSINESS IT'S THE IT
ALSO TEXAS THE COMMENTS ON
SOLUTIONS HELP OUR SITE PUT
THEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
NECK I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. THAT WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT. SEEING NONE OF
ANYONE AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
LOCATION. IS THERE ARE NONE A
MODERATOR CAN YOU OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
IF YOU'RE NOT ALREADY IN THE-
COMMENT QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE NOT ALREADY IN THE
COMIC YOU YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX. OUR FIRST LINE TO COMMON
IS MINE ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SH GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
OCEAN PROTECTION ORGANIZATION
OSHANA AND OCEAN CONSERVANCY
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
LINE ONE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SURE NUMBER EXTRA FORTY
OFF ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP COUNCIL AND
NATIONAL LEADERSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE
ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MADELINE COOPER FROM NIELSEN
MARKETING OR ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF MARIN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU TO REMEMBER
THE KEY TO CRAPPIE BUT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK. NINE
ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO LINE FIFTY
FOUR LINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS GINNY ALL
DALY I'M A STUDENT AT SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY AND A MEMBER
OF PROPER CHAPTER AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX. NINE ONE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION- CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWENTY
THREE ONE TWENTY THREE YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
MOVING ON TO LINE ONE TWENTY
SEVEN LINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JANEY GIRL ON BEHALF OF
THAT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS KAYLA
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF RETHINK
WASTE AND BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE ONE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS
GENEVIEVE ADDED ON HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ELEVEN CLEAN FEES
LOBBYING COALITION
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE PROBABLY
SPONSORING THIS BILL IN SUPPORT
STRONG SUPPORT ALSO WITH THE
INTENTION OF REDUCING CALL IN
AIR TIME I AM REGISTERING
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE CONSERVATION VOTERS
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
CLEAN WATER ACTION CALPERS
CALIFORNIA COOKIE PEARLAND
AUDUBON CALIFORNIA COURAGE
CALIFORNIA THE LEAGUE TO SAVE
LAKE TAHOE THE STORY OF STUFF
PROJECT HABITS OF WASTE
COMMUNITY ENVIRONMENTAL COUNCIL
CAFE AQUATICA. PIER TWENTY
THREE CAFE AND RESTAURANT AND
SAY THAN AND PATAKI RESTAURANT
THANK YOU. LINE NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
PROBABLY THE ONLY DIRECTLY
IMPACTED PARTY CALLING IN ON
THIS BUT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION.
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S EFFORTS ON THIS AND WE
ARE WORKING PRODUCTIVELY WITH
THE AUTHORED SECTION THREE THAT
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE COMMENDED OF
COURSE WE ALIGN AND APPRECIATE
THE NOTION OF NEEDING TO MAKE A
REQUEST FOR THESE ACCESSORIES-
WE WOULD LIKE AND HAVE
SUGGESTED A NUMBER OF WAYS THAT
THOSE- SUGGESTIONS COULD BE
IMPROVED TO OFFER CUSTOMERS A
FEW MORE OPTIONS TO MAKE THAT
REQUEST- AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT
WE CAN GET THERE BASED ON-
MEETINGS WITH THE SPONSORING
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE. SECTION
FOR I WANT TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO BECAUSE THAT GOES
RIGHT INTO DINING ROOMS AND
RESTAURANTS AND IT MANDATES
THAT WE NOT USE ANY SINGLE USE
PRODUCTS IN THE DINING ROOMS OF
RESTAURANTS AND AS YOU ALL KNOW
RESTAURANTS DINING ROOMS HAVE
BEEN LARGELY CLOSED FOR THE
LAST YEAR. WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THAT WE HAVE A
HISTORY OF OPPOSING THOSE TYPES
OF PROPOSALS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND WE CERTAINLY PLEASE
CONTINUE TO TREAD LIGHTLY WITH
NEW MANDATES ON RESTAURANT
DINING ROOMS AT THIS TIME. WHEN
WERE BARELY OPERATING THANK YOU.
NINE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS JARED COLE AND THE STUDENT
AT UC SAN DIEGO AND THE CHAIR
OF CALPERS STUDENTS CHAPTER
UCSD AND I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELFTH. SEVENTY SIX. LINE ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY ONE TWENTY
SIX YOU MAY BE ON ME PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MOVING ON TO LINE ONE
TWENTY TWO LINE ONE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH MY MOM TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KEEP THEM
GRABBED YOU HEAR ME NOW WE CAN
YES. I THINK MANAGER KEEP WITH
CLUB WERE PLEASE TO SUPPORT TO
BE TALKED OF THE FIX THE PUBS
JOINT COLLAPSE CUT WE CAN. AND
COMMITTED TO MAKING THERE ARE
AND BURN REMAINS. PRIOR HERE
AND HOW THANKS VERY MUCH. NINE
EIGHTY. YOUR LINE OPEN GO AHEAD.
SHARES OF COLUMN THE SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA CORONER'S
REPORT OF AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX. THANK. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AND CUTE I'M SORRY-
NINE ONE TWENTY SIX WHEN ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
TWENTY SIX YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
TO MAKE YOU. THANK YOU TIME TO
IT DOES ANY MEMBER HAVE A
QUESTION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA AT THANK YOU TO THE
OTHERFOR- BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I KNOW OFTENTIMES- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH ALL
THE PLASTIC THAT COMES IN IN MY
BAG WHEN I FORGET TIME AHEAD OF
TIME THE PLASTIC. CYPRESSES
THAT AND I APPRECIATE- YOUR
EXPANSION OF THE ORIGINAL OF
STRAW BILL I KNOW YOU BUILDING
ON THAT TO INCLUDE DELIVERY
PLATFORMS AND SO FORTH ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE PREVIOUS
BILL THAT YOU'RE BUILDING ON
DIDN'T INCLUDE FAST FOOD
RESTAURANTS IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU ARE CONSIDERING AT ANY
POINT TO LOOK AT AS WELL. THE
INTENT IS FOR FOOD DELIVERY. SO
IF- YOU'RE ORDERING THROUGH. AN
APP LIKE YOU HEARD GRUBHUB-
TESTIFY JUST NOW. IT'S THE IDEA
THAT- YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO
CHOOSE AN OPTION. WHETHER YOU
WOULD BE ABLE TO- RECEIVE THAT
PLASTIC- THE TITLE IN YOUR
DELIVERY WILL CERTAINLY LOOK
INTO THE DETAILS OF IF YOU'RE
ACTUALLY AT THE RESTAURANT.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
CONSIDERING AS WELL. SO IF I
ORDER MCDONALD'S TO GRAB THEM I
WOULD BE TAKING CARE OF. THAT
IS THE GOAL AND INTENT YES IT'S
GREAT. TO BE ABLE TO OFFER YOU
THE OPTION THANK YOU FOR THAT
WORK. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU- A OF.
WHEN I FIRST READ YOUR BILL
LIKE I THOUGHT. I LOVE THIS
BILL ONLINE YOU KNOW WHAT I.
WOULD LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR-
BUT THEN OF COURSE YOU KNOW I.
OF HEARING THE SOME OF THE
DETAILS THAT I HAPPEN TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO REVIEW- AS THE
CONCERNS FROM THE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION I WOULD LOVE TO
HEAR. MORE MAYBE MY OFFICE
RECEIVED A LETTER FROM THE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION. IF I
DID DIE I'D LIKE TO. TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT BUT- YEAH I THINK
YOUR BILL IS VERY TIMELY AND
ONE OF THOSE. I'M SURE.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO. YOU
KNOW GET MY FOOD TO TAKE OUT
AND THINKING DANG I FORGOT TO
TELL THEM DUE TO LEAVE THE
TONSILS OUT- SO- ON THE BUDGET
YOU KNOW WE JUST FALLING OVER
MS GARCIA'S QUESTIONS SO. IF I
GO TO A LOCAL A LOCAL
RESTAURANT. AND I CAN I GET
TAKE OUT- AND THEY HAVE THE
UTENSILS AND THEIR- THIS BILL
APPLIES TO. THE PLASTIC
UTENSILS IF YOU ACTUALLY GO TO
THE RESTAURANT AND PICK IT UP
YOURSELF THAT'S RIGHT SO THOSE
ARE THE DETAILS THAT WERE
IRONING OUT WITH A CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION TO MAKE
IT ONE IT'S AN OPTION FOR THE
CONSUMER RIGHT TO AND IF YOU
NEED THEM YOU SHOULD GET THEM
BUT YOU SHOULDN'T JUST GET THEM
AND THEN ENDS UP IN THE TRASH-
IN YOUR- YOU KNOW SECRET SAUCE
AND UTENSIL DRAWER IN YOUR
KITCHEN- AND WORKING OUT THOSE
DETAILS AND I RECOGNIZE THERE
ARE DIFFERENT TYPES OF. THERE
ARE DIFFERENT TYPES OF-
RESTAURANTS SO THERE'S THAT
TABLE SETTING RIGHT AND THEN
THERE'S FAST FOOD AND SO WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT LIKE WHERE
WE ACTUALLY LAND TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL BURDENS
BUT THE BUT THE CONVERSATIONS
HAVE BEEN FRUITFUL AND I KNOW
AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL GET
TO A GOOD PLACE OKAY- WELL LIKE
I WILL BE IN SUPPORT OF. THIS
BILL TODAY THANK. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN WELL AS MUCH AS
ALL THIS STUFFING MORE OF THOSE
TAKE OUT FORKS AND KNIVES INTO
THAT DOOR ALONG WITH A LITTLE
TOUCH OF CONTAINERS I'M LOOKING
FOR THIS BILL I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THAT I HOPE YOU MAKE IT AS
EXPENSIVE AS PROCESS AS
POSSIBLE YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE
DOING PICK UP YOU REALLY SHOULD
HAVE THE SAME OPTION BECAUSE
MOST PEOPLE IF THEY WOULD ASK
FOR UTENSILS OR- TICKET BE
TAKING HOME THIS DAY IN AGE OR-
HAVE THEIR OWN UTENSILS IN THE
CAR. THE REVIEWS THEM OUT BUT I
DO WANT TO JUST ALSO SAY THAT
YOU KNOW RESTAURANTS CERTAINLY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THIS NOW
AND EVEN GRUB HUB AND THOSE
KINDS OF- DELIVERIES COULD
PROGRAM THIS INTO THEIR OWN
ORDERING SYSTEM THEIR AUTOMATED
ORDERING SYSTEMS OF OPTING IN
OUR OPTING OUT. AND SO I'M NOT
SAYING THAT YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE
YOUR BILL I THINK YOU SHOULD
BUT I THINK IT'S BECAUSE THE
RESTAURANTS HAVE BEEN VERY LOOK
VERY. A LACKADAISICAL ABOUT
THIS AND- I JUST HOPE THAT ALL
BUSINESSES LOOK FOR WAYS TO
REDUCE PLASTIC RIBBON AND MAKE
THEIR OWN BUSINESSES MORE
SUSTAINABLE- YOU KNOW WE DON'T
HAVE TO TAKE ACTION IF THEY
WERE ACTING MORE RESPONSIBLY
AND THE TRUTH IS THEY'RE NOT
ACTING RESPONSIBLY AND MANY
RESTAURANTS DO ASK YOU AT THIS
POINT AND I COMMEND THEM FOR
THAT. AND SO I YOU KNOW IT'S
HARD TO HAVE A LOT OF SYMPATHY
WITH YOU KNOW- INDUSTRY IN
GENERAL WHEN THEY SORT OF DON'T
TAKE ON A PROBLEM THAT THEY'RE
CREATING AND SORT OF WAY FOR US
TO COME IN AND THEN GET MAD
THAT WE TRY TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT. SO I DON'T THINK THE
AUTHOR I LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL. AND
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO SUPPORT
TODAY. THANK YOU. MISTER MATHIS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- REALLY
LIKE WHERE WE'RE HEADS THAT
WITH THIS ONE I UNDERSTAND THE
PROBLEM I THINK WE SEE IT EVERY
DAY READ REGARDLESS OF WHERE
OUR DISTRICT IS THE INCREASED
AMOUNT OF TRASH THAT WERE SEEN.
MY CONCERN IS WITH GOING TO
BROUGHT IT IN IT WAS A CONCERN
I REMEMBER WHEN- MISTER
CALDERON WAS DOING THE PLASTIC
STRAW BAN AND I KEPT THINKING
WE- DON'T WE'RE GOING AFTER THE
STRAWS WEREN'T GOING AFTER THE
PACKAGE. YOU KNOW IT'S THESE
THINGS ARE- PACKAGED IN PLASTIC
BECAUSE A LOT OF ROOM YOU KNOW
YOU GET A LITTLE CONTINENT
THINGS OR- WHAT WHY ARE WE
ADDRESSING THAT. IN TAKING YOU
KNOW TARGETING THAT FIRST. ONTO
TO JUST SIMPLY GO OKAY LET'S
MAKE SURE THESE ARE GOING TO
PAPER NINE AND CUT DOWN THE
WASTE THAT WAY- I DO LIKE THE
OCT INVERSES THE OPT OUT BUT
AND TELL THE- DETAILS ARE FULLY
IRONED OUT UNLESS THEY OFFER
YOUR BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO THE CLOSE YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE MEMBERS
FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND-
CONSIDERATION OF THE BILL. I
WOULD SAY THAT. AB TOLL SEVENTY
SIX IS A WASTE REDUCTION
MEASURE THAT REDUCES WEIGHT OF
STRING BEFORE IT ACTUALLY- IS
CREATED. AND IN FACT IT IT'LL
SAVE URBAN AND RURAL COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE OFCALIFORNIA
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FACT US
THE RESTAURANTS IN THE UNITED
STATES CURRENTLY SPEND ABOUT
NINETEEN BILLION. PURCHASING
DISPOSABLE FOOD WHERE AND
CALIFORNIA ALONE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SPEND. ALMOST UP TO
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
ANNUALLY AND ONGOING EFFORTS TO
CLEAN UP AND PREVENT LITTERING
THE STREETS STORMS. STORM
DRAINS DRAINS BOB PARKS AND
WATERWAYS SO FOR LOOKING AT
WAYS IN WHICH WE REDUCE COSTS
THIS IS A SIMPLE. WAY THAT WE
CAN DO THAT IT'S EFFECTIVE IT'S
ABOUT HOW WE CONSUME HOW WE ACT
TOWARDS OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
MAKE IT EASIER- I DO WANT TO
SAY- I CONVENED A- A SMALL
GROUP OF RESTAURANTS SMALL
RESTAURANT OWNERS. IN MY
DISTRICT. BECAUSE I AM VERY
AWARE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
THEY HAVE FACED AMID COVERT
NINETEEN. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT CAME UP WAS THE 1% SAVINGS
SO IF A RESTAURANT A SMALL
RESTAURANT CAN SAVE ONE
PERCENT. IN THE BOTTOM LINE
WHICH IS WHAT THEY'RE SPENDING
IN PLASTIC WHERE THAT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A NEW JOB. IT'S
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
REINVEST IN THE RESTAURANT IT'S
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO. NOT
WASTE THEIR MONEY ON SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO GO IN TE TRASH
VERSUS THE VERY REAL. ECONOMIC
RECOVERY EFFORTS THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES ACROSS OUR STATE AND
SPECIFICALLY SMALL RESTAURANTS
NEED TO DO RIGHT NOW IN AN
EFFORT TO. YOU KNOW BRING US
BACK TO THE NORMAL THING IN A
WAY THAT SAFE. AMID COVERT
NINETEEN SO WE ARE WORKING VERY
HARD TO. ACHIEVE THE GOALS THAT
WE NEED TO ACHIEVE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I WILL.
THANK U. S. MEMBER CARILLO FROM
PRESENTING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE- TO REDUCE UNNECESSARY
WASTE I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
TODAY. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE. SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I DON'T SEVEN AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE
FLORA. LARA NOT VOTING CHAU
CHAU HI FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I
GARCIA GARCIA I MATHIS. MATHIS
NOT VOTING MCCARTY MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I SAY ARE CHAU.
STONE STONE I WOULD. SIX ZERO
KIDNAPPED BILLS OUT BUT WILL
REMAIN ON CALL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I NEXT UP WE HAVE AB EIGHT
EIGHT ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WITH. THANK YOU. FOR I'LL BE
QUICK THEN THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE BILL IT ADDS TO THE
TRANSPARENCY OF WHAT WHAT WE
CALL RECYCLABLE IS REALLY BEING
RECYCLED AND NOT TO SHIP TO A
FOREIGN COUNTRY AND DISPOSED OF
IN WAYS THAT WE WOULDN'T
CONSIDER AS RECYCLING THAT'S
WHAT THE BILL DOES A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. HE
THANK YOU- WE ARE READY FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. HI GOOD
MORNING AGAIN THIS OF THE NIQAB
OF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND- WANTED
TO EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO
ON AMERICAN POLICY FOR TAKING
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AND TO
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO HAVE
ACTUALLY ENGAGED IN A VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE. CONVERSATION
AROUND MAKING THIS WORK- FOR TO
LONG CALIFORNIA COUNTY MATERIAL
BEING RECYCLED AS SOON AS THEY
GO INTO SHIPPING CONTAINER HAD
OVERSEE. AND UNFORTUNATELY
WE'VE BECOME ALL TOO FAMILIAR
WITH THE FACT THAT MUCH OF THE
MATERIAL HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
MISMANAGED- IF YOU ARE IF YOU
HAPPEN TO WATCH JOHN OLIVER
SHOWED HAPPY CAN BE THOUGHT AND
FOOTAGE OF THAT. AND I KIND OF
PUT IT IS BECOMING MORE AND
MORE REGULAR. AND A LOT WHILE
SOME MATERIAL WITH DEFINITELY
HIM STARTED- ONCE WE GOT
OVERSEAS IT WAS DONE SO UNDER
UNACCEPTABLE ENVIRONMENTAL
LABOR CONDITIONS. WHERE PEOPLE
BASICALLY LOOKING FOR THE FEW
LEFTOVER RECYCLABLES THAT WERE
STILL IN THE MIX OF- ON
RECYCLABLE GARBAGE THAT WE SENT
OVER. AND THEN MOST OF THE
MATERIAL END UP GETTING
LANDFILLS DUMPED OR BURNED. AND
POLLUTING COMMUNITIES ALL OVER
SOUTHEAST ASIA- THE SLIDE TO
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD
ASKING FOR NEXT FIVE WAYS TO BE
RECLASSIFIED AS HAZARDOUS WASTE
UNDER THE INTERNATIONAL PEOPLE
CONVENTION. BEGINNING JANUARY
OF THIS YEAR SO RIGHT NOW IT IS
ACTUALLY LEGAL FOR THE MOST
ALMOST EVERY COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD TO IMPORT. ON THE U. S.
SEVEN IN RESPONSE TO THAT MANY
OF THE STATE- BIGGEST WASTE
HAULERS INCLUDING WASTE
MANAGEMENT FOR PUBLIC RECALL G.
HAVE MADE PUBLI COMMITMENTS TO
STOP EXPORTING NEXT POCKET
OVERSEAS. BUT IF THEY CONTINUE
TO BE A LEADING EXPORTER OF THE
MATERIAL AND VIOLATION OF THE
PEOPLE CONNECTION. THIS BILL
WILL DO A FEW SIMPLE THINGS
YEAH I THINK MOST IMPORTANTLY
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IT WILL
RESTORE THE PUBLIC FAITH IN THE
RECYCLING SYSTEM. THANK THE
PUBLIC WILL NO LONGER HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THEIR RECYCLABLES
CONTRIBUTING. TO THE
INTERNATIONAL POLLUTION THAT
THEY REGULARLY SEE ON THE
EVENING NEWS- I THINK THAT'S AN
EXISTENTIAL ISSUE FOR RECYCLING.
AT EIGHT IT WILL ALSO KEEP MANY
FACTORS TO BE ABLE TO GREEN
WASH THEIR PRODUCT THOSE
RECYCLABLE DESPITE NOT ACTUALLY
HAVING ANY RECYCLING MARKET.
BECAUSE THEY GO IN A SHIPPING
CONTAINER THEY CAN ACT LIKE IT
IS BEING RECYCLED. IT ALSO
DRIVE INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA
RECYCLING MARKET. AND CREATE
LOCAL JOBS AND FINALLY IT'LL
CREATE AN EVEN REGULATORY
PLAYING FIELD BETWEEN THOSE
COMPANIES WHO ARE DOING THE
RIGHT THING AND COMPLYING WITH
INTERNATIONAL LAW. AND THOSE
WHO AREN'T. FOR THIS REASON WE
REGARD YOUR AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHT ONE AND AGAIN LIKE
TO COMMEND THE CALL NUMBER THE
BALLOTS FOR TAKING ON THIS LONG
OVERDUE ISSUE. THANK YOU WE'RE
READY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. THAT WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT. CASEY NINE. ANYONE AT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION.
I DON'T SEE ANY OF MODERATOR P.
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'RE
NOT ALREADY IN THE QUESTION
QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS. ONE AND
THEN ZERO TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION AB. EIGHT EIGHT
ONE. NINE ONE TWENTY ONE JUST A
BRIEF MOMENT. WHEN ONE TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AGAIN MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS JENNIFER HEARING
ON BEHALF OF THE OCEAN
CONSERVANCY WE EXPRESSED ON
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT
ONE THANK YOU. EVERBRIGHT
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I REMEMBER
THINKING ACROSS THE AGAIN WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND CHILD SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ALICE
STATLER I'M A RESIDENT OF
RITUALS FOR EAST AND RIGHT NEXT
TO THE OCEAN A FRIEND OF MINE
PADDLES OUT AND- COLLECT-
CARPET CLASSIC FROM- THE
HARBOR. YEAH L. A. HARPER AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL- YOU KNOW YOUR TO ACTION
DOES ABOUT. EXPORT AND I THINK
IT'S SCANDALOUS TO HAVE PEOPLE
THINKING THEY'RE RECYCLING WHAT
IS ACTUALLY- CONTRIBUTED TRASH
I WILL SAY ALSO THAT ALL THOSE.
COMPLYING WITH THE BATTLE
CONVENTION- THE REBEL
CONVENTION MY MIND IS NOT GOING
STRONG ENOUGH IF THERE ACTUALLY
IS SAYING THAT AND MIX OF
POLYETHYLENE POLYPROPYLENE. AND
POLY ETHYLENE TEREPHTHALATE- IS
IF THAT HAVE A MIX OF THAT IS
GOING TO BE SHORT RECYCLABLE
THOSE ARE INDIVIDUALLY
RECYCLABLE BUT ALTOGETHER WE
SHOULD. WE SHOULD ESTABLISH A
RECYCLING- AND RE USE-
CAPABILITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE U. S. A. AND STOP
HAVING NON REUSABLE RECYCLABLE.
PLASTICS THANK YOU. MIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
HERE NUMBERS PERSONAL AGAIN-
WITH NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
ACTION COUNCIL AND CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
TWENTY FOUR. YOUR GOOD MORNING
MANAGER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CONSISTING WITH THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL- IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ALL CAN BE DONE- WHAT PART OF
ONE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. NINE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI LEARN
COLORS HERE CUT CALIFORNIA CON
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT EIGHTY
ONE THANK YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MELISSA ROMERO AT THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE ONE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS THIS IS MICHAEL BACK
WITH THE PANDA KAYLEE ON BEHALF
OF REPUBLIC SURGEONS WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US SOMETHING
CONCERNS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THE BILL AS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED. THANK YOU. ONE
SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI BONNIE BY
ALL OF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE CALLING INTO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR SAVE OUR SHORES
PLASTIC POLLUTION COALITION FOR
SECOND GENERATION VISORS
UPSTREAM AND THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA RECYCLING
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. NINE ONE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO KELLY
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF RETHINK
WASTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JIM WILDER
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE FRENCH
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT EIGHT ONE THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY I'M
SORRY ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE ONE
LAST COMMENT. ONE MOMENT FOR
THE LINE IMPROVE.
IT'LL BE JUST
A BRIEF MOMENT FOR THAT ONE.
ONE ONE THIRTY TWENTY ONE
THIRTY NINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GO AHEAD. YEAH NINE ONE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING TOUGH NONPROFIT
CALIFORNIA COMPOST COALITION IS
FROM SUPPORT THANK. AND THERE
ARE NO LONGER OPEN THERE'S-
THANK YOU I'M NEXT WE HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS ALL START
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- MISS
GONZALEZ I REALLY LOVE WHERE
YOU'RE GOING WITH THIS I THINK
WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO ENSURE A GOOD
CORPORATE SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
WHEN IT COMES TO OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH RECYCLABLES FONG I
WOULD LIKE TO JOIN YOU AS A
JOINT AUTHORS IN THIS ENDEAVOR
IF YOU'LL HAVE ME SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY SHOW A FULL PUSH. ON
TO ENSURE THIS ACTUALLY HAPPENS
AND FRANKLY I'D LIKE TO SEE- A
LITTLE MORE TEETH BE PUT INTO
THIS- TO GO AFTER THE BAD
ACTORS IF YOU'LL TAKE GREAT
TWENTY. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA NO NOT A
QUESTION BUT A COMMENT. THANK
YOU FOR THIS BILL IT'S- FOR A
LONG TIME THIS IS THAT OUR
DIRTY LITTLE SECRET CALIFORNIA
IS THE FIFTH BIGGEST ECONOMY
PRODUCES A LOT OF. OF PLASTIC
THAT WE LEAVE LESS RECYCLING IS
NOT BEING RECYCLED- AND WE ALSO
GET TO BE LEADERS IN THE SPACE
ITSELF THANK YOU FOR TAKING US
FROM. OTHER STATES WERE AT TO
BE LEADERS IN THE SPACE AND I
SEE- BEING HONEST WITH
CONSUMERS ABOUT WHAT IS AND
ISN'T EXACTLY IT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP. AN INCREASE IN
TURNING THE SYSTEM AROUND IN
EDUCATING THE PUBLIC IN MAKING
SURE BEING RESPONSIBLE STEWARDS
OF THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS. THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR OFFER OTHER
ANALYSTS THE RESOLUTION AS WELL
SO THAT. WE'RE TACKLING THIS
FROM ALL SIDES. OKAY THANK YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECT ASK CAN I HAVE A- CASE
THANKS. THE MOTION WE HAVE A
MOTION OF. MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA- SECONDED BY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLORA THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY KEEP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HI MATE AB EIGHT EIGHTY
ONE FIVE MEMBER RANDY GONZALEZ
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS RIVAS. I
RIVERSIDE FLORA. LAURA HI CHAU
CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE
GARCIA GARCIA AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY MURATSUCHI
WELL TWO G. I.'S AIRTEL HI THEY
ARE TO AYE STONE. STONE I WOULD.
NINE ZERO THANK YOU. THE BILL
IS OUT NEXT WE HAVE AB. ONE
NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING SUGGESTED COMMITTEE
AND MOMENTS A THROUGH F. IN THE
ANALYSIS AND WILL BE CONTINUING
DISCUSSION ON SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT G. WITH BOTH THE
COMMITTEE AND STAKEHOLDERS
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETEEN CODIFIES
GOVERNOR NEWSOM TWENTY TWENTY
PARTS OF GOVERNANCE IN TWENTY
TWENTY EXECUTIVE ORDER ALLOWING
CERTAIN FILING AND POSTING
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT TO CONTINUE BEING
CARRIED OUT. ELECTRONICALLY THE
COSBY NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
PUSHED GOVERNMENT AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO RETHINK HOW
IT CONDUCTS BUSINESS EVOLVING
TO EMBRACE THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY. TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE.
WHILE REDUCING COSTS AND
INCREASING TRANSPARENCY PAPER
FILING AND MAIL REQUEST OF
SECRET DOCUMENTS IS OUTDATED
AND CUMBERSOME IT INHIBITS
PUBLIC ACCESS IS EXPENSIVE. AND
LIMITS PUBLIC INPUT IN
DEVELOPMENT AND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETEEN. UPDATES THE SECRET
PROCESS TO REFLECT AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY AND WILL IMPROVE
PUBLIC ACCESS AND INPUT FOR
PROJECTS. ACROSS CALIFORNIA. ON
THE PHONE TESTIFIES LAUREN THE
BLOOD VALENCIA YOU SUNSHINE AS
FROM THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION AND ADAM REGULA
FROM THE CALCHAMBER THANK YOU.
EXACTLY THANK YOU OUR MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
FOUR POINTER OPEN GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AREN'T
ABLE ONE PAIR REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
PLEASED TO BE HERE AND SUPPORT
AS AMENDED ON MARCH
SEVENTEENTH- WE DO APPRECIATE
THE- EXTENSION OF THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER AND
THINK THAT THIS DOES NOT HELP
ENCOURAGE TRANSPARENCY AND
PUBLIC ACCESS- WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVIN'S EFFORTS AGAIN ON THIS
ISSUE AND ARE- PLEASED TO BE
HERE SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ADAM RIGHTLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ALSO TESTIFYING. IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT ONE NINE AS
AMENDED WE WANT A FIRST BEGIN
BY APPRECIATE ANY- AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT SOME OF
OUR AMENDMENT. TO ADDRESS- THE
APPLICANT LANGUAGE AND- WE
SUPPORT AB ONE NINE WHICH
ESSENTIALLY REQUIRES THE AGENCY
TO POST ON THEIR WEBSITE. LIKE
TRONIC LEE HE QUIT NOTICES AND
OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
DOCUMENT. HE WASPRIMARILY
DESIGNED TO IDENTIFY AND
DISCLOSE I PUBLIC FOR TO THE
PUBLIC ANY POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT. AND TO MITIGATE THOSE.
TO THE EXTENT FEASIBLE AND WE
THINK AB EIGHT ONE NINE. IS
REALLY CODIFYING AGENCY BEST
PRACTICES OF PROVIDING THE
PUBLIC WITH ELECTRONIC NOTICE
AND OTHER SPEAK WHAT DOCUMENTS
THAT DOES. FURTHER THE
TRANSPARENCY INTENT OF FIFA AND
BETTER INFORM THE PUBLIC. WE
THINK THAT HE WENT PAST FIVE
DECADES AGO DIDN'T CONTEMPLATE
THE INTERNET NOR DIGITIZATION
OF DOCUMENTS AND AB EIGHT ONE
NINE WILL PROVIDE A WELCOME TO
UPDATE HE GREW UP. BY BRINGING
PEOPLE REALLY KNOW THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY OF- PROVIDING THE
DOCUMENTS ELECTRONICALLY WHICH
MANY AGENCIES DO. I WILL NOT
ONE OUTSTANDING ISSUE THAT THE
AUTHOR COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING.
AND THAT IT'S ANY UNINTENDED
BUT POTENTIALLY- CHANGES TO
COMMENT PERIOD UNDER SEQUEL WE
SUPPORT THE AUTHOR'S INTENT TO-
INSURE AB ONE NINE. ONLY
IMMENSELY QUICK TO REQUIRE THE
DOCUMENTS BE POSTED AND PROVIDE
ELECTRONICALLY BUT DOES NOT
OTHERWISE CHANGE THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE STATUTE FOR
THESE REASONS. WE ARE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WITNESS PLEASE. OKAY NO NO
FURTHER WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
OKAY THANK YOU- NEXT I'D LIKE
TO OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM. C.
NINE ON ANYONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION. THERE ARE
NONE A MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND IF YOU'RE
NOT ALREADY IN THE COMIC QUEUE.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB. EIGHT ONE
NINE. NINE ONE SEVENTEEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHRIS ANDERSON ON
BEHALF ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WITH
POSITION OF SUPPORT OF
COMMENDED WHERE SUPPORT OF THE
EFFORTS IN THE BILL THAT
STREAMLINED THE SEQUIN NOTICING
US INQUIRE MEANT. JUSTIN
HIGHLIGHTED BILLS FAMILY
WRITTEN COULD BE READ TO EXTEND
COMMENTARIES FOR VERY EQUAL
DOCUMENTS TOP WAS UNDERSTANDING
THIS WAS NOT THE OTHER TOP
THERE'S INTENT WHICH IS WHY WE
HAVE TO SUPPORT THEM IN THE
POSITION WE SUBMITTED WRITTEN
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD RESOLVE.
THE CONFLICT OF LAW PARTIES
HERE HAVE COMMUNICATED INTENT
WORK PROPERLY SOLVE THE ISSUE I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
STAFF AND COMMITTEE STAFFER
CONTINUING. TO WORK ON THIS
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
CA IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
YES AGAIN- MR LEVINE I'D LIKE
TO ADD ON IS GOING AUTHOR AND
HELP YOU WITH THIS- I'M ALSO
WORKING ON A BUDGET TRAILER
BILL ON TO IMPROVE OUR-
TECHNOLOGY BEING THAT- WE HAD
OUT BUDGET HEARING IN AND FOUND
OUT THAT OUR COMPUTER SYSTEMS
IN THE STATE ARE THIRTY TO
TWENTY YEARS OLD- SO I'M TRYING
TO ADDRESS THAT AS WELL BUT I'D
I'D LIKE TO HELP YOU WITH THIS
IF WE NEED TO GET OUR SYSTEMS
UPDATED. THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
FOR MEMBERS. OKAY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS WAS A BILL THAT WE
BEGAN WORKING ON LAST YEAR AND
I WANT TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE
TO YOUR STAFF HAVE BEEN PAYING
ATTENTION TO IT SINCE THEN FOR.
RESPECT LAST WHEN I GO. THANK
YOU- WE HAVE A MOTION. FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORISTS
SECONDED. BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS. THE MOTION IS. DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- SECRETARY CAME
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I DON'T
NINE AB EIGHT NINETEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE THEMOTION IS TO PASS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RIVAS I
RIVERSIDE FLORA. FLORA I'D
CHILD CHILD FIVE FRIEDMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA. MATHIS
MATHIS I MCCARTY WHERE THIRTY
TWO G. I.'S AIRTEL HI THERE
TELL US STONE. SO I WOULD WOOD
FIVE NINE ZERO THANK YOU THANK
YOU. K. NEXT UP WE HAVE AB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
COLLEAGUES TO SEE EVERYBODY
ELECTED THEY COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR- ALL OF YOUR CONSIDERATION
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS LEGISLATION.
AND IT SEEMS THAT RECENTLY- A
LOT OF ATTENTION HAS BEEN
PLACED ON IT NATURAL CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS ARE NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS. IN A LAND
CONSERVATION RESTORATION AND
STRATEGIC LAND MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES AND INCORPORATING
THESE NATURAL- SOME SOLUTIONS
INTO EFFORTS TO MITIGATE
INCREASING AMOUNTS OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS- YOU
KNOW ESSENTIALLY LEVERAGING OUR
FARMS RANCHES FORESTS.
GRASSLANDS AND WETLANDS TO HELP
REMOVE CARBON FROM OUR
ATMOSPHERE AND CLEARLY THERE IS
AN OBVIOUS NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
RESEARCH WHEN IT COMES TO FULLY
UNDERSTANDING AND VALIDATING
CARBON SEQUESTRATION RATES TO
OUR STATE'S NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS- BUT THE SCIENCE IS CLEAR
NOW ACCORDING TO A
GROUNDBREAKING STUDY THAT WAS
RELEASED IN AUGUST OF LAST
YEAR. CALLED IT WAS GETTING TO
NEUTRAL OPTIONS FOR NEGATIVE
CARBON EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO STORE VAST AMOUNTS
OF CARBON. NOT TO MENTION OFTEN
IMPORTANT- SOME CALL BENEFITS
TO AIR AND WATER QUALITY.
ECOSYSTEM AND SOIL HEALTH
RESILIENCE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
AND PROTECTION OF LIFE AND
PROPERTY TWO FIRE REDUCTION. A
NATURAL WORKING LANDS IS ALSO-
THAT'S CONSIDERED THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE AMONG CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS- BUT MOST OF US CAN
AGREE THAT WE HAVE REACHED THE
POINT OUR CLIMATE CRISIS WHERE
WE MUST URGENTLY AND
CREATIVELY. DEVELOP NEW
PATHWAYS TO REDUCE AND REMOVE
CARBON FROM OUR ATMOSPHERE-
IT'S OF THIS LEGISLATION
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHT FOUR IS
INTENDED TO HELP OUR STATE
IDENTIFY STRATEGIES. TO
INTEGRATE OUR NATURAL WORKING
LANCE'S ASSETS IN THAT FIGHT.
AND SO THIS BILL WOULD SET IN
STATUTE AND REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO WORK IN COLLABORATION WITH
RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. TO IDENTIFY
CLIMATE GOAL FOR THE STATE'S
NATURAL WORKING LANDS WHILE
IDENTIFYING BEST PRACTICES AND
POLICY INCENTIVES. IN ACHIEVING
THIS GOAL- AND SO WITH ME TODAY
IS- LUCAS- FREE REX WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND JEANNIE
MERYL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE.
NETWORK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU. UP IF. MODERATE CAN
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. GREAT
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE CONCERN ABOUT THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND WHEN I
THINK I SOME OF OUR READERS FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL
FIRSTLY BUT ALSO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEAK TODAY
RIGHT NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED NATURE FOR OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HEALTH OF OUR
CLIMATE AND EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY
FOUR WOULD HELP ADVANCE BOTH
OUTCOMES AS WELL AS IN OTHER
IMPORTANT BENEFITS. OVER THE
PAST DECADE THERE'S BEEN
SIGNIFICANT WORK IN CALIFORNIA
ON THIS TOPIC ESTIMATING GHG
REDUCTION POTENTIAL ACCOUNTING
METHOD NOT DEFINED A RANGE OF
BENEFITS THAT WILL RESULT FROM
CRIME ACTION AFTER WORKING LAND
SECTOR. IN SPITE OF ALL THIS
WORK THOUGH A CLEAR CLIMATE
GOAL AND COORDINATED SUSTAINED
ACTION LIKE WE HAVE IN OTHER
SECTORS IS STILL MISSING.
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR IS AN
IMPORTANT CATALYST TO HELP
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AT PROVIDE
BUT USUALLY LEADERSHIP ON THE
ISSUE RECOGNIZING THE STATE'S
NATIONAL WORKING LANDS ARE
ESSENTIAL PART OF MEETING THE
STATE KIND OF BOLD. ADVANTAGE
AGENCY COORDINATION WITH A
CLEAR LEAD THIS IS CRITICAL FOR
INDUCING CONFUSION MAKING
PROGRESS AT PROVIDE A CLEAR
TIMELINE FOR A KIND OF PLANNING
GOAL AND ALSO ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
CLIMATE STRATEGY FOR NATURAL
WORKING LANDS NEED TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT OTHER IMPORTANT
BENEFITS. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB. TWENTY FOUR INNER DRIVE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. I THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME'S JEANNIE MERYL
I'M A POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK WHERE
COALITION OF FORMER LEADERS IN
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE GROUPS
WORKING TO ADVANCE AGRICULTURAL
SOLUTION TO CLIMATE CHANGE WE
ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB THREE
FOUR WHICH RECOGNIZES THE NEED
FOR CALIFORNIA TO VANCE A
CLINICAL AND RELATED STRATEGIES
FOR ADAPTING IMPORTANT NATURAL
WORKING LANDS. I WANTED TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL RAISED BY MY
COLLEAGUES IN AGRICULTURE WE
AGREE WITH OUR COLLEAGUES THAT
INCONSISTENT FUNDING FOR THE
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE
PROGRAMS LIKE THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM MAKE IT CHALLENGING TO
SCALE UP AGRICULTURAL SOLUTIONS
TO THE CLIMATE CRISIS. HOWEVER
AS WE WORK ON BUDGET AND BOND
PROPOSALS TO SUPPORT STABLE AND
IMPROVE FUNDING FOR CLIMATE
SMART ACT PROGRAMS WE CAN'T THE
LANE CREATING A STATEWIDE
FRAMEWORK FOR ADVANCING NATURAL
WORKING LANDS CLIMATE SOLUTIONS
AS PROPOSED BY EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY FOUR. OF MY COLLEAGUES
IN AGRICULTURE ALSO SUGGESTS
THAT THE IMPACT IS GREATER
WEATHER EXTREMES INCLUDING
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES I MEAN
WE MUST PAUSE EFFORTS LIKE
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR WE DO
NOT ACT NOW HOWEVER TO EMBRACE
MORE RESILIENCE AND CLIMATE
FRIENDLY AND NATURAL WORKING
LANDS ONE WILL BE TO IT- WE
CAN'T WAIT TO OTHER STATES
LITERALLY BURNS OUR
AGRICULTURAL LANDS CAN AND
SHOULD BE PART OF THE STATE'S
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS. AND WE
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES IN AGRICULTURE THAT
WE MUST FIND CLIMATE SOLUTIONS
THAT IMPROVE THE ECONOMIC
VIABILITY AND RESILIENCE OF OUR
AGRICULTURAL LANDS IN AB. TWO
EIGHTY FOUR AND BRACES THESE
MULTIPLE BENEFITS. WE SAW
DURING THE- LAST YEAR WE HAD
MORE FARMERS THAN EVER. IT UP
CLIMATE PRO FOR FIELD ONE OR
FROM. AND A HEALTHY SO PRO.
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR WILL
ALLOW THE STATE TO UNDERSTAND
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO SCALE UP
THIS WORK IN MEANINGFUL WAYS.
AND FARMERS ARE DEMONSTRATING
TODAY EVEN DURING THESE
UNCERTAIN TIMES BUT THEY WANT
THE STATE'S CLIMATE EFFORTS TO
CONTINUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
NEXT WE HAVE THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TETHER RUSSIAN
EARLIER SILVERTHORNE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS TAYLOR RUSSIAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU HI WE
ARE UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL WE DON'T OBJECT IN
FACT WE AGREED WITH MR EVEN
THAT WORKING LAND WHEN PROPERLY
INCENTIVE CAMPER QUESTOR
CARBON. WARY OF DIVERGE HOWEVER
IS IN THE PRACTICALITY OF THE
GOALTENDING ITSELF I WORKING
TRYING TO DISPEL CHARGES CARDS
AVAILABLE BASED ON WHAT'S
POSSIBLE AT A SINGLE POINT IN
TIME THIS IS A REQUEST FOR
APPLIED AT THE RATHER TO ASSESS
THE FEASIBILITY OF GOAL SETTING
WHICH FLEXIBILITY THAT SOMETIME
AFTER AT THE BILL DIRECT SCHOOL
SETTING IF I WAS BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. BUT WON'T
ACCOMMODATE FOR WHAT WE KNOW
WILL BE TERMINATE THE PATH WE
FOR CARBON SEQUESTRATION
BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT I THINK I
THINK MY AND EVEN MODERATE
WILDFIRES EVEN IF I WAS THE
CURRENT THE CARBON COPY IS GONE
AND GET THE BALL WITH THAT.
ADDITIONALLY WERE CONCERNED
THAT THEIR CORRECTIVE THE CARD
FOR INCOME AND FOR GOAL SETTING
WITHOUT AN ADDITIONAL DIRECTOR
FOR FUNDING FOR NATURAL WORKING
LAND WE HAVE THAT DIFFERENT
THAT DIFFICULT AT THE PUMP IS
NOTED THE STATE HAS
CONSISTENTLY AN ADEQUATELY
FUNDED PROGRAMS LIKE EDUCATION
MANAGEMENT FOR CALIFORNIA
MAXALT AND HEALTHY SOIL. THE
WITHOUT P. FIFTY UNAMBIGUOUS
FUNDING LEVEL IN ADOPTION AND
SCALABILITY WILL BE IMPOSSIBLE
TO ACHIEVE UNFORTUNATELY THE
BILL DOESN'T ADDRESS THAT- IN
SHORT WE'RE WE'RE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE OR THE
ADMINISTRATION RIGHT TACKLE
THEIR INVENTION BUT RATHER TO
PUT IT IN CONTEXT THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE THAT FOR THESE REASONS
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY BECAUSE.
THE SELF THANK YOU. THE MORNING
SHARED MEMBERS WE HAVE FOR THE
WITH THE COW. CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. WE DO APPRECIATE THE
INTENT- MEMORY WITH FOR THE
IMPORT FASHION OF THE WALL THAT
CALIFORNIA ACT NOW RESOURCES
LOOKING ACTIVE. LAKE IN MEETING
OUR CAR NEUTRALITY BOTH- BUT
ART. YOU RESULT FROM AT THE
RESULT OF THE THIS. AND FROM.
COM LARGER OVERALL OF HOW YOU
DEFINE MEASURES EACH PEOPLE
PUBLIC. AND AS AN INITIAL
DISCOUNT. WHAT NEUTRALITY WILL
AT YOU LIVE. SO WE KNOW
GOVERNOR SENATE BISHOP OF CRIME
CAL TWENTY FIVE FIVE. IN THE
MIDDLE AS BEGUN WORKS. YOU NEED.
SO IN ADDITION THE RE THAT.
OUTLINED BY MICHAEL AT THE FOR
BUREAU ARE OF THE BILLS TO
CARBON. GOALS ON ONE AFTER THE.
FOR CALLING LIVE SHE ABOUT. TO
BE THE FIRST TIME ALLEGE. AGAIN
ON. ISSUE CRIMINALITY. AND
MEMORIALIZING. DIRECTLY THAT
COULD WHETHER INTENTIONAL OR
FOR COMMERCIAL REACT. AFTER
CARBON EMISSIONS. WHICH IS
NOTED BY LAST YEAR'S ANALYSIS
IONIS COMMITTEE ON A NEARLY
IDENTICAL BILL. COMPRISES ONLY
9% OF GLOBAL MISSION. INSTEAD
OF ENGAGING IN A MORE HOLISTIC
EVALUATION OF HOW ALL SECTORS
YOU CONTRIBUTE TO CARBON.
CAPTURE SEQUESTRATION. TO
ADDRESS OUR- TROPICAL. IF YOU
ARE THE LEGISLATURE TO EXERCISE
CAUTION IN ADVANCING INDUSTRY
SPECIFIC ALL. PRIOR TO THE
LARGER CARBON NEUTRALITY
DISCUSSION THERE MANY FACTORS.
INJURIES INFLICTED FACTORY NET
GLOBAL CARBON EMISSIONS. AND WE
CAN'T ENSURING THE LEGISLATURE
HAS THE ABILITY IN THE FUNDING
TO DEDICATE THIS GOAL. LOOK AT
HOW THE LEGISLATURE WHAT. YEAH
IMPOLITE. ROSS FOR IN A MANNER
THAT DOESN'T. AND CORPORATE AND
RECOVERY FOR. TO PROVIDE. FALL
IN VALUE SETTING AND MEETING
COST THANK YOU CARBON
NEUTRALITY GOAL THE FOR THE
THREE WE ARE RESPECT ME THE
BILL ALL RIGHT. GOT TO GET A
FEW THANK YOU HI NOW IT TO OPEN
IT UP FOR PUBLIC. IS THERE IN
THE HEARING. C. NINE ANYONE AT
THE REMOTE. TESTIMONY LOCATION
SEE NON MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION BUT
BEFORE YOU DO THAT- CAN YOU LET
ME KNOW HOW MANY COLORS YOU
HAVE IN THE QUEUE. ABSOLUTELY
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN I'M
CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE ELEVEN.
OKAY THANK YOU. N. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE ALREADY IN
THE COMIC YOU IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE NINE.
PLEASE STAY THERE AND IF YOU
HAVE NOT YET CUED UP PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU ONE ONE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MELISSA
ROMERO WITH THE CALIFORNIA THE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN THE
COURT EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR.
NINE ONE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JANIE CAL ON
BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. I
THINK YOUR MIND SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS BONNIE BY ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT OF. OKAY NINE ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WELL LIKE I SAID I'M
SURE MEMBERS OUT OF STORES WITH.
THREE SIXTY I'M HAPPY AMERICA
OF COURSE. IN SUPPORT OF
POLICIES WE GOT THE LETTER IN
LATE BUT WANTED TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT THANK YOU- YOU
KNOW WHATEVER. I'M ONE MOMENT
PLEASE MY- IS THERE ANOTHER
LINE. OPEN IT THIS IS YES I WAS
LOOKING FOR THAT ONE MOMENT
YEAH THANK YOU. WELL ORPHEUM
OUTLOOK ORDER. I SERVING. OKAY
AND. NINE ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SHERRY MEMBERS VINCENT
WERE LARGER WITH THE CLIMATE
CENTER YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE INTERN
MEMBERS STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANNING COALITION
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO EIGHTY
FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH. MY MOM
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS RECALL
MASTRODONATO WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE ONE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING I'M MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MATTHEW ALONG WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSED.
NINE ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
WITH MARK FENSTER MAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCECONSERVATION DISTRICT. SANTA
CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACES
ALREADY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ONE UP THE MIDDLE WITH
AUDUBON CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JUST
TO MILAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOST COALITION IN
FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE
ONE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY
BOILED IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION WESTERN PLANT
HEALTH ASSOCIATION AND WESTERN
AG PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR MORNING
THIS IS LOUIS BLOOMBERG BUT
CLIMATE COALITION. IN SUPPORT.
NINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE NINE ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS DENNIS ALBION IN
BEHALF OF THE ALL METAL LIVE
THE CALIFORNIA GREEN FEED THE
CALIFORNIA FEES ASSOCIATION
AMONG OTHER AGRICULTURAL
INTERESTS. WE LINE OUR COMMENTS
WITH THE FARM BUREAU'S
TESTIMONY AND WE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED WE HAVE MET WITH THE
STAFF AND NUMBER AND BELIEVE WE
WERE MAKING PROGRESS BUT
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSED AMENDED
AT THIS TIME. THANKS WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. OKAY. THANK YOU- ANY
QUESTIONS WHAT NEXT WE HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS I'M GONNA
START WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORIDA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR- THEY ALSO MAKE ME
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH YOUNG
SAID RELATED ISSUES AND THAT'S
AWESOME THAT YOU CARE AS MUCH
ABOUT THIS IS YOU DO. BUT AS WE
CONTINUE TO- THAT PUSHES
MANDATE ON ACT WHICH I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE VERY WELL AWARE OF
THAT THAT'S KIND OF. A THING
THAT WE DO. IS THERE ANY.
MOVEMENT OR ANY ABILITY TO GIVE
PERMANENT CROPS WELL THIS WEEK
AMMONS WALNUTS CHERRIES
PISTACHIOS WHATEVER THOSE FOLKS
ARE GROWING. THE CREDIT THE
PARTY CONSTRUCTION CUTS ONLY
PLAN ROUGHLY HUNDRED THIRTY
TREES THE WEAKER. AND I THINK
AS WE TALK ABOUT CARBON
SEQUESTRATION AND THE NEED FOR
THAT. I THINK THAT WOULD BE
TREMENDOUSLY HELPFUL FOR THAT
COMMUNITY TO A- HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAST GET CREDIT
FOR THE TREES OF THE PUTTING ON
THE GROUND. ANY ANY THOUGHTS ON
THAT SURE YEAH I KNOW-
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS ON THE
MEMBER FLORA AND- YOU KNOW I
THINK FIRST- YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
OPPOSITION YOU KNOW AS ONE OF
THE COMMENTS WAS MADE IS
EXERCISING CAUTION- WE LOOK AT
THIS BILL. IT'S A VERY CAUTIOUS
APPROACH IN ESTABLISHING A GOAL
IT'S DOESN'T MANDATE ANYTHING
THE ONLY THING THAT THIS BILL
ACTUALLY MANDATES IS THE
REQUIRES CARP TO. WORK WITH
STATE AID RATHER STATE AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS TO ESTABLISH
THIS GOAL AND SO I THINK YOUR
POINT IS A IS WELL TAKEN IF YOU
LOOK AT THE LAST SECTION OF
THIS BILL- IT CALLS ON A R. B.
TO DEVELOP STANDARD METHODS FOR
STATE AGENCIES TO TRACK.
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS CARBON SEQUESTRATION
AND SO CERTAINLY- I THINK- WE
TALK ABOUT- EXISTING- LAND
MANAGEMENT- NOW IN THE STATE
YEAH IT'S AS IT RELATES TO
SPECIFIC- CROPS YOU KNOW THAT
NEEDS TO BE ASSESSED IN PART OF
THIS EFFORT AS WELL BECAUSE
WHAT. WORKS WELL IN ONE AREA
THE STATE IS GOING TO WORK WELL
IN ANOTHER AREA AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S ABOUT BRINGING TOGETHER
THESE EXPERTS- TO ESTABLISH A
GOAL- TO ASSESS OUR ENTIRE
LANDSCAPING CALIFORNIA- WHICH
IS AS WE ALL KNOW VERY- IS
DIVERSE- AND- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY. UP IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT CROSS DAY. WE YOU
HAVE THOSE COME. WITH CARBON DO
YOU FEEL THAT THERE IS A- THE
DESIRE TO MAKE SOME OF THOSE
CHANGES BECAUSE THERE'S GONNA
BE SOME BIG CHANGES WITHIN THE
STATUTE OF THE GONNA HAVE TO
CHANGE TO MAKE THAT. DOABLE DO
YOU FEEL THAT THERE IS A DESIRE
FOR THAT YEAH WELL I- YOU KNOW
I CAN'T I CAN'T COMMENT ON
BEHALF OF KERR BUT I THINK THAT
CERTAINLY THERE'S WE READ THE-
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ESPECIALLY AT THE ACT THAT. YOU
KNOW. WITH IN CAR OVER THE
YEARS AROUND DOING SOMETHING
AROUND THAT'S WORKING LANDS
ANALYSIS TALKS ABOUT THIS
PIECEMEAL- APPROACHES PROGRAM
BY PROGRAM APPROACH WHEN IT
COMES OUR NETWORKING LANDS BUT
I THINK. THAT'S OUR GOAL HERE
IS TO PLACE GREATER EMPHASIS ON
THE POTENTIAL MATCH WORKING
LANDS. TRYING TO INCENTIVIZE
BEST PRACTICES- AND YOU KNOW
BECAUSE AS AS WE KNOW AS
RESEARCH INDICATES. AS THE
SCIENCE INDICATES IS IT IS
CERTAINLY. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY- FOR OUR STATE TO
UTILIZE OUR NATURAL WORKING
LANDS- TO BE PART OF- THE
LARGER CLIMATE CRISIS WERE
ENCOUNTERING. AND OBVIOUSLY AS
I MENTIONED- WITH THE- NEW
ADMINISTRATION WASHINGTON
THERE'S A PLACE IN A LOT OF
EMPHASIS ON THIS IN CASE AS WE
KNOW WE HAD. A THROUGH OUR-
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE
ENVIRONMENTAL AGRICULTURE
HEARING- WHERE KAREN ROSS.
SECRETARY OF CDFA. HIGHLIGHTED
THE UNIQUE PROGRAMS WE OFFER AN
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING. WHICH
ARE UNIQUE TO THE COUNTRY NOT
VERY MANY STATES ARE WHERE WE
ARE- AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THESE PROGRAMS LIKE HEALTHY
SOILS AND AMP PROGRAM. MET THE
REDUCTIONS THEY'RE
OVERPRESCRIBED- THEY ARE. IN
THE BACK TO OUR I'VE BEEN ON
VERY POPULAR PROGRAMS. YOU KNOW
PEOPLE THAT UTILIZE THEM- TALK
ABOUT- THE BENEFITS THEY SEE
AND THEY HOW THEY APPRECIATED
PROGRAMS. BUT CERTAINLY THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE HAVE MADE
AS A STATE HAVE BEEN ENOUGH.
NOT CREATE THAT AND IF THERE'S
ANYTHING I CAN DO TO WORK WITH
YOU- WITH KERR ON THIS ISSUE I
WOULD LOVE TO BE A PART OF
THAT. BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT-
THE COMMUNITY- WE'VE HAD THIS
KIND. IS A AND WILLING TO MOVE
FORWARD IN A LOT OF THESE
AREAS. IF THERE IS THAT CARE
VERSUS STICK APPROACH. AND I
THINK IF WE CAN GIVE THEM. SOME
SORT OF. ADDITIONAL OPTIONS TO
GET THE SEQUESTRATION CREDITS-
THIS BILL BECOMES INCREDIBLY
SUPPORTABLE. BUT I WOULD I
WOULD JUST HOLD OFF ON IT RIGHT
NOW BUT WOULD LOVE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU ON THAT
BECAUSE I DO THINK THERE IS A-
SOME OPPORTUNITIES HERE TO GIVE
ACT- ADDITIONAL OPTIONS ON
SEQUESTRATION. SURE THE ANSWER
YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS. THANK
YOU MAN I'M SURE I'M GONNA
START OFF BY THANKING THE- HI
MY CO PARTNER ON AS AG HERE IS
ON THE VICE CHAIRMAN OF
AGRICULTURE AND BEEN WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES FOR YEARS GOING ON
GOT REALLY SIX SEVEN YEARS NOW-
THE AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO ALIGN
WITH THE- THE CALLING MISTER
FLORES COMMENTS YOU KNOW. THERE
THERE'S A LOT. TO BE DONE AND
TO BE SAID HERE I COMMEND YOU.
ON THE STREET IS FOR TRYING TO
THREAD A VERY TOUGH NEEDLE ON
THAT A LOT OF US HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO DO FOR QUITE SOME
TIME- I I'M GONNA TAKE A SLIDER
STEP FORWARD AND PROBABLY UPSET
SOME OF MY- AGRICULTURAL
FRIENDS AN OFFER TO JOIN AUTHOR
THIS WITH YOU. WITH THE CAVIAR
OF I WANT TO SEE SOME ACTUAL.
OCT CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS IN
HERE GOING TO THIS TO PROVIDE
THAT KERRY- SOME OF US WHO
SPENT. FIVE AND WEEKENDS
WORKING WITH- FORMER GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN. IN IRONING OUT THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM- I
REMEMBER SOME VERY LATE NIGHT
CONVERSATIONS WITH HIM. TO
ENSURE THE FUNDING FOR THE
SPECIFIC ISSUES FOR AGRICULTURE
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE BACKING
UP THE SIZE THAT WE ARE USING
THIS. AS A KERRY VERSUS THE
STATE TO MOVE OUR STATE
FORWARD- WE NEED TO SEE IT
ACTUALLY HAPPEN- YOU KNOW I
RECENTLY GOT INTERVIEWED BY-
NBC NEW YORK IN REGARDS TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN TALKING ABOUT
BUDGET PRIORITIES IN OUR STATE
IN THE STILL BLOWS MY MIND THAT
WE'RE SPENDING SIX POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS A- DAY. TO GO
AFTER A HIGH SPEED RAIL. NGUYEN
IF WE WERE FORTY SIX POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS A DAY INTO OUR
AGRICULTURAL CROPS WITH
ACTUALLY BEGINNING A BIGGER
BANG FOR OUR BALK WHEN IT COMES
TO CLIMATE CHANGE. SO I ASKED
MY OTHER COLLEAGUE SOON IN
MEMBERS OUT THERE. YOU KNOW
THINK THINK ABOUT THESE THINGS
THINK ABOUT WERE ACTUALLY
SPENDING OUR MONEY. TO SOLVE
CLIMATE CHANGE TO ADDRESS THESE
PROBLEMS TO MAKE SURE THAT. YOU
KNOW THE FACT THAT. ALL FROM
THE CITY CALIFORNIA IS THE
NUMBER ONE AXFORD DO YOU SEEN
STATE. NET NOT ONLY IN THE
COUNTRY BUT IN THE WORLD. WE
WILL PRODUCE MORE AND MORE
FINANCIALLY FOR FIVE TIMES MORE
THAN ANYWHERE ELSE. IN OUR AD
PROCESSES OR ONE OF THE TOP.
CLIMIE REDUCTIONS THAT WE CAN
DO FOR CARBON SEQUESTRATION MR
FLOORS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT OUR TREE CROPS
ARE GETTING THOSE CARBON
CREDITS. IN INDUSTRIES I WANT
TO PARTNER WITH YOU ON THAT WE
WE'VE HAD THE TALKS WITH BEEN
ON THE TOUR'S. WE WE'VE TALKED
TO ALL THE DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS BY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WE ALL NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER ON THESE CLIMATE GOALS
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STATE AGENCIES ARE ACTUALLY-
PROVIDING AN INCENTIVE TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD ON THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND THAT WE IT'S NOT
JUST TALK IT'S ACTUALLY ACTION.
IN FRONT OF ALL ACTION THE
INSURERS THAT OUR AGRICULTURAL
PARTNERS CAN ACTUALLY DO THESE
THINGS AND STOP PUNISHING THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ACTUALLY HELP
TRYING TO HELP. ON THE SO WITH
THAT SAID I. THEY ALLEGE
JOINTLY DO THIS WITH YOU-
MYSTERY WAS TO ENSURE THAT WE
ACTUALLY MOVE THE BALL IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION THANK YOU
APPRECIATE COMMENTS SOMEONE
ABOUT THIS. THANK YOU OKAY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU OF. THE SERVICE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE I KNOW THAT-
YOU AND I ALONG WITH THE MS
GARCIA ARE WORKING ON
PRIORITIZING- THE A. R. P. TO.
COME UP WITH A PLAN FOR HOW WE
GET TO CARPENTRY ALITY BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE AND- I THINK
IT'S VERY SIGNIFICANT- THAT THE
CHAIR OF THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMITTEE AND PERHAPS THE VICE
CHAIR THE AGRICULTURE-
COMMITTEE ON. WILL BE WORKING
TOGETHER TO PRIORITIZE- THE AIR
BE TO COME UP WITH THIS PLAN-
HI I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY.
FIRST OF ALL THE SCOPE PLAN IS
A IS. NINE IS A CORRECT THAT'S
THAT'S MY UNDERSTAND YES OKAY
THEN AND SO NEVER ME THAT TO.
THAT YOU KNOW WHENEVER I'M MEET
WITH- REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
AND INDUSTRY YOU KNOW THERE
THERE TO THEY THEY ALWAYS CALL
BY THAT YOU KNOW WE ONE CAN
ABOUT BEING YOU KNOW GREATER.
OF THE LAND AT THE END AND THEN
WE DO OUR OWN. AND SO. YOU
KNOW. IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT-
HI I'M NOT A FARMER YOU KNOW
AND- I HAVE TO DEFER TO THOSE
THEY HAVE MORE EXPERIENCE- THAN
I DO- BUT- IT SEEMS TO ME IN
THE SCIENCE SEEMS TO BE CLEAR
THAT THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS. IS
RINA WREAKING HAVOC ON ON OUR
NATURAL AND ARE WORKING LANDS-
WHAT WHAT THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE WILDFIRES WHETHER
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE DROUGHT
CONDITIONS- AND SO IT SEEMS
LIKE YOUR BILL ALL IS TALKING
ABOUT IS COMING UP WITH THE
WORKING PLAN. SO THAT WE CAN BE
GOOD STEWARDS OF OUR NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD THINK
THAT YOU KNOW THOSE THAT ARE
COMMITTED TO BEING THE GREATEST
STEWARDS OF OUR LAND YOU KNOW
WOULD WANT TO HAVE THAT
RESPONSIBLE PLANNING. SO THAT-
WE YOU KNOW SO THAT WE DO.
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO AVOID
THE WORST IMPACTS OF. OF
CLIMATE CHANGE ON OUR- ON OUR
LAND SO- I WOULD TO I WANT US
TO BE A JOINT AUTHORS A BILL
BUT I WOULD ASK. THAT YOU HAD
ME AS A CO AUTHOR OF YOUR BILL
ABSOLUTELY AND I CAN APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE AND THANK HER
COMMENTS ADAM. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER. FROM MEMBERS. HEY MISTER
RIVAS WOULD YOU LIKE TO LOSE
NO JUST- REALLY APPRECIATE THE
TIME MADAM CHAIR AND YOU KNOW
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
OPPOSITION YOU KNOW WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THEM SINCE
DAY ONE OF THEM WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS FROM DAY ONE HOPE
THAT WE WILL REACH A COMPROMISE
WITH THEM AND- YOU KNOW REALLY-
RESPECT LESS WHEN I BOTH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- I DON'T I
BELIEVE I DON'T HAVE A MOTION
FOR THE SPOT. THANK YOU SO. OUR
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MURATSUCHI Q. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I IN TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RIVAS HI
RIVAS III FLORA. FLOOR NOT
VOTING. CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I'D GARCIA GARCIA AYE
MCCARTY MURATSUCHI. RIGHT TO GI
MATHIS MATHIS I. CERAKOTE YEAH
SO YOUR TOTAL STONE STONE I
WOULD. WOULD I. THAT ONE. THANK
YOU I'M FIRST I'D LIKE TO ASK
THE AT&T MODERATOR- IF WE SEEM
TO BE HEARING SOME OPEN LINES
IF YOU CAN MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
REMAIN CLOSED WHILE WERE.
DURING DURING THIS HEARING.
IDEOLOGY BUT FOR THOSE IT'S
ACTUALLY COMING FROM YOUR LINE.
YEAH I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A
ROOM THAT HAS A MICROPHONE.
COMMITTEES THE SERGEANTS PLEASE
CHECK ON THAT I. YEAH I THE
SKIS ME. YEAH RIGHT OKAY WHAT
ARMS SAYING THEY SEE THE LIGHT
THE LINE LIGHT UP AND THAT IT'S
THE A. T. AND T. LINE. IF YOU
CAN PLEASE DOUBLE CHECK. WHAT
WE'RE READING ONE MOMENT WE'RE
READY TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
BILL. AB TWELVE A ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG AND I'M
GONNA ASK PRESENTERS TO PLEASE
SET UP THE RIGHT HAND SIDE OF
THE TABLE SO WE MAINTAIN SOCIAL
DISTANCING FOR MARK COMMITTEE
SECRETARY. MOVED A BILL. GREAT
THANK YOU FOR FIRST LET ME JUST
SAY I'M ACCEPTING ALL THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE LIMITS IN
THE BILL ANALYSIS. AND ALSO
PLAN TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH.
BPI ON THEIR SUGGESTION TO
DELAY THE BILL'S TIMELINE FOR
COMPLYING WITH THE NATIONAL
ORGANICS PROGRAM. AGAIN AB
TWELVE A ONE PART PRODUCT ME
HIGHER QUALITY STANDARDS IN
ORDER TO THE LABEL AS
COMPOSTABLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FEDERAL. THANK YOU. I'M SO
WE'RE READY FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. MODERATOR
IF YOU CAN OPEN THE LINES. THE
LINES ARE OPEN. SHE SAID SHE.
OKAY WE'RE READY I BELIEVE WE
HAVE CHRISTINE WILL
PHARMACOLOGY. YEAH I THINK SO
MUCH OF THIS IS CHRISTINE WOKE
WITH RECOLOGY. WE'VE BEEN
OPERATING MUNICIPAL COMPOSTING
PROGRAMS FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE EIGHTY
TWELVE A ONE. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT WE CAN GET CARE PREPARING
IMPLEMENT CONVERSE TACKLE THAT
FEATURES NINETY THREE
REGULATIONS NEXT YEAR. SB
THIRTY THREE WILL REQUIRE
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
TO IMPLEMENT TO TRACK WITH
COVERING OUR GAME X. PROCESSING
PROGRAMS. WE'RE SEEING THAT
MANY JURISDICTIONS WANT TO
INCLUDE COMPOSTABLE PACKAGING
OF PRODUCTS IN OUR PROGRAMS IN
THE INTEREST OF MAXIMIZING
CUSTOMER CONVENIENCE. MANY DID
COMMUNITIES ALONG WITH
INDIVIDUAL BUSINESSES AND
RESIDENTS WANT USE COMPOSTABLE
TO MINIMIZE THEIR DEPENDENCE
SOMETHING. GO USE DISPOSABLE
PLASTIC. HOWEVER JUST LIKE
PRODUCTS CLAIM TO PRECISE.
PRODUCTS THAT ARE LABELED
COMPOSED SHOULD ACTUALLY BE
CAPABLE BEING COMPOSTED.
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO STANDARDS
TO VISUALLY DIFFERENTIATE NON
COMBUSTIBLE COMPOSTABLE
PRODUCTS NEITHER CONSUMERS NOR
COMPOSTERS CAN TELL THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THEM.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T RISK
CONTAMINATING ARE COMPOSTED
PLASTIC MOST OF THIS MATERIAL
MUST BE EXCLUDED AT THE
BEGINNING OF A COMPLEX PROCESS
SENT TO LANDFILL. COMPOSED
PRODUCTS AND- ENTERED WITH THE
QUALITY OF THE COMPLEX WE MAKE
IN OUR ABILITY TO MARKET TO
AGRICULTURAL CUSTOMERS OUR
LARGEST MARKET. ACOSTA
EXTENSIVE DECONTAMINATION
EQUIPMENT AT THE FACILITY TO
OPERATE PLUS THE COST OF
DISPOSAL INCREASE THE COSTS OF
THESE PROGRAMS AT THE TIME WE
CAN LEAST AFFORD IT. ACCORDING
TO CAL CYCLE CALIFORNIA WILL
NEED TO BUILD BETWEEN EIGHTY
AND A HUNDRED NEW COMPOST
FACILITIES. TO PROCESS ORGANIC
DIVERTED FROM LANDFILL TO MEET
OUR SHORT WITH QUITE A POINT
REDUCTION GOAL. EACH DAY SO
WHAT IT WILL NEED TO BE
DESIGNED AND PERMITTED TO
SAFELY AND EFFICIENTLY
COMPOSTED WASTE WHILE MEETING
STRINGENT ERIN WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS. WE'LL TRY TO
CONFRONT THIS CHALLENGE THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE WASTING TIME AND
MONEY CLEANING UP THE PROBLEM
THAT CAN BE FIXED AT THE
SOURCE. AB TWELVE A ONE ONE
HALF THESE ISSUES BY SETTING
STANDARDS FOR COMPOSTABLE
PRODUCTS THAT BETTER MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE COMPOST MYSTERY IN
JURISDICTIONS. USING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE. THANK YOU.
THANK NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
MORNING JERRY ABOUT THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I PROJECT
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF FOR THE IMPORTANT
TIME THE GIRL I'M DELIGHTED
YOU'RE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMPOST
COLLISION OUR MEMBERS ARE
PREDOMINATELYSERVICE PROVIDERS
FOR THE NATIONALITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA PROCESS
YARD TRIMMINGS. AND
INCREASINGLY FOOD WASTE. OUR
MEMBERS NAMES INCREASE REFLECT
ORGANIC. AND FOR THE USE OF
CLEAN COMPOST OF THE WAY TO
COMPLETE THE ORGANIC RECYCLING
WAS. AB TWO ALTHOUGH ONE OF THE
NECESSARY STEPANEK INCOMPATIBLE
PRODUCTS APART OF THE CAPITAL
ORGANICS RECYCLING SYSTEM YOU
KEEP THEM OUT OF LANDFILLS. THE
VAST MAJORITY WELL OVER 95% OF
PROPOSAL PACKAGING IS CURRENTLY
BEING LANDFILLED. IT'S DOUBLING
LABELING AND IDENTIFICATION
STANDARDS INCLUDING SPECIFIC
COLORING IDENTIFICATION MARKING
FOR COMPATIBLE PACKAGING WILL
HELP PREVENT CONSUMER CONFUSION
WHAT SORTS OF READING FOOD
WASTE AND ENHANCE THE ABILITY
OF PROCESSING FACILITY
OPERATORS TO REMOVE NON
COMPOSTABLE PACKAGING. HELPING
REDUCE CONTAMINATION IN FOOD
CAPITAL ACTION PROGRAMS.
REDUCING PROGRAM COSTS. MOST
COMPOSTERS BELIEVE THE
COMPOSABLE FOODSERVICE CAN HAVE
VALUE IN HELPING COLLECTION
PROGRAMS DELIVER MARKETS
CRAFTED THEIR FACILITIES
BLOATING LOOK MORE EFFECTIVELY.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT
ATTRIBUTES OF COMPOSABLE FOOD
PACKAGING MEAN THAT THEY ARE
PART OF A SYSTEM WHICH IS
DESIGNED TO FAIL. SIMILAR TO
THE WASTE RECYCLING PHENOMENON
WHICH COMPOSTING DOES NOT MEAN
THAT COMPOSTERS ARE ABLE TO
DEAL EFFECTIVELY WITH THE
PROBLEMS BROUGHT TO THEIR
FACILITIES LIKE IMPOSSIBLE
PACKAGING. WHICH SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED PROCESSING COSTS
REMOVED AND ULTIMATELY DISPOSE
OF THEM. ADDITIONALLY
COMPOSABLE PLASTICS ARE NOT
ALLOWED FOR USE IN ORGANIC
AGRICULTURE MEETING COMPOST
WHICH IS PRODUCED INCLUDING
THEM IS NOT ALLOWED AS AN
ORGANIC INPUT. WHICH IS
REGULATED UNDER CDFA AUTHORITY.
AND WHAT'S REQUIRED THEY WROTE
THAT REMOVAL PROCESS BE
EMPLOYED DURING COMPOST
PRODUCTION. NEW FOOD SAFETY
MODERNIZATION ACT REQUIREMENTS
ALONG WITH MARKETING AGREEMENTS
AND OTHER DIRECTIVES FROM
CONVENTIONAL PRODUCE PURCHASERS
LIKE WALMART MCDONALD'S AND
OTHERS ARE PUSHING MOST
CONVENTIONAL GROWERS USE ONLY
CDFA CERTIFIED ORGANIC INPUT.
ANY COMPATIBLE PLASTIC NOT BE
ELIMINATED FROM THE FEEDSTOCKS.
AGRICULTURE IS THE SINGLE
LARGEST MARKET FOR COMPOST WITH
OVER 60% SHARE NOW THAT REMAINS
LARGELY UNTAPPED. AT ORGANIC
DIVERSION PROGRAM GROWTH
MEDICALLY OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS TO MEET THE LOFTY GOALS
THAT THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
THE IMPORTANCE OF AGRICULTURAL
MARKETS FOR COMP INCREASE
IMMENSELY. LATTERLY COMPOSABLE
PRODUKTIVNOSTI MEET THE
PRODUCTION CYCLE OF THE TYPICAL
COMPOST MANUFACTURER. WELL ASTM
STANDARDS FOR COMPOSTABLE
PLASTICS ALLOW FOR UP TO A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS TO
ACHIEVE 95% BIO DEGRADATION OF
THE MATERIAL. MOKABA PRODUCERS
WORK ON FORTY FIVE TO SIXTY DAY
CYCLE OR SOMETIMES SHORTER.
WE'LL BE WORKING ON AMENDMENTS
THIS CURRENT BILL LANGUAGE TO
ADD A FIELD TESTING PROTOCOL
AND ENSURE THE COMPLETE TOTAL
PRODUCT ME COPPER MANUFACTURING
REQUIREMENTS. AB TWO ALTHOUGH
ONE COMES AT A CRITICAL TIME IN
HELPING TO ENSURE THAT THE
COMPOSED LOOKING PACKAGING
MEETS IT VALUE PROMISE AS AN
ASSET TO FOODS CRAP RECYCLING
PROGRAMS. HELPING COMPOSTERS
CLOSE THE LOOP ON ORGANIC
MATERIAL AND HELP THE STATE
MEET ITS CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS
INSTEAD OF BURDENING ARE
ALREADY SCARED INFRASTRUCTURE
WITH CONTAMINATION CHALLENGES.
WE THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE ALIGNED AND ASPIRIN I
LOVE. THANK YOU- NEXT I'D LIKE
TO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
KATE SNOW ONE ANYONE AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION. NO
ONE IS THERE A MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR SUPPORTER OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE NOT
ALREADY IN THE COMMENT QUEUE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE A ONE. NINE ONE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING HERE
NUMBER THREE THOUGHTS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AND SUPPORT
BY AN OFFICE SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO. AND SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTED DECISION A
PRECIPITOUS QUESTIONS WITH THE
FUNDING FOR THE BALLOT
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE MAY BE
SOME TWEAKS ON THE NATIONAL
ORGANIC PROGRAM ISSUE WHICH
PERMANENTLY TEAM MENTIONED ANY
OF THE PRESENTATION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. IT'S PAST AND.
THE FATHER THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NINE ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MADAM CHAIR NUMBER CAME
ROBINSON REGISTER REGISTER IN
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWELVE ALL ONE
FOR BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS RETHINK WAIT CLEAN
WATER ACTION ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP THANK YOU. MY
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS NIKITA CRAPPIE BUT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE ALL ONE THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CLINTON LEVACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH COALITION
ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT. LINE ONE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JUST FROM A LOT OF THE
HEARTS OF THE KING HE'S
LOBBYING COALITION AND THE
LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS BONNIE THAT ALL THE
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
OH ONE. NINE SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FLOORPLANS A RESOURCE RECOVERY
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. NINE ONE SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND I'M SURE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CHECK CALVET WITH
REPUBLIC SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
NINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI LAUREN
COLUMN REPAIR CALL CALIFORNIA
CON IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE A
ONE. THANK YOU. AND AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU- NEXT A MOVE TO QUESTIONS
FOR MEMBERS ALL START WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN- I
WANTED TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL FORD AND FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP. IN THE PLASTICS-
AND RECYCLING AND WASTE ISSUES
AND I JUST WANTED TO REQUEST
BEING ADDED AS A JOINT OR CO
AUTHOR WHATEVER HE WOULD LIKE
AT SOME POINT THANK YOU. FOR
THAT THE GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT.
JUST A QUESTION AND IF IT WAS
BROUGHT UP AND I MISSED IT I
APOLOGIZE- GO TO SOME LITTLE
OFF THE WALL SO- IT'S BUT MAYBE
AS LOW BLOOD SUGAR- HAS HAS THE
INDUSTRY THAT PRODUCES-
COMPOSTABLE PLASTICS
CONSIDERED. A SPECIFIC COLOR.
FOR THESE AS A WAY TO ENSURE
THAT- THAT THOSE SPECIFIC
COLORED ITEMS END UP IN THE
RIGHT WAY STRENGTH THE- REASON
I. YES THAT'S NOT A COMPARISON
OF THE TWO BUT I THINK OF.
ADDITIONAL PIPE FOR WATER AND
RECYCLE WATER BEING A PURPLE
PIPE. SO I JUST WONDER IS THE
INDUSTRY CONSIDER THAT AS A WAY
TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT THE WAY
STREAMS DO NOT GET- DO NOT GET
CONTAMINATED. YEAH LET ME SEE
IF NEIL- CHRISTINE KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION BECAUSE
I DON'T. I WOULD BE HAPPY TO-
YEAH THE INDUSTRY IS PROPOSED
THAT. DIRECTLY LIMIT THE NUMBER
OF. COLOR SCHEMES TO BROWN OR
GREEN. IN NATURE. AND I THINK
WILL ALSO BE WORKING ON
AMENDMENTS STILL. FADEOUT OR
ELIMINATE OTHER LOOKALIKE
PRODUCTS I KNOW MANY OF YOU
PROBABLY GOT YOUR LOCAL SAFEWAY
AND GOTTEN A GREEN PLASTIC BAG
THAT LOOKS A LOT LIKE A
COMPOSABLE BAG- SO THOSE KINDS
OF CONFUSING PRODUCT ON THE
MARKET ONLY EXACERBATE
CONTAMINATION ISSUE. THANK YOU
FOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- MISTER
CHANG A APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS
HERE- I'D LIKE TO HELP PUSH
THOSE FIRED BY- JOINING YOU AS
A AS A JOINT AUTHORS SHOW
BIPARTISANSHIP ON THIS MATTER
IF YOU'LL HAVE ME. THAT THAT
WOULD BE GREAT WE CAN HAVE BOTH
YOU AND MISS FRIEDMAN AS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA WOULD YET THANK
YOU ARE WHEN I THINK YOUR YOUR
EFFORT ON IN THIS SPACE AND
PARTICULARLY HIDING THE ISSUE
WITH- HIGHLIGHTING THE ISSUE
WITH P. FOSS- THAT'S OUT THERE
AND SO WHILE IT IS A REPELLENT
THAT'S OFTEN USED IT'S A FIVER
CHEMICAL AT THE SAME BREAKDOWN
AND SO NOT ONLY IS IT NOT
COMPOSABLE WE HAVE ISSUES WITH
WHAT IT DOES TO OUR BODIES WERE
AT THAT TIME TO SUMMER TEAM SO
I DO APPRECIATE- YOUR WORK IN
THIS SPACE AS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT EDUCATING. THE
PUBLIC IN ENSURING THAT THINGS
ARE ACTUALLY COMPOSTABLE OR
RECYCLABLE- AND LYFT SOME SORT
OF A CELL SYSTEM SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR. PERHAPS WE WOULD
LOVE THE BOOK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- MISTER KING WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. IT REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORTED THE COMMITTEE'S
QUESTIONS WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU- THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORIDA SECRETARY KING PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I AM THIRTEEN AB
TWELVE OH ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIANG. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. REYES
RIVAS I RIVERSIDE FLORIDA FLOOR
AYE CHAU SHALL I FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA AYE
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
MURATSUCHI A TO G. I'D SAY ARE
TOP HI SAY ARE T<c.cyan> STONE.</c>
STONE I WOULD. WHAT I TEN ZERO
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT STEP WE
HAVE AB TWO SIXTY SEVEN-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VIA THAT IS.
GREAT. IT. PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
START WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MEMBERS AND STAFF OR TIME FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THE CELL THE
PROBLEM AND THEN IF I DID YOU
NECESSARY ABOUT ONE HELLO
COMMITMENT THREE THE NECESSARY
MOB ARE HIGHER BUT I PROJECT.
WILL IF YOU'RE IN NEED. AND
BARBARA YOU SEE. SET BY THE
GOVERNMENT. NUMBER I DON'T
YOU'RE A YOU HOW CRITICAL THAT
IS THE ISSUE OF WILD ARE IN THE
C. HAS EACH YEAR HAVE. MORE
ACRES ARE. MORE HOW AND- ARE
JUST. AND MOST TRAGICALLY. MORE
LAW. ARE LOST. TO HELP MITIGATE
THE DESTRUCTION AND THE LOSS OF
LIFE WE ARE RESPONSIBLE WE MUST
COMMIT TO MEANINGFUL REFORM
THAT WILL RETURN OUR LANDS AND
FORESTS TO HEALTHY CONDITIONS
THAT REDUCE THE RISK OF
WILDFIRES ONE IMPORTANT WAY WE
CAN FURTHER THIS COMMITMENT IS
BY SUPPORTING PROVEN METHODS
THAT WORK TO TREAT OUR FORESTS
AND REDUCE WILDFIRE RISKS. THIS
BILL IS ONE SUCH MEASURE THAT
WILL EXTEND BY THREE YEARS A
SEQUEL EXEMPTION FOR WILDFIRE
REDUCTION PROJECTS ON FEDERAL
LANDS THAT HAVE ALREADY PASSED
THE STANDARDS AND THE REVIEW
UNDER THE NATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY ACT NEPA.
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL WILL HELP
REMOVE THE BARRIERS TO
SIGNIFICANT WILDFIRE PREVENTION
IT WILL SAVE LOCAL AND STATE
AGENCIES OF VALUABLE TIME AND
RESOURCES. WHILE STILL
MAINTAINING MEANINGFUL
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW STANDARDS.
UNDER NEPA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE I DO HAVE TO-
WITNESSES HERE FOR TESTIMONY.
L. OLSON DIRECTOR OF ECOSYSTEM
PLANNING FOR THE U. S. FIRE
SERVICE OR FOR SERVICE AND
SAFETY HEATON AND ADVOCATE FOR
FROM RULE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MODERATOR KEY PLEASE-
ALLOW THE WITNESSES TO PROVIDE
THEIR TESTIMONY AND I WANT TO
REMIND BOTH WITNESSES THAT YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES. WITH AND
WITH THE INTEREST OF TIME I
WILL BE TRACKING THE TIME.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I'M L. OLSON DIRECTOR
OF YOU COULD COMPLAIN TO THE
PACIFIC SOUTHWEST REGION OF U.
S. WAR SERVICE OUR SERVICE.
OVER TWENTY MILLION ACRES OF.
LAND IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
ABOUT 50% OF ALL FOREST LANDS
IN THE STATE ON BEHALF OF THE
REGION I'M HERE TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SIX SEVEN WHICH WOULD EXTEND
THE SUNSET GAINES TELLS BY
SENATE BILL NINE OH ONE. FOR
EXEMPTIONS FROM THE STATE AND-
CAL STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BIOMEDICAL YAK. IS EXEMPTIONS
APPLY THIS COULD SWEET OF
COURSE BILLS PROJECT. TO
RESTORE THE FOREST ON FEDERAL-LAND HAD THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
REVIEWED UNDER THE NATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY ACT. NEPA
IS A COMPREHENSIVE LAW THAT
REQUIRES DISCLOSURE AFFECT THE
PROJECT ON FEDERAL LAND IN
ADDITION PAPER REQUIRES
INTEGRATION WITH PLANNING
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCEDURES. REQUIRED BY OTHER
LAWS SUCH AS THE CLEAN WATER
ACT ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT AND
NATIONAL HISTORIC PRESERVATION
ACT. OUR AT THE REGION COMPLETE
ENVIRONMENT. WITH PUBLIC REVIEW.
THE FLORIDA TAKING FOR PRESSED
WORK. WHICH IS CRITICAL THE CAL.
FOR COMMITTEE WHILE PROPER.
JOBS ARE REAL COMMUNITIES. SAFE
DRINKING AND AGRICULTURAL WATER.
AND WHILE IT SERVICE ARE FOR
WILDLIFE ENERGY TRANSPORTATION
RECREATION. THE REGION HAS THE
FLEXIBILITY UNDER THE CORRECT
NEED A POLICY TO MEET STATE
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING ANALYSIS
OF GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. NO
CRIED TO COMPLETE COMPLETE A
SEQUEL ANALYSIS IN ADDITION TO
A NEEDS ANALYSIS IS OFTEN
RESULT OF STATE PLANS BEING
USED ON FEDERAL LANDS. OKAY TO
THE PROJECTS ARE FUNDED. AND
ADMINISTERED TO CALIFORNICA
NEXT YEAR AND THAT'LL NEVADA
CONSERVANCY AND OTHER STATE
AGENCIES. A COLLABORATION THIS
COLLABORATION REFLECTS THE
NATURE SHARED STEWARDSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA WERE BREAKING DOWN
BOUNDARIES LOOKING FOR
RESTORATION FROM A HOST
POLITICAL LANDSCAPE APPROACH
THAT INCLUDES ALL LANDS USING
BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDING.
THE SECRET THAT CAN HAVE BEEN
USED OVER TWENTY TIMES SO FAR.
NUMBER NINETEEN YOUR AT TWO
MINUTES. THE SUMMER IN YOUR- UP
IN IN RESPONSE BECAUSE WHAT
THIS IS BEEN USED MULTIPLE
TIMES WITH EXEMPTION TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE. HEY FOR GREEN PAID
PLANNING CALL FROM PLANNING
TIME THE FOR SERVICE REMAINS
COMPLETE COMMITTED CARCINOGENIC
RESEARCHERS CALPERS
POSSIBILITIES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON STATE
IN WITH THE WORLD RECORD OF.
WERE REPRESENTING THIRTY SEVEN
RURAL COUNTY STATEWIDE. OUR
MEMBERSHIP CONTAINS MORE THAN
70% CALIFORNIA'S NATIONAL
FOREST LAND IN MANY OF OUR
MEMBER COUNTY THE STUFF FOR THE
MOST DEVASTATING WILDFIRES ON
FEDERAL LANDS IN THE LAST
DECADE. THE SIMPSONS PHABLET IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SENATE
BILL NINE A ONE WHICH IS
COMPOSED FOR EXTENSION IN AB
TWO SIXTY SEVEN WAS INTENDED TO
HELP INCREASE THE PAPERS
CALIFORNIA MANAGEMENT IF YOU'LL
TREATMENT PROJECTS ON FEDERAL
LANDS. THAT HAVE ALREADY GONE
TO THE NEED FOR PRIMARY MENTAL
REVIEW PROCESS. NEED VISION HAS
ALREADY MADE POSSIBLE SUCH
MODERN PROJECTS AS THE FRENCH
MEADOWS PARTNERSHIP IN OUR
MEMBER COUNTY PLASTER WHICH IS
AN INNOVATIVE TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND ACRE RESTORATION
PROJECT UNDERWAY BY PLASTER
COUNTY. AFTER COUNTY WATER
AGENCY U. S. FOREST SERVICE THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND IF
YOU'RE NEVADA CONSERVANCY.
WITHOUT THE SB NINE ONE
EXEMPTION FRENCH MEADOWS WOULD
LIKELY HAVE BEEN DELAYED
SEVERAL MONTHS FOR NICK WHAT
THE FIRST PEOPLE TO THINK FOR
RADIO. MUCH OF WHICH WOULD BE
DUPLICATIVE OF WHAT WAS ALREADY
DONE UNDERNEATH THAT. THE STATE
SHOULD BE ENCOURAGING
PARTNERSHIPS LIKE THIS ON
FEDERAL LANDS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO HELP RESTORE FEDERAL
FOREST LANDS AND PREVENT FUTURE
WILDFIRES WHICH IS WHY RC RC
STRONGLY SUPPORT EXTENDING THE
SUNSET ON THE SEQUENCE ACTION
AS PROPOSED IN AB TWO SIXTY
SEVEN. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- NEXT UP- WE HAVE.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES. JUST WANNA.
REMIND YOU THAT YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH. GOOD AFTERNOON AT
AND MEMBER DANIEL BROAD BEHALF
SIERRA CLUB. AND A HALF MILLION.
AND SUPPORTERS. IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO SIXTY SEVEN. THIS
BILL WOULD EXTEND EQUIPPED
PENSION FOR FUEL REDUCTION
PROJECTS ON FEDERAL LANDS THAT
HAVE UNDERGONE THE PROJECT
COVERED IN DEL INVOLVING TENS
OF PROPERTIES SUCH AS REMOVING
TRADES WITH HEAVY EQUIPMENT AND
APPLYING HERBICIDES. APPERLEY
PLANNED THE PROJECT CAN HAVE
ENORMOUS POTENTIAL. FOR
NEGATIVE ECOLOGICAL IMPACTS
SUCH. AS OPPOSED TO SEE WHAT
YOU WANTED ME BUT DOES NOT
REQUIRE MEDICATION ANY BEDS
CUMULATIVE AFFECT THEM OUT THAT
IS WEAKER THIS BILL WOULD
CONTINUE SUBJECTING LARGE
SWATHS OF CALIFORNIA'S POOREST
TO INTENSIVE OPERATIONS.
WITHOUT MEDICATION AND WEAKER
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSIS. THIS
SHOULD AND SUPPORT GARAGE
BENEFITS ECOLOGICALLY
BENEFICIAL ACTIONS SUCH AS
PRESCRIBED DID MANAGE FIRE HI
THE MEANS TO RETURN FIRE TO
CALIFORNIA'S. DR SOURCED
HOWEVER DURING OPERATIONS AND
EVEN PRESCRIBED FIRE IN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES CAN HAVE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSEQUENCES IF NOT DONE
PROPERLY. LAND MANAGERS SHOULD
TAKE EVEN MORE CARE TO EVALUATE
POTENTIAL NEGATIVE IMPACT THAT.
AN OPERATION AND MITIGATE THEM
WHEN DEALING WITH COMPLEX
FORCED AND CHAPARRAL ECOSYSTEMS.
THIS EXEMPTION ALLOWED SIR LAST
CAREFUL FOREST OPERATIONS AND
COULD THEREFORE TO GRADE
CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE AND FRAGILE
LANDSCAPES AND EVEN HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AGAIN
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA. IT'S
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO A. B.
TWO SIXTY SEVEN AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR KNOW
ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOUR
NEXT WITNESS. AND GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS BRIAN A
WIKI WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY- EIGHT
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATION
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN OPPOSITION
TO BE TWO SIX SEVEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THIS
AFTERNOON DANIELS ALREADY HIT-
MANY OF THE MAIN POINTS BUT
THERE'S A COUPLE I WOULD LIKE
TO- ADD A LITTLE MORE-
INFORMATION ON AND THAT IS- I
WANT TO REMIND- THE COMMITTEE
THAT- NEPA AND SYKORA DO YOU
HAVE MUCH HELP OVERLAP BUT
THERE IS A SUBSTANTIAL
DIFFERENCE IN HOW THE ANALYSES
ARE ACTUALLY DONE AND WHAT WE
END UP WITH. AT THE END OF THE
PROCESS DANIEL MENTIONED- NEPA
DOES NOT REQUIRE MEDICATION
AND- PROVIDE THE SAME CONTEXT
THAT SEQUENCE WHERE WE END UP
HAVING MEASURES BUILT RIGHT
INTO THE PROJECTS TO HELP TO
MITIGATE AGAINST SOME OF THE
IMPACTS THAT HAPPEN WITHIN
THOSE PROJECTS SECONDLY THE
CUMULATIVE AND THE CUMULATIVE
IMPACT ANALYSIS HAPPEN TO
COMPLETE THAT HAPPENS AT A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT SCALE IN
AS MUCH MORE THOROUGH OFTEN
WITH. THE SEQUEL ANALYSIS SO
THAT WHEN WE HAVE THESE MULTI
STAKEHOLDER MULTI LANDOWNER
PROJECTS WERE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
MUCH MORE ACCOUNT TO THOSE AND
REDUCE THOSE IMPACTS UNDER THE
SYKORA REVIEW IN THE PROJECT
CHANGES THAT COME FROM THAT
SEEK REVIEW AND LASTLY ON THIS
NEPA REVIEW HAPPENS AT A MUCH
LARGER SCALE IT IS TRUE THAT
LOOKS AT ALL OF THE MANY OF THE
SAME IMPACTS BUT IT'S LOOKING
AT THEM AT THE PROGRAMMATIC
SCALE AND THE SEQUEL REVIEW
ALLOWS US TO POUR DOWN INTO THE
SPECIFICS OF THAT PROJECT. NOT
TEARING OFF OF A PROGRAMMATIC
ENVIRONMENTAL ASSESSMENT FOR
THESE REASONS THERE'S TONS OF
BENEFITS GIVEN TO US FROM THE
SECRET YOU WE DON'T WANT TO
LOSE AND THERE'S NO REASON WHY
THESE PROJECTS. SHOULD BOTH BE
PROTECTING OUR CAN UNITY'S. IN
PROTECTING THEM BE ABLE TO
PROTECT OUR NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
AGAIN WE'RE- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU- NEXTEL OPENED
UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. WE HAVE 1%
MADAM MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
THE HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANY'S IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I'M DO WE HAVE ANYONE AT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION.
WE DON'T OUR MODERATOR CAN YOU
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE NOT
ALREADY IN THE COMMENT QUEUE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
SIX SEVEN. OUR FIRST LINE FOR
COMMENT IS NINE SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAPTAIN BOARD WITH
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON AND
COMPORT. FIND ONE SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS LUCAS FRERICHS ON
BEHALF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIX SEVEN.
ONE ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
CHRIS ROSA ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NINE ONE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS JULIA HOLIDAY
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT. NO FURTHER
COMMENT TO MAKE YOU. THANK YOU
ALL START WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHAT. I WANT TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AS SOMEONE WHO WORKED
ON SB NINE OH ONE- I THINK THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT BILL I THINK
IT'S A REASONABLE EXTENSION- I
A- I DO. WANT TO POINT OUT I
THINK THAT. A LOT OF THESE-
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROJECTS
TAKE A LONG TIME WITH OR
WITHOUT- A SEQUENCE. ANALYSIS
AND I THINK THAT- IT IS IT IS.
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE THIS
WORK I WANT TO I WILL POINT OUT
THIS IS YOU'RE ASKING FOR A
THREE YEAR EXISTS- EXTENSION
THAT'S NOT SO IT'S NOT A
FOREVER THING. I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT I'D LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU
HAVE ME ON. ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU THANK YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CITY. THANK YOU VENTURA NAY MAY
OF THE SENATE PORTIONS WHO'S
ONE OF THE OPPOSITION FOR SURE
GO AHEAD. OKAY SO DO YOU TO OR
TO SEVERAL MY LAST PERSONS HI
I'M HERE YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT
THE DIFFERENCES THE HE GREW UP
AS IT RELATES TO MITIGATION AND
HEWLETT AND PACKARD BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE- YOU KNOW. WE JUST
CONSIDERING ALL OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE ALL YOU
SEE MINIMAL ONE ARE IS THAT
THAT THAT STREAMLINING
INVESTIGATING- ORDER BY
HALFORD'S- TAKE A- PRIORITY-
pUP ADDRESS A MICROPHONE IN THAT
AT THIS POINT IS MORE BECAUSE-
ONE OF OUR MANY THAT YOU WORRY
ABOUT. WE NEED PEOPLE. YEAH
MADAM CHAIR I FOLLOWED I ALL
RIGHT SOUNDS LIKE THEY'VE MAY
NOW FOR AS- SO. YOU COULD BE
BRIEF THAT WOULD BE A PRETTY.
RECENT IF YOU COULD BRIEF JUST
OKAY OF TIME BUT SHE HAS
REQUESTED- THIS- MIKE IS TO
WHAT OF THE TWO OPPOSING-
WITNESSES- MY- MY CAN MIKE MY
PERCEPTION IS THAT WHILE I
RECOGNIZE THE COMPROMISES
BETWEEN THE NEPA AND SYKORA.
THAT THE HIGHER PRIORITY IS TO
STREAMLINE AND- PRIORITIZE THE
WILDFIRE MITIGATION IS THE WHAT
FAR MITIGATION. YOU KNOW IT
SHOULD THE WILDFIRE MITIGATION
BE A HIGHER PRIORITY IN TERMS
OF THE- OVERALL ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS OF THE WILDFIRES-
RELATIVE TO BID NEPA SYKORA-
COMPROMISES. HELLO THE QUESTION
FOR THE OPPOSITION THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ARE WE
STILL HAVE THEM ON THE LINE.
YES I'M HERE I WAS. HAVING
TROUBLE GETTING OUT YEAH- SO I
THINK. BUT I WOULD SAY IT'S
FIRST OF ALL. WE DON'T IF YOU
WERE NOT ANALYZING THE- THE
PRACTICE PROJECTS TO THAT THE
FULL EXTENT THAT WE NEED TO BE
TAKEN ACTUALLY HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT COULD
INCREASE- WILDFIRE RISK FOR
COULD INCREASE- THE DAMAGE TO
THE ECOSYSTEM SHOULD DAY-
ENCOUNTER WILD FIRES THAT THE
FIRST THING I WOULD SAY. THE-
SECOND OF ALL THERE'S A
RELATIVELY. NOW WE DO HAVE-
INCREASED WILDFIRES IN RECENT
YEARS THERE'S STILL. A
RELATIVELY LOW CHANCE THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL. RAJAT THAT OCCURS
IN THE FOREST WILL ENCOUNTER
WILD FIRES IN A TIME INTERVAL-
NECESSARY- BEFORE I WOULD HAVE
TO BE- THAT THE PROJECT WOULD
HAVE TO BE PRE DINER-
MAINTAINED- AND SO IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE IF WE DIDN'T DO
THEIR CORPORATE WILD FIRE FOR I
MEAN THE APPROPRIATE RUBIO UP
FRONT. AND THEN WE COULD HAVE
HAD AN EXTREMELY NEGATIVE
ECOLOGICAL IMPACTS- AND THEN
ACTUALLY NOT NOT ADDRESS THE
WILDFIRE PLUCKY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- LIKE TO TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO- POINT AT
WHAT CAME OUT- AUGUST
THIRTEENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY-
OUR STATE ACTUALLY SIGNED AN
AGREEMENT FOR SHARED
STEWARDSHIP- CALIFORNIA'S
FORESTS AND RANGELANDS- WITH
OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS TO PURSUE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF
OUR CALIFORNIA FOREST IN FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF
FEDERAL FORCED. TO GET CLEANED
UP TO MITIGATE OUR FIRE RISK-
WHAT WE'VE SEEN HOWEVER IS THE
PROBLEM WITH CHIC WAS SLOWING
DOWN THESE PROJECTS AND WE'RE
NOT BEING ABLE TO KEEP UP AND
THEN ON THE BUDGETARY SIDE
BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING TO PULL
THE FUNDING FROM CLEANING UP.
AND PUT IT TO THAT PUTTING OUT
THE FIRE IN THE HAVOC OF THESE
MASSIVE FOREST FIRES WHICH WERE
NOT ACTUALLY SEEN THE FUNDING
GOING TO CLEANING UP I JOIN
AUTHORED THIS BILL- WITH
ASSEMBLYWOMAN VALLADARES
BECAUSE WE SEE THIS THIS IS A
PROBLEM IN THE ONLY WAY TO
ACTUALLY GET OUT THERE. IS TO
EXPEDITE THIS PROCESS IS DOCTOR
WHICH STATED THIS IS THE ONLY A
THREE YEAR EXTENSION- TO MOVE
FORWARD. TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY DOING THE THINGS
NECESSARY- I UNDERSTAND THE-
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS BUT ON
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OR
LET IT ALL BURN TO THE GROUND.
OR GET IN THERE AND TRY TO
PRESERVE IT A LITTLE BIT SO
WITHOUT MEMBERS ASK YOU TO.
OPEN YOUR HEARTS AND MINDS IN
IN CONSIDERED COMING ON THIS
ENDEAVOR- DOCTOR WAS APPRECIATE
YOU JOINING- IT IS A CO AUTHOR.
IF WE'RE GOING TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT OUR FORCE WE NEED TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN. AND WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN'T ACTUALLY
GET OUT THERE WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THIS COMPACT. THAT OUR
STATE SIGNED. US NOT TOO OFTEN
I THINK THE GOVERNOR FOR
SOMETHING HE'S DONE- BUT THIS
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WE NEED TO ACTUALLY
BE ABLE TO GET GROUPS ON THE
GROUND TO GET THIS DONE. SLASH
YOU ALL THE- JOINT ON AND GET
THIS. AUSTIN TO HIS DESK. THANK
YOU MISFIRED ARTISTS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I THINK. A MATHIS
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORIDA ON THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I DON'T FOURTEEN AB
TWO SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VIRUS THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THREE PER TRIP
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THREE OF US I RIVERSIDE FLORA.
FLORA I'D CHAU CHAU AYE
FRIEDMAN. GARCIA MATHIS- MATHIS
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO G. I.'S
TERRITORY HI SO YOUR JULY STONE.
STONE NOW WOULD WOOD I. EIGHT
ONE KANNAPOLIS OUT THANK YOU
OKAY BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
COMMITTEE A MEMBER BUT PLEASE
GO AHEAD MR TELLING GET READY
BUT BEFORE WE MOVE ON- WE HAVE
FORTY MINUTES LEFT IN THIS ROOM
I'M GOING TO TRY TO QUICKLY GO
THROUGH FIVE BILLS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- BUT BEFORE I
DO THAT I'D LIKE A MOTION TO.
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE RULES.
THIS CASE OF SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS THAT THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE RULES BE
ADOPTED MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVAS
FIVE FLORA. FLORA I CHAU CHAU
AYE GARCIA. GARCIA HI FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I SAY ARE CHAU FAIR
ALL RIGHT STONE. STONE I WOULD.
WOULD I ELEVEN ZERO THANK YOU-
WE HAVE THREE BILLS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR OKAY. THANK
YOU SECRETARY CAME PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ON THE CONSENT TO
PASS WITH CONTENT
RECOMMENDATION MEMBERS RIVAS HI
RIVERSIDE FLORA. CHARLES HI
CHARLES I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE
GARCIA GARCIA I. MATHIS. MATHIS
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI. THEY ARE TELL.
THIRTY FIVE STONE. STONE I
WOULD WOOD I. NINE ZERO. AN
EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS%
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THAT WAS ITEM ONE AB TEN EIGHTY
SIX BY IGOR CURRY DO PASSES
AMENDED REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THREE OF US I
RIVERSIDE FLORIDA. CHAU HI CHAU
AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I'D
GARCIA GARCIA HI MATHIS MATHIS
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI. THEY ARE THOROUGH
SAY OUR TO OUR AYE STONE. STONE
I WOULD WOULD I NINE ZERO THANK
YOU THAT BILL IS OUT OF NEXT UP
WE HAVE AB SIX NINETY SEVEN HI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHILD PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THEM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS EIGHTY SIX
NINETY SEVEN WOULD CREATE A
PROGRAM FOR THE STATE TO PLAN
MANAGE AND IMPLEMENT FOREST
RESTORATION PROJECT ON U. S.
FOREST SERVICE LANDS. THROUGH
AN EXPANDED AND FORMALIZED GOOD
NEIGHBOR AUTHORITY TNA
WILDFIRES ARE CONTINUING
GROWING PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA
THE FREQUENCY SIZE AND
INTENSITY OF THE WILDFIRES IS
INCREASING EVERY YEAR IN FACT
THE TOP SEVENTH LARGEST
WILDFIRES HAVE ALL OCCURRED
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AND
FIVE OF THE TOP SIX ACCORDING
TWENTY TWENTY ALONE WHICH
RESULTED IN MORE THAN FOUR
POINT ONE MILLION ACRES BURNED.
MANY MAJOR FOUGHT A WILDFIRE
START ON THE 57% OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOREST LANDS OWNED
AND MANAGED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND THEN SPREAD TO
AND DAMAGE COMMUNITY SO
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE IN TWENTY
TWENTY OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ACRES BURNED ON FEDERAL
LAND IN CALIFORNIA. IT IS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
WORK TOGETHER TO ADDRESS OF
COURSE HEALTH AND REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISK. JNA IS A FEDERAL
AUTHORITY ALLOWING STATES TO
CONTRIBUTE FUNDING AND STAFFING
TO ADVANCE FOREST AND WATERSHED
RESTORATION ON FOREST SERVICE
LANDS- EIGHTY SIX NINETY SEVEN
FORMALIZES AND EXPANDS TO DNA
IN CALIFORNIA THE BILL
BASICALLY ESTABLISHES
PRIORITIES FOR WHICH TYPES OF
PROJECTS SHOULD BE FUNDED AND
LIST ELIGIBLE ACTIVITIES IT
PROVIDES GREATER DETAIL FOR THE
ELIGIBLE ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
ALLOWING STATE WORKERS TO HELP
PREPARE I NEED TO AND SEE WHAT
DOCUMENTS AND ENGAGE IN PROJECT
PLANNING LIKE THE PREPARATION
OF RESOURCE SURVEYS ANALYSES
AND REPORTS THESE ARE CURRENTLY
ACTIVITIES NOT SPECIFICALLY
AUTHORIZED IN STATUTE. AND BY
FORMALIZING THE DNA SB SIX
NINETY SEVEN WOULD ACCELERATE
THE PACE AND SCALE OF
ECONOMICALLY- PLEASE STOP
ECOLOGICALLY BASED TO FORCE
MANAGEMENT AND HOPEFULLY REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISKS IN CALIFORNIA I
HAVE BY ELIZABETH CALIFORNIA
FORSBERG ON BEHALF OF MY
SPONSOR CALLED THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY READY TO TESTIFY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAN WE'VE HAVE THE-
FIRST WITNESS. I DON'T. THINK
YOU'RE A MEMBER. MY NAME IS
WORKFORCE BURKE AND I NEED TO
TRACK OUR POLICY COMMISSION
CONDUCT. ONE THREE EIGHTY SIX
NINETY FIVE. L. RESTORATION
NEEDS CAN WE INCREASE GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF CALIFORNIANS
BALLPARK PROBLEMS ONE KEY THEIR
YOUR EFFICIENT WE HAVE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO ACTIVE
RESTORING. FORESTS AND
LANDSCAPES YEAH. CALIFORNIA BUT
THE DOCTOR COMPANY HAVE THAT
ALL MALE APPROACHED YOU FOR OUR
THAT KIND OF ALL OWNERSHIP FOR
CALIFORNIA. INCLUDING STATE
PRIVATE FEDERAL GRANTS AND
EIGHTY SIX NINETY SEVEN OF THE
BY THE COLLECTIVE. WILDFIRES
DON'T BOTHER JURISDICTIONAL
BOUNDARIES. THE BILL WILL
EXPAND ORDINATION BETWEEN THE
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
HELP PROTECT COMMUNITIES AND
RESTORE. WATERSHEDS ACROSS ALL
CALIFORNIA. NOT THAT I DIDN'T
FOR THE GOVERNMENT AND TO WORK
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS FOR OUT
CONGRESS PEOPLE WHO TYPICALLY
NEIGHBORS AND TO THE FOURTEEN
PARKER. OPTIMIZING THE I
THOUGHT GOVERNMENT FIND
AGREEMENT WITH A LABEL TO SHOW
BONDS WITH STOCKS AND OTHER.
ACROSS YOUR BOUNDARIES. EIGHTY
SIX SEVEN EXPAND THE GOOD
NEIGHBOR AUTHORITY HELP ALONG
YOU TO FOLLOW PROGRAM. AND
HELPING BALK AT PEOPLE BECAUSE-
WITH BOTH. PLAN AND
IMPLEMENTATION ON NASH FOREST
LAND. THE BILL ALL HOW MANY
PEOPLE OF WHISKEY GO CA REPORTS
PARTY. ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND
RESOURCE ON MY THINK PROVIDE
GREATER ACCOUNT ON THE BACK.
PERSPECTIVE WILDFIRES GOING.
ONE OF APPLE'S MARKET REFORMS
PARTNERSHIP FOR THE PARTNERS
ARE WORKING COOPERATIVELY TO
PLAN FINANCE THE DEADLINE FOR
STRUCTURATION ACROSS. TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
ACRES. SHARKS SHARKS CALIFORNIA
PORTS CRITICAL WITH THE WITH OF
LOS. WE GREATLY IT MY CAL
LEADERSHIP THE ISSUE AND WAS
QUESTIONS TO. THANK YOU. NEXT I
MOVED TO COMMENT ANYONE IN THE
ROOM. SCENE IT ANYWAY AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION.
THERE IS NONE MODERATOR KEY
PLEASE THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE ALREADY IN THE COMIC
YOU PLEASE STAY. IF YOU HAVE
NOT QUEUED UP IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX NINE SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND ONE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CREDIT MEMBERS GREG COOK
REPRESENTING THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY IN
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU. ONE
ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF HIS MARK FENSTER
MAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
AND THE WATERSHED RESEARCH AND
TRAINING CENTER IN SUPPORT. ONE
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS VERONICA
BY THE ACCOMPLICE ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
BEAUTIFUL NONPROFIT IN LOS
ANGELES. BUDGET SPAIN AND POWER
PROGRAM- PLEASE- CASE- VOTE YES
ON THE- SHE- ONE ONE FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JERRY MEMBERS JULIA
HALL- WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE OKAY ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WE DO HAVE ONE COMMENT
THAT PROMPTED. ONE MOMENT WHILE
WE COULD GATHER THE MY NUMBER.
THE MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE
SOMEONE ON THE LINE. WE DO HAVE
TWO PARTIES IN THE COMMENTS Q.
RIGHT NOW MY ONE EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M YES HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KIM DELFINO
REPRESENTING- CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY AND DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SIX NINETY SEVEN. NINE ONE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JERRY THIS MEMBER
CHRIS ROBERT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION PERCENT
LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSOR FOR THE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
HAVING SINCE BEFORE THE BILL
WAS INTRODUCED- WE ARE EITHER
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSE WE HAVE A
CONCERNS POSITION- WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE. SO G. IN A PROJECT
PROJECTS AND WE'RE IN GREAT
SUPPORT OF THE INTENT BEHIND
THIS BILL WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT ABOUT LANGUAGE IN SECTION
FORTY EIGHT TWELVE EIGHTY WHICH
PRIORITIZES CERTAIN TYPES OF G.
ANY PRODUCTS OVER OTHER
PROJECTS. ALTHOUGH CALPERS THE
COURTS DETECTED PROJECTS THAT
ARE LISTED IN THIS SECTION WE
BELIEVE THAT PRIORITIZING
SPECIFIC PROJECTS THE BILL WILL
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THE
STATE AND ITS PARTNERS TO
COMPLETE MUCH NEEDED G. ANY
PROJECTS THAT DON'T MEET THE
CRITERIA LISTED IN THE BILL.
AND HERE'S THE UP FOR EXAMPLE
IMPORTANT GILBERT PROJECTS
EITHER ELIGIBLE UNDER FEDERAL
JEANNIE GUIDELINES AND THEY
WOULD BE DE PRIORITIZED BASED
ON THE LANGUAGE IN THAT SECTION
LIKEWISE CALIFORNIA COURT THE
INCREASED USE OF PRESCRIBED
FIRE AND THAT CONDITION. THE
CURRENT CONDITION OF FEDERAL
LANDS IN MANY PARTS OF THE
STATE MAKE THE USE OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE INPRACTICAL
SOMETIMES IN POTENTIALLY UNSAFE
THEY'RE REQUIRING OTHER TIGHT A
FUEL REDUCTION STRATEGIES IS
IMPORTANT PRIORITIZING A
PRESCRIPTIVE REQUIREMENTS MAKE
IT MORE DIFFICULT TO COMPLETE-
IMPORTANT SKILL REDUCTION
PROJECTS THROUGH THE J. G.
EMAIL HER GROUNDSTROKES- PLEASE
YES PLEASE. WE JUST NEEDED YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND. AND
POSITION. THANK YOU- IS THERE
ARE ANY OTHERS THE QUEUE. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. THANK YOU MANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS- MISTER
CHOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
ASK FOR ADULTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OF WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I DON'T FIFTEEN
EIGHTY SIX NINETY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAU TO PASS
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RIVAS I
RIVERSIDE FLORIDA. LARA NO
CHILD CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS NO MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI. THEY
ARE JONES HI SAY ARE TO AYE
STONE STONE I WOULD. WOULD I.
EIGHT TWO THANK YOU THAT BILL
IS OUT I'M NEXT IS AB SIX FORTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
NUMBER YOU'RE READY. STATE
INSURANCE MEMBERS- IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'LL BE VERY
BRIEF THIS IS AN ON A BUS FIRE
PREVENTION BILL THAT MAKES
VARIOUS CHANGES TO SUPPORT
CULTURAL PRESCRIBE HIGHER FIRE
AND TO HELP ENCOURAGE HOME
HARDENING. AND I'D LIKE TO JUST
THANK YOUR STAFF PARTICULARLY
MICHAEL GERARD FOR HIS WORK ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU I'M NEXT
WE HAVE A WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION. FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AND THE
SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA.
AGAIN MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
BLESSED ONES BURKE WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY SIX
FORTY JAIL. I'M ABOUT FIVE
VENTURE MAKING CHANGE TOOK FAN
WHICH FIRE CULTURAL BURNING A
COURT WHILE GROUPS REDUCTION.
IN PARTICULAR EIGHTY THREE
FORTY TWO WOULD INCREASE. BY
AND WOULD MAKE TAKEN COURT
STEPS TO. CULTURAL IN HELL. BUT
A CONTROLLED LIAISON AT THE-
FOR STREET FIGHTER. SO WHAT
PART AND ENGAGEMENT OF NATIVE
AMERICANS. APPLETON AND
CULTURAL PRACTITIONERS FOR
STOPPING THAT PRIVATE PROPERTY.
THE OFF TOPIC WHICH FIVE BY
TRAINING CALIFORNIA. THE
COMPLETE WORKS OF ART AS ABOUT
IS CORRECT TRAINING CHANGES
WHICH BY OUT FOR MANAGE
IMPLEMENTING TREATMENT COURT
AND LANDSCAPE A DOCTOR. I THINK
THE JUST PROVIDE A COOPER BURKE
MADOFF MORE PROPERTY LOCAL THE
BILL FROM COUNTRY CAPACITY IN
THE RIGHT PLACES. WE THIS CAR
OUR TRAINING PRODUCT SB SIX
FORTY YEARS. DON'T ATTRACT
FARMS SUPPORT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
AND SCALE COOPER MODEL THE
STATE. FINALLY COULD OF THE
BECAUSE COMMITTEE WILDFIRE
REDUCTION IN SIX ONE TWO TO THE
A LOT OF ITS MODEL TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES NO AND REDUCE THEIR
ABOUT. CHURNING OUT WELFARE
GRANTS. AND IMPROVE OUR
PREVENTION ACTION IT CAN TAKE.
I DON'T REMEMBER FRIEDMAN HAS
WHAT IT NUMBER PEOPLE INVOLVED
YOURSELF AND WE EIGHTY TWENTY
TWO WILL BUILT ON A CAR SHE HAD
MADE THIS THE CRITICAL FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES ACROSS.
THE STATE. I REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
MOVE TO PUT COMMENT IN THE ROOM
C. NINE ANYWAY AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION FOR OUR NON-
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR SUPPORTER OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AGAIN MY COMMANDED
ONE AND THEN THEY OFFER SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. WE WILL GO TO A
LINE OF ONE OLD THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS NOEL CREAMERS
WITH WINE INSTITUTE IN COURT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS NOW THEY KNOCKED ON
BEHALF OF THE REDWOODS LEAGUE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO
THE LINE OF ONE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING
CARE AND MEMBERS REAP THE
MONSTER TO NOT A WITH THE TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF ONE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR LARA
TABLE AND SEAT REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO
THE LINE OF EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI LAUREN COME
WITH THEIR CLOTHES CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANKS OF A LINE OF ONE EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KIM DELFINO BEHALF OF DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE AND CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO ON A ONE FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MARK
ANSWER MAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
AND WATERSHED RESEARCH AND
TRAINING CENTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND AS A REMINDER IT
IS ONE ZERO FOR ANY SUPPORT OR%
OPPOSITION. WHEN ACTUAL ONE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RON BREWER WITH
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON HERE
IN SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY SIX
FORTY TWO. THANK YOUNG MEXICO
LINE OF ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HEY ONE OF THEM
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT AMONG
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE
FURTHER IN Q. IT THIS TIME
CREATE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. MR SAY OCTOBER TENTH I
NOTICE IN THIS THERE'S A LOT
OF- LIKE WE JUST FOR ONE
INSTANCE THIS TRAINING FACILITY
FOR PRESCRIBED BURNS. WHAT DOES
THAT ENTAIL AND HOW MUCH COST
IS RELATED TO THAT AND- HOW DO
WE ENSURE THAT THAT'S EFFECTIVE
BECAUSE- IN THE FIRE SERVICE WE
ARE EXTENSIVELY TRAINED FOR
THAT PURPOSE AND WE DON'T
REALLY NEED A TRAINING FACILITY
FOR THAT. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I DON'T HAVE. AN
ESTIMATE FOR YOU AT THIS MOMENT
ABOUT COST BUT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH CAL
FIRE ON THIS BILL AND THE IDEA
WITH THIS IS TO HELP. TRAIN THE
INDIGENOUS- THE PEOPLE WILL BE
WORKING ON THE INDIGENOUS BURNS
UP TO HAVE TO HAVE MORE
EXPERIENCE DOING THIS OF THAT
AS THEY WORK ALONGSIDE
ALONGSIDE THEIR PARTNERS A CALL
FIRE. WILL BE MORE EXPERIENCED-
PEOPLE OUT THERE TO HELP
FACILITATE ALL OF THIS AS WELL
AS TO- WORK ON- A PRESCRIBED
FIRE BURN BOSS CURRICULUM THAT
CAN ALSO BE RUN THROUGH THESE
PROGRAMS SO THAT. THE PEOPLE
WHO. WE CAN EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF EXPERIENCED AND QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS WHO RIGHT NOW WE'RE
DOING THIS WORK BUT ONE OF THE
BARRIERS AND OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRAINED AND EXPERIENCED RIGHT.
SO WE DO HAVE QUALIFIED BOSS
AND BURN FOR BURN BOSSES AND WE
HAVE PROGRAMS FOR THAT
EXTENSIVELY IN THE STATE THE C.
STC. SO. I GUESS I AM A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE- AMOUNT OF
COSTS FOR. SOMETHING THAT WE
KIND OF DON'T HAVE A GRASP ON
ON WHAT IT IS EXACTLY THAT
WE'RE WE'RE DOING- AS FAR AS
ITS EFFECTIVENESS. AND
WILDFIRES. JUST TO CLARIFY- ONE
WE WERE TRYING TO EXPLORE WHY.
THERE WERE NOT MORE BURNS IN
AREAS THAT WOULD THAT COULD USE
THE BURNS THIS HAD CONSTANTLY
COME UP AS A ONE OF THE REASONS
AND ONE OF THE BARRIERS WAS NOT
HAVING ENOUGH EXPERIENCE
PERSONNEL- BOTH WITH THE BERM
BOSSES AND OTHERWISE. SO THIS
WAS AN ATTEMPT TO. CREATE JOBS
FOR ONE THING AS WELL AS
TRAINING PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
DO THIS AND WE WILL WORK
CONTINUE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
CAL FIRE. AND THE REST OF THE
FIRE COMMUNITY- AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS RIGHT THERE'S
ONLY A FEW AGENCIES ARE
ACTUALLY QUALIFIED HAVE
QUALIFYING GRANDPA'S FOLKS. AND
IN THOSE AGENCIES THEMSELVES
ARE ARE. NOT- I MEAN. IF YOU'RE
ABOUT DOING EXCESSIVE BURNING
IS A Q. AND D. PERMITS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORIDA. YEAH
IT IS VERY SHORT WILL JUST GO.
CALL THOMAS I MEAN I DO THINK
ON THE- SIDE. COMING OUT OF THE
TRIAL WORLD USED TO DO WITH THE-
GO ALL THE TIME JUST ON PAPERS
AND THEY HAVE A DISTRICT. OF
INNOVATION- THIS WELL YEAH ONE
OF THE BIGGEST WORLD WAS
WONDERING YOU SIGN UP FOR PARK
TO GO DO THAT SO. I WAS HERE
THAT HE MAY WHEN WE TALK YOU TO
JUST PEOPLE ABOUT DOING YOUR
OWN THE FIRE ON THE GROUND IN
CONTROL OVER WITHIN THEIR
BEFORE SYSTEM THING HAPPENED
TOLD I THINK. WE NEED TO ON
OBVIOUSLY- ARTISTS WITH THE BUT
I. BECAUSE I THINK THAT THAT
HAS A LOT OF POTENTIAL AND- I
AM EXCITED ABOUT THE LEAST THE
CONVERSATIONS. OF CONTROLLED
BURNS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A
HUGE HUGE- PART OF OUR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND I WILL SAY THAT THIS
IS. AN ONGOING CONVERSATION
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THE
LAST TIME THAT THE BILLBE
HEARD AS THE FIRST HEARING. AND
I REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU.
AND THOSE IN THE LEGISLATURE
THAT HAVE THIS ON THE GROUND
EXPERIENCE AS WE CONTINUE TO
REFINE THE BILL AND WE'RE
ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO A TO CHANGES
AS WE MOVE FORWARD BUT THE
GOAL. HERE REALLY IS TO REMOVE
THE BARRIERS TO ALLOW. MORE OF
A CULTURAL AND MORE BURNS IN
PLACES THAT NEED IT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT. YES THANK YOU FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD OF LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF
YOU'LL HAVE ME. I THINK. THE
MORE WE CAN DO- TO PROMOTE. OF
CONTROLLED BURNS- AND THIS IS
JUST A PIECE OF THE PUZZLE I
RECOGNIZE AND THERE ARE A LOT
OF PIECES IT'S A VERY BIG
PUZZLE BUT- THAT'S A STEP IN
RIGHT DIRECTION AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS THANK YOU. COURSE WOULD BE
PROUD TO ADD YOU. THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THIS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
TO ALLOW US TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
WE HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE SECONDED. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA'S THE
MOTION. IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ITEM SIXTEEN
EIGHTY SIX FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN DO PASS
AND REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS RIVAS. I
RIVERSIDE FLORA. FLORA I'D
CHAU. CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN HI.
FRIEDMAN GARCIA. GARCIA I
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI. THEY
ARE TOUGH NOT. FAIR CHAU NUMBER.
STONE STONE I WOULD WOOD I.
NINE ZERO. K. THAT BILL IS OUT
I'M NEXT WE HAVE A J. R. FOR
ASSEMBLY KRISTIN GARCIA. OKAY
SO YOU HAVE. I LOS AND THIS
AGER URGENT THE VITA MINISTRY
TO ACT IMMEDIATELY TO READ THE
COME. WHICH ADDRESS THE GLOBE.
WELL I CONCERNED PLASTIC. AND
TO AND FIVE AND- YOU THEY NAY
STATES IS THE ONLY INDUSTRY
COUNTRY THAT HAS BILL TO MODIFY.
THIS VITAL MORE ENVIRONMENT
AGREEMNT THAT PROTECTS YOU
FELT IN FROM AND COUNTRIES THAT
X. AND PLACE- AND THAT THOSE
AND CANNOT MY- RESPECTFUL ASK
FOR NAY VOTE. THANK YOU. WHO DO
WE HAVE OF. AND SOME. MODERATOR
ARE THERE NEW OKAY THANKS. GO
AHEAD IS OPEN- THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBER I'M
HI FEDERAL IN THE NOT SEARCH
COUNCIL NONPROFIT ABBOTT FOR
ECONOMY HERE IN SUPPORT. I WILL
ALSO NOTE THAT I NOT SURE OF
THERE MIGHT BE ON THE OR AND
COULD RECYCLING YOUR DOCTOR A
POLICY RECORD. WHAT THE
UNANIMOUS SEVEN BECAUSE THEY A
VOTE REQUEST THAT CAN
ENCOURAGED FEDERAL TO THE BOB
OKAY. WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT H.
THANK ARE FOR WILL DO. AB ARE
FORMAL BY THE MINISTER TO COULD
RATIFY THE BASEL CONVENTION
AGREEMENT WITHIN THE- FACTOR
IMPROPERLY RIGHT. THE INTERNET
BAR AND- OF PLASTIC AND- WASTE
DUMP ON CAN THAT. DO HAVE A
CAPACITY TO PROP MAN THE MATURE.
EIGHT ZERO FOUR NOT THE FIRST
TIME IS HAS BEEN DISCUSSED THE
LEAD TO. AND NINETEEN FOUNDER
HOUSE THE AUTHOR AT R. FOR
SEVEN. WHICH WOULD ALSO. BATTED
CAL DEVOID SINCE A OF JOINT
ABOUT THE- THAT IT STILL HAS
NOT BEEN ROUTED. WE HOPE THIS
RESOLUTION WILL ENCOURAGE THE
NOTED. TO FINALLY RATIFY. THE
BASEL CONVENTION AGREEMENT. AND
IT IS MORE NOW THAN. ON JANUARY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ABOUT
THE CONVENTION AGREEMENT WENT
INTO EFFECT THE PLACE TRADE
CONTROLS ON PLASTIC WASTE. FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT
POTENTIAL U. S. TRADING
PARTNERS. THESE RULES REQUIRE
THE PLASTIC WASTE WHICH IS NOT
SORTED AND CLEANED. TO SINGLE
POLYMERIC AND WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT CONTAMINATION WILL
FALL WITHIN. THE ANNEXED TO OF
THE AGREEMENT AND WILL ONLY BE
ALLOWED FOR EXPORT TO OTHER
BASEL PARTIES WHEN THERE ARE
SHORTAGES OF ENVIRONMENTALLY
SOUND MANAGEMENT. AND ONLY IF
THE RECIPIENT BY THE PARTY IS
FIRST NOTIFIED BY THE EXPORTING
COUNTRY. AND RECEIVE THEIR
CONSENT. AB IMPORTANT. IS THAT
THE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
THOUSAND PARTY FOR NOT BE A TO
LEAGUE RECEIVE HIS CLASS WAYS
FROM THE U. S. AT ALL DUE TO
THE FACT THAT WE NOT PARTY TO
THE- AND THIS IS NOW BEEN A
CASE. FOR FIFTH MONTH.
REPUBLICAN VERY. ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PLASTIC.
THAT ON THE- THIS IS TO MINUTES.
I'M YOU'VE- GOT HERE WE RESPECT
WHERE. YOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WITH SINCE THE- DO WE HAVE
ANOTHER. YEAH THIS IS FOR BY
TRIED JUNIOR IS LIKELY
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST NONPROFIT
REFLECT OPERATE. AND DOWN
COUNTY SUPER SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF A AJ ARE FOR. THANK
YOU. ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
OKAY WELL OPEN UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT OF ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM SCENE NINE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION NO ONE OF
OUR MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. YOU ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
WELL THE FIRST LINE OF SIXTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS BONNIE BEEN ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT OF HR FOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BACK TO WILL AND ONE
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU HAVE NEW MANAGER MEMBERS
JIM JUST A WITH AMERICAN CAB
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL- IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE A ONE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS PERSONAL YOU DON'T COME
OF THE PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL AND LIKE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO OF ONE TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SH GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
FEARING AGAIN EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR A DAY ARE FOR- SHE- THANK
YOU. THANK MEXICO LINE OF
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS IS
MICHAEL WITH THE AND MAKE LEON
OF THE SERVICES AND SUPPORT OF
JET A. ARE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ABOUT OF ONE EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE EIGHT ONE EIGHTY
I'M ONE. TWO YOUR LINE IS A-
THANK YOU. L. SATTLER LIKE
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS. BY
THANK YOU X. OF A LINE OF ONE
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BECAUSE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND SUPPORTING EACH
YEAR FOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AS A REMINDER IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORE POSSIBLE REPORTS RECOVERY
COALITION A CALIFORNIA COURT.
THANK YOU AND MADAM CHAIR THAT
WAS OUR LAST ONE IN Q. THANK
YOU MISTER SHE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE SECOND AND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLORIDA- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ITEM
SEVENTEEN AJ ARE FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
THE MOTION IS THAT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED. MEMBERS
RIVAS I RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA
I'D CHAU CHAU FIVE THREE AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA
MATHIS MATHIS I MCCARTY MCCARTY
I'M A. THERE ARE TWO NOT VOTING.
THIRTEEN VOTING STONE. STONE I
WOULD. WOOD I. NINE ZERO. THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT MADAM I THINK WE GOT OF
YOU BILLS UP STARTING AB. FIVE
EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU I WANT TO
START BY THANKING ELIZABETH FOR
HER WORK ON THIS ANALYSIS AB
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE COORDINATE
STATE EFFORTS TO HELP URBAN AND
RURAL COMMUNITIES COMBAT
EXTREME HEAT. BY CREATING THE
EXTREME HEAT IN COMMUNITY
RESILIENCY PROGRAM UNDER THE
COP GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH THE BILL.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MANAGER. ANYONE
ELSE'S SUPPORT. TO WITNESSES
TWO MINUTES EACH IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GOING
TO BE K. WHAT I'M A POLICY NOT
WITH CONSULTANTS REQUIRED
RESULTS. NONPROFIT GROUP BASED
IN BUILDING CALL. TO CHECK A
CLIMATE- THANK YOU FOR THE TO
ABOUT AB FIVE BECAUSE YOU'RE
HEAT AND CAN RESULT THAT.
BEFORE I BEGAN I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU MEMBER WE'VE US FOR
YOUR LEADER ON THIS ISSUE AND
YOUR STUFF FOR ALL THE ARE WORK
DONE THIS. I'D LIKE TO ADD
THREE KEY POINTS FOR. HE A BIG
PROBLEM. ON IS HE FROM YOUR- IN
ATTIC. SO COULD NOT REALLY BARE
BOMBER ARE BLOCKING CAN YOU
FACE. WHEN IT COMES THE FURTHER.
NO AS EXTREME. THE SECOND AB
HARD BY ADDRESS THE GROWING
PROBLEM. REQUIRE COURT OF WORK
FOR MORE THAN A DOZEN AID IS
CURRENTLY WORKING IN SILO.
SOMETHING THAT IS KERN LACKING
AND THE LIMITED FUNDING TO THE
FISH SPENT. IT OF THE FENCE A
GOOD GUY BILL. AB TWENTY FIVE
ALSO ESTABLISHES A FOR THAT WE
BE A GAME TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND COMMUNITY OR- AND AT. TO
ADDRESS EXTREME HEAT- AFTER YOU
AB EIGHT THE TO PROTECT ALL CAL.
THE SPECIAL BLACK AND BROWN I'M
OTHER PHONE TO FOR THE INCREASE
THREAT OF EXTREME HEAT. AB
HARVEY WILL HELP THE LIVES
AMPLUG BIG. IN THE STATE
UPWARDS TO USINESS TO CLIMATE
CHANGE FOR THEIR AND FUTURE. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. WE APPRECIATE THAT- NEXT
UP IN SUPPORT WE HAVE- J. R.
THE SHOW ALSO. YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- J. R. D. SHADES
THOUGH- PROFESSOR HERE AT UCLA
AND DIRECTOR OF THE LOS
CONTENDER FOR INNOVATION- WE'VE
UNDERTAKEN A STATEWIDE POLICY
GAP ASSESSMENT- REGULATIONS
WITH RESPECT TO EXTREME HEAT
EXPOSURE- AND I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT BECAUSE THE CLIMATE
CHANGE CALIFORNIANS ARE GONNA
EXPERIENCE INCREASES IN AVERAGE
EXTREME HEAT AND MORE EXTREME
HEAT DAYS- A GROWING BODY OF
LITERATURE AND RESEARCH. TELLS
US THAT THIS IS IMPACTING OUR
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH- WE
KNOW NOW THAT STUDENTS LEARN
LAST WHEN EXPOSED TO EXTREME
HEAT WORKERS HAVE MORE
ACCIDENTS. CLIMATE EXPOSED THAT
IS OUTDOOR WORKERS EARN LESS
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS PAY MORE TO
COOL THEIR HOMES. CALIFORNIA
WILL INCREASINGLY NEED TO
REGULATE HEAT EXPOSURE AND
AVOID THESE MOUNTING HEALTH.
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL DAMAGE.
THANK YOU KNOW WE FOUND THE
RESULT OF OUR REVIEW IS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY NO CENTRAL
AUTHORITY THAT PROVIDES
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. STRATEGIC
FUNDING OR COORDINATION TO
SISTER AGENCIES TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES OF HEAT AND HEAT
EXPOSURE- AS WE MENTIONED HE
FOR D. OVER- EXTREME HEAT IS
FRAGMENTED- ACROSS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AMONG
OTHERS- THIS STATE VERY MUCH
NEED A SINGLE AUTHORITY WHICH
WOULD. SUPPORT THE SISTER
AGENCIES BUT THE RESEARCH ON
THE IMPACT OF EXTREME HEAT
EXPOSURE SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT. AND DESIGN HE-
REDUCTION POLICY. WITH ANYTHING
AGENCIES. LEVER THE EXACTLY
BRANCH AUTHORITY TO ENSURE
INTER AGENCY COORDINATION. AND
THEN PROMOTE EDUCATION ACROSS
DIFFERENT- A DIFFERENT-
EXPOSURE DOMAINS LIKE AT WORK
AT HOME AT SCHOOL ASSISTED
LIVING FACILITIES CARE DAYCARE
FACILITIES SCHOOLS THINGS LIKE
THAT. AND ADMINISTER FUNDING
FOR UNIQUE HEAT RISK REDUCTION
INVESTMENT THAT SHOULD OR
CANNOT BE CHANNEL TO A SISTER
AGENCY- FUNDING PATHWAYS THANK
YOU JEFF WE CAN HAVE YOU FINISH
UP YOUR THOUGHT. SO THE LAST
THING I'LL JUST POINT OUT IS
THAT THERE'S IS CURRENTLY NOTE
STATE INVESTMENT PROGRAM HIS
PRIMARY OBJECTIVE IN EXTREME
HEAT RISK REDUCTION- EXTREME
HEAT IS CURRENTLY NOT INCLUDED
IN CALAVERAS SCREEN- WHICH AND
SO AS A RESULT IS NOT- GUIDING
INVESTMENTS TOWARDS OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
SANDERS ONO- OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR-
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT ON THE
LINE. ANY OPPOSITION. HEARING
NONE I LOVE ALL MY YES MEMBERS
YES MA'AM I'M SORRY. OKAY IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. OVERALL THE
FIRST LINE OF ONE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NORTH
AMERICA LPG IMPROPRIETIES BY
THE FACT THAT THE- THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF ONE SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON JACK ANDERSON WITH
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE A
ONE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON- MADAM
CHAIR RECALL MASTRODONATO WITH
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
INTRODUCING THE BILL AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE CONCEPT
WORKING WITH MR CLERVAUX. AND
LET'S GET COLD THERE TO- TO-
OPTICS SOME OF THE LANGUAGE OR
ADDRESS SOME OF OUR ISSUES BUT-
ARE STRONGLY SUPPORTING MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
A ONE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU CAN LOOK DOWN
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WILL GO ON A ONE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM DELFINO ON
BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT OF A
LINE OF ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NATALIE MAC THE
BEHALF OF COMMUNITY NATURE
CONNECTION IN CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALEX BREGMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASPHALT PAVEMENT
ASSOCIATION WE CONTACTED
DOCTORS OFFICE ABOUT SOME
CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO COOL
PAVEMENTS- THERE'S AN
UNFORESEEN CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
HAPPENED HERE FOR UC BERKELEY
UC DAVIS AND STANFORD HAVE ALL
DEMONSTRATED. THAT COOL
PAVEMENT CAN ACTUALLY INCREASE
THE HEAT- FILL THAT IN
BUILDINGS GETTING AN INCREASE
GHG EMISSIONS SO WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE OFFERED OFFICEJET
TRYING TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON STERN
MEMBERS INTO BECAUSE THERE WAS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT I
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
THE LINE OF EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI LAUREN COLUMN
WITH THEIR COOK CALIFORNIA CON
IN SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I A
REMINDER IT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. MEXICO LINE A ONE
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH ONE DOLLAR FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT OF AB I
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
OF A LINE OF ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MARIN
DATELINE CAN'T REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU IN
MEXICO LINE A ONE NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
LYNN SOLAR FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES
CENTER FOR HEALTHY CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS IN SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU AND
THAT WAS OUR LAST LINE IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS MISTER MATHIS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- AS A IRAQI WAR VETERAN
WHO'S BEEN IN EXTREME HEAT TO
THE POINT WHERE YOUR FOOD SMELL
ON THE SIDEWALK- IN
REPRESENTING SOME OF THE
HOTTEST AREAS IN THE STATE WITH
THAT VALLEY. I REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
HERE AND WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
THIS A BIPARTISAN BILL BY JOINT
OFFERING IT WITH YOU- THE
EXTREME HEAT IS EX. EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT- IN WE SEE TOO MANY
ISSUES WITH THIS HAPENING
RECYCLING CENTERS AND OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE NEEDED AND
NECESSARY AND IT'S ABOUT TIME
THAT WE DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
IS THE STATE SO THANK YOU WHEN
I LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU
ON THIS THANK YOU AND I WELCOME
YOU AS A PARTNER ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
FROM THE COMMITTEE CAN
QUESTIONS. CNN MANAGER WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NAY VOTE. ABOUT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. ITEM
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE I THREE OF US. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS A REPROACH
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE
FLORA. FLORIDA VOTING CHAU.
CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE MATHIS
AYE MATHIS AYE MCCARTY. RT I
MURATSUCHI FOR A TO G. I. C. R.
JONES OF LADING CERTAIN
UPLOADING STONE. STONE I WOULD
WOULD I. NINE ZERO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MANAGER YOU KNOW
ONE MORE BILL AB. NINE SEVEN
SIX. THANK YOU AB NINE SEVENTY
SIX CREATES A STATEWIDE PILOT
PROGRAM MODELED FROM L. A.
COUNTY IS EMPOWER PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE GRANT FUNDING TO
NONPROFITS. THAT DELIVER
EXISTING GOVERNMENT COST SAVING
SERVICES AND RESOURCES TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF THE PHONE LINES I
DON'T THINK THERE WILL TO MAKE
IT. WE JUST WANT TO CONFIRM
THAT. HELLO READERS ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINES. SUPPORT
CORRUPT ADDITION ONE AND THEN.
ZERO WE DO HAVE TO IN Q. WILL
GO TO LINE A ONE NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NATALIE BIRDS ARE
A ON BEHALF OF THE LIBERTY
HEALTH FOUNDATION SALLY CAN
REDEEMER COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIP
LOS ANGELES NEIGHBORHOODS
MANTRAP THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS. COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR AND CLEAN THE
BEAUTIFUL ALL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. IN
OUR LIVES FINAL COME FROM LINE
OF EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FOR MORE INCOME WITH THE
ERROR CODE CALIFORNIA CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE HAVE NO ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU BRING ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE THIS COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. CNN EDITOR WHICH
LETS ME ASK FOR NAY VOTE. OF
SIXTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I
AM TWENTY AB NINE SEVENTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER THREE OF US
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS THREE OF US HI
RIVERSIDE FLORIDA OTHER FLOOR
NOT VOTING CHAU. CHAO II
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I'D GARCIA.
GARCIA I MATHIS. MATHIS NOT
VOTING MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I SAY ARE
TOUGH ENOUGH THEY ARE NOT
VOTING STONE. STONE I WOULD.
WOULD I. EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MANAGER THANK YOU WE
HAVE FOUR BILLS THAT ARE ON
CALL- WE'LL START WITH AB FIVE
FIFTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION SECRETARY CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
CURRENT VOTERS THREE TO ZERO
WITH. THE CHAIR VOTING I AM THE
VICE CHAIR. NOT VOTING ABSENT
MEMBERS CHILD WELL I GARCIA
GARCIA HI MATHIS. ON AB FIVE
FIFTY NINE ITEM TO. MATHIS
MATHIS NOT VOTING. MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO
GI WOULD. WHAT I. EIGHT ZERO
CAN I BILL IS OUT- NEXUS AB
TWENTY ONE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PROVIDERS
THREE TO THREE WHAT THE- VICE
CHAIR VOTING NOW ABSENT MEMBERS
RIVAS I RIVERSIDE CHAU. CHAU
NOT VOTING MCCARTY MCCARTY I
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI NOT
VOTING. WOOD WHAT I. SIX THREE
KANNAPOLIS OUT OF NEXT WAVE AB
EIGHT NINETY SIX. THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CARVANA'S THREE TO ZERO WITH
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NOT
VOTING. ABSENT MEMBERS RIVAS I
RIVERSIDE CHAU CHAU I MCCARTY.
THIRTY AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I SAY ARE CHAU. THEY
ARE TURNOUT VOTING WOULD WOULD
I'D THIS IS FOR H. ZERO. OKAY
THAT BILL IS OUT SORRY OKAY.
LAST BILL AB SIXTY SIX MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL- VOTERS FIVE ONE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I'D AND THE VICE
CHAIR NOT VOTING. ABSENT
MEMBERS MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I SAY OUR
THROW. SEARCH ARE NOT VOTING
WOULD. WOULD I. EIGHT ONE AND
THAT BILL IS OUT. MEETING
ADJOURNED THANK YOU SO MUCH-
SORRY YEAH YOU CAN YOU GET OUT
ON AFTER THE OUT ON AFTER. A
LOT OF THOSE KGO. THE IF
THERE'S A MEMBERS OF THE WHITE
HOUSE. OKAY SO WE HAVE SOME
MEMBERS THAT WERE TO ADD ON TO.
WHICH BILL. THE CONSENT OKAY
CONSENT CALENDAR. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. OF PER VOTE
NINE ZERO WITH THE
TROUBLESHOOTING I AFTER MEMBER
FLORA. LARA AYE MURATSUCHI ROAD
TO GI LEVIN ZERO. THAT'S MOTION
PASSES. OKAY AB. TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX. ONE WELL I ON ITEM SEVEN
AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX CURRENT
VOTE SIX TO ZERO WITH THE
TRAVELING I ADVISED HER VOTING
NOBODY NOT VOTING ABSENT
MEMBERS MCCARTY. MCCARTY IS
SERRA CHAU. WOOD I WOULD I.
EIGHT ZERO. CATERPILLARS OUT
NEXT IS. ON ITEM A AB EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE ABOUT NINE ZERO-
VOTING I'VE FIVE SURE I ABSENT
MEMBERS MCCARTY MCCARTY I WOULD
WOULD I LIVE IN ZERO. THE BILL
IS OUT. NINETEENTH. ONE NINE
ONE NINE AB EIGHT NINETEEN
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS GARCIA GARCIA I MCCARTY.
RIGHT MCCARTY AYE LEVIN. ZERO
WELL AB AND. ONE ITEM ONE A. B.
TEN EIGHTY SIX FOR ABOUT NINE
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
MARTUCCI WROTE TO GI. TEN ZERO.
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT. I THINK
WE'RE ALL SET THANK YOU. OKAY.